ON PUBLIC SAFETY. WELCOME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT OUR PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE ARE
LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS SENATE HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. WHEN
COMBINED WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MAKING
HISTORY JUSTIN'S ARMEL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WELL WE CONDUCT THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH. AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND REYES. TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC. THREE A MINUTE BREMER'S
THE PUBLIC TO THE BALCONY. AND
TO A HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE'LL
ALSO BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TESTIFIED TODAY. IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. THERE'S A PARTISAN
TOLL FREE NUMBER THEIR ASSIST
VOTE. IS POSTED ON OUR SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. BUT I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
TO YOU NOW IT IS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. PART CODE. THREE SIX.
FOUR EIGHT FIVE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO COMMENT MODERATE WILL
IDENTIFY IN. OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. YOU MEET THE DEVICE
YOU WERE WATCHING THE HEARING
ON PRIORITY GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS IS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAYBE LAG TIMES FOR SOME
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
USE OF THE NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES IN UNIT BUT WHEN
THERE CAN BE JUST TECHNOLOGICAL
DIFFICULTIES PLEASE BE RESPECT
ONE PATIENT BUT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. HE HEARD. WE WILL NOW
IN THE BILL HERE. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING- IN ADDITION TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE
WELCOME SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ON
THE ZOOM WILL BE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS LEVINE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA LET ME OPEN WITH
SOME COMMENTS AND THEN I WILL
ASK IF- CENTER MORE LOCKER
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS WHICH
I HOPECAN BE BRIEF. AND THEN
WE WILL TURN TO. WHAT UNDER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVE IN A CAR
IN CASE THEY WANT TO. BUT THEN-
WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST PANEL.
AND I WILL MENTION WHAT THE
PANELS ARE IN A MOMENT. SO I'M
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER I'M CHAIR
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AND AS I OPENED
THIS IS A HEARING ON THE SPREAD
OF COVERT NINETEEN IN OUR STATE
PRISONS. SPREAD THAT IS
THREATENING THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE NOT ONLY OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN HELD IN
OUR PRISONS BUT ALSO THE STAFF.
AND STAFF AND ALL CALIFORNIANS.
A VIRUS KNOWS NO BOUNDARIES ITS
RAPID SPREAD HAS NOW AFFECTED
INFECTED. THE MINIMUM OF FIVE
THOUSAND COURSE ROOTED IN
VICTORY INDIVIDUALS WITH OVER
ELEVEN HUNDRED IN SAN QUENTIN
ALONE ALONG WITH HUNDREDS OF
STAFF STAFF WHO DO NOT LIVE IN
PRISON FACILITIES BUT GO HOME
EVERY DAY. ACTUALLY SPREADING
THE VIRUS TO FAMILY FRIENDS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. AS OF TODAY.
THE REPORT THE DATA WE KNOW
FROM CCAR IS TWENTY TWO INMATES
HAVE DIED AS WELL AS TO MEMBERS
OF THE STAFF. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING RECORD NUMBERS OF
NEW CASES AND WE HAVE PULLED
BACK ONE PLANNED OPENING OF
BARS JAMS AND MORE. HOW MUCH OF
THE INCREASE IN CASES IS
RELATED TO THE UNCONTROLLED
SPREAD IN OUR PRISONS WHICH WE
KNOW IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITIES.
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS MONTH
LONG THIS IS THE GOVERNOR BUT
WE ASSN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAVE HELD REGULAR
NOON BRIEFING GUIDING ALL OF US
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF PHYSICAL
DISTANCING WEARING A SHORT
COVERING STAND WATCHING IN THE
NECESSITY TO DO WIDESPREAD
TESTING. WHAT WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES NOW. IS WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
LISTENING. WAS CDC ARE
MAINTAINING OR MANDATING THE
SAME PUBLIC HEALTH PROTOCOLS
THAT THE STATE ASKED OF THE
REST OF US. OUR STATE PRISONS
ARE LARGEST CONGREGATE
SETTINGS. THE MAJOR OUTBREAKS
AND THE NUMBER OF DEATHS FROM
NURSING HOMES TOLD US LOUD AND
CLEAR. THEY CONGREGATE SETTINGS
ARE INCUBATORS FOR A WILDFIRE
LIKE SPREAD OF THIS FIRST. MY
STAFF AND I'VE BEEN MONITORING
THE OUTBREAK IN CDC OUR
FACILITY SINCE LATE MARCH EARLY
APRIL WE'VE BEEN IN WRITTEN AND
VERBAL CONTACT WITH CITIES HERE
ARE OFFICIALS THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES OF CDC OUR
STAFF AND STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND IN THE FIRST
EIGHT WEEKS OR SOME OF THE
OUTBREAK CITIES YOUR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TOOK NUMEROUS
APPS TO LIMIT THE SPREAD. THE
DISTRIBUTED MASKS PROVIDED HAND
SANITIZER HAND WASHING STATIONS
STOPPED VISITATION AN INTAKE
COUNTY JAILS IN IN THOSE FIRST
FEW. IT APPEARED PRESENCE OF
THE VIRUS IN THE PRISONS WAS
ABOUT THE SAME AS IT WAS IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. BUT AT SOME POINT
THINGS WENT TERRIBLY WRONG
THERE WAS A GROWING OUTBREAK
INITIALLY AT CHINO. AND THEN AT
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION OF
WOMEN CHUCKWALLA AVENUE.
FOLLOWED BY THE- TRANSFER OF
INMATES FROM CHINO TO SAN
QUENTIN AND AS WE KNOW THERE IS
NOW THE PRESENCE OF THE VIRUS
IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
STATE PRISON FACILITIES. THE
DECISION TO TRANSFER
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FROM A
PRISON WITH ONE OF THE WORST
OUTBREAKS CHINO TO SAN QUENTIN
WHICH AT THE POINT HAD NO KNOWN
CASES. RAISES SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT CDC ARTS
HANDLING OF THIS CRISIS THE NOW
MAJOR OUTBREAK AT SAN QUENTIN
THREATENS THE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ON STAFF THERE BUT ALSO
BAY AREA HOSPITALS AND
RESIDENTS. SUBSEQUENT TRANSFERS
FROM SANDY. TO THE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN SUSANVILLE SO THIS
HAPPENED AFTER THE TRANSFER
FROM CHINO. NOW HAS TO THAT
FACILITY WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
CASES AND SUSAN BILL IS THE
PIPELINE FOR OUR FIRE CAMPS AND
WE ARE IN FIRE SEASON. THE
TRANSFER OF ONE INCARCERATED
PERSON TO THE SACRAMENTO PRISON
FACILITY RESULTED IN A NURSE
AND A STAFF THERE WHO PROCESS
THAT INDIVIDUAL. TURNING
CASTING NOW POSITIVE THESE IN
THE ORIGINAL TRANSFER. RAISE
LEGITIMATE CONCERN IN ANGER AT
CDC OURS HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC. ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT CDC ARE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND OR SO PEOPLE THAT ARE
HELD IN OUR STATE PRISONS SERVE
ON AVERAGE JUST THREE POINT TWO
YEARS THAT'S THEIR AVERAGE
SENTENCE. NOW THOUSANDS OF
THOSE ARE BEING HELD IN FEAR OF
DEATH. IN FEAR OF PERMANENT
MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS AN INJURY
FROM COVERT NINETEEN AS WELL AS
I MENTIONED THE THREAT OF
SPREAD NOT ONLY THE THREAT WITH
ME NO THE SPREAD IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THREE COURSE
REPEAT AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
LEGITIMATELY AN EXTREMELY
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO THEM CD R. C. OUR STAFF AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE LEGITIMATELY
AND CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING. THE PLAIN FACT IS.
THE VIRUS IS OUT OF CONTROL AT
OUR STATE PRISON FACILITIES AND
IT IS DEFINING EVERY CURVE WE
POINT TO FOR PROGRESS. IN THE
PLAIN FACT IS OUR PRISONS ARE
STILL OVER CROWDED AND THERE
ARE MANY HUNDREDS OF MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE AND VERY ELDERLY
INMATES WHO AS WE KNOW FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA ARE MOST AT
RISK OF DEATH FROM THE SPIRES.-THE ATTENTION AT LEAST MY
INTENTION FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
IS TO HEAR FROM THE SEED FROM
CDC ARE INDEED MINISTRATION ON
THE STATUS OF THE OUTBREAK.
WHAT THEIR PLAN IS FOR
CONTAINING THE VIRUS IN
REDUCING DEATHS. AND FOR
LIMITING COMMUNITY SPREAD. AND
HEAR WHAT THE PLAN IS FOR
IDENTIFYING AND ACCOUNTING
EXCUSE ME FOR STAFF CONFECTIONS
BECAUSE THE REPORTED NUMBERS
SEEM VERY LOW. AND YOUR STAND
THE TESTING PROCESS AND HOW
REFUSALS FOR TESTS ARE BEING
MANAGED. AND THEN TO HEAR FROM
CDC OUR STAFF REPRESENTATIVES
AND ADVOCATES WHO WERE IN
COMMUNICATION. WITH
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL AS AN EXTERNAL MEDICAL
TEAM THAT VISITED STANDPOINT SO
THE TWO PANELS WILL HAVE. WELL
ALL POLL INTRODUCED THE PANELS
IN A MOMENT LET US JUST TURN
SENATOR MORE LIKE DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN
WITH. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
OR MEASURES USE ME- THERE WAS A
RECENT TELEVISION NEWS- REPORT-
SHOWING VIDEO OF. INMATES
INTENTIONALLY SPREADING CODE
NINETEEN- IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TODAY TO LEARN
WHAT. WAS THEIR ASSUMPTION. EN
ROUTE WHY ARE THEY DOING IT
INTENTIONALLY- SO WHEN WE HEAR
THE PANELISTS I'D LIKE TO. SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON BUT I- ECHO
YOUR CONCERNS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPENING REMARKS. THANK
IT'S THEIR BREAD. THANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I THINK
THIS IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
HEARING AND- NOT ONLY FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WORK AT THESE FACILITIES BUT
THE INMATES THEMSELVES AND WE
HAVE TO BE CRITICAL CLEAR THAT
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. HAVE NOT BROUGHT
THIS DISEASE INTO THIS FACILITY.
AND WHAT. WORK IN THIS FACILITY
THE GOAL. ASUS WHO HAS BROUGHT
THE SAN AND I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE TESTED ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO NOT ONLY AS
YOUR CHAIR WOMAN STATED MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS ARE OURS ARE SAFE AND-
AFFECTED BY THIS DISEASE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE INCARCERATED WHO
CANNOT BELIEVE THESE FACILITIES
SO. I'M INTERESTED IN HEARING.
ALSO FROM THE LEADERS HERE THIS
SILLY OR WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK THERE ARE TESTED
BEFORE THEY COME TO WORK ON A
DAILY BASIS. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER. HI THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I'M SURE I REALLY
WANNA- THANK YOU FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING BUT ALSO ON YOUR
CONSISTENTLY TO SHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND YOU HAVE BEEN DEEPLY
PERSONAL AND KIDS. ON THIS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND COVERED
NINETEEN OF TO SEE OUR FOR
MONTHS NOW AND ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND PUSHING- CDC ARE
AND YOU HAVE BEEN ON THIS FROM
THE BEGINNING AND FRANKLY. A
LOT OF BY I WISH SO A LOT OF
YOUR ADVOCACY HAVE BEEN CHEATED
MORE OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS
COULD WE PERHAPS COULD AVOIDED
THIS FIASCO SAN QUENTIN. FOR A-
FOR YOUR ROCKETS LEADER. ON I
THINK LOOKING AT BIG PICTURE
HERE TRAGICALLY. THE THAT WHAT
IS HAPPENING OVERSEEING AT SAN
QUENTIN ELSEWHERE WITH THE
SPREAD OF THIS CONTINUE TO. I
SHOULD SURPRISE NO ONE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ON THE
LEADING CUTTING THIS ACCOUNTS
INCARCERATION FOR DECADES- ON
THE CUTTING EDGE IN A BAD WAY.
THE STATE HAS PIONEERED MASS
INCARCERATION GOING FROM E.
STATE PRISONS IN THE SEVENTIES
TO OVER THIRTY STATE PRISONS BY
THE TURN OF THE CENTURY. AND
DESPITE THAT EXPLOSION AND
NUMBER OF PRISONS AND THE COST
TO OUR BUDGET. AND THE COST TO
SO MANY COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TORN APART OUR PRISONS
WERE STILL MAGICALLY
OVERCROWDED AND SO DRAMATICALLY
OVERCROWDED THAT THE YOU
SUPPORT US WAS ON CON. FIVE AND
SO IT NOT SHOCKING THAT WITH.
THAT LEVEL OF MASSACRE. AND
INTO PRISONS NOT SHOT. THAT A
CONTAGION LIKE COVER NINETEEN
WOULD SPREAD HI AND THIS IS YET
ANOTHER REMINDER OF THE
ABSOLUTE IMPERATIVE TO REDUCE
OUR PRISON POPULATIONS AND MOVE
TOWARDS CARS SERRATION. IT IS.
A MASS INCARCERATION. IF THE-
HI DOES NOT MAKE US CITY FOR AS
A STATE BUT A COSTS AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT COULD BE
GOING TO HEALTH EDUCATION AND
OTHER NEEDS- AND IT TEARS APART
COMMUNITIES IN THE HOUSE TO
STOP IN THIS IS YET ANOTHER
REMINDER TO MOVE AGGRESSIVELY
TOWARD THE CAR'S SERRATION IN A
SHORT WE NEED REDUCE POPULATION.
AND HEALTH TO. THIS DEMOCRATS
IN ON OUR PER WHICH I THE CHAIR
NOTES WILL NOT STATE A THE
PRISON. WHATEVER HAPPENS IN OUR
PRISONS AS A TENDENCY TO SAID I
TESTED OUT SYSTEM PRISON.
PRISONS ARE LINKED TO SOCIETY
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS IN PRISONS
WILL SPREAD OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND VICE VERSA. WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
TODAY- TO SEE WHAT CDC ARE
GOING RIGHT NOW. TO DRAW A
CLEAR CHANGE ITS APPROACH
PRONTO THING AROUND THE RELEASE
BY MAKING SURE WE'RE TESTING
PEOPLE AS THEY'RE BEING
RELEASEDSO THAT WE ARE
MONITORING THAT SITUATION. SO
THAT WE CAN GET AHEAD ON US AND
IT RELATED ISSUE THAT I WILL BE
RAISING. I THINK IS INCREDIBLY
POOR AND- THAT IS WHY IS CITIES
PRK CONTINUING TO TRANSFER.
KEEP FROM ITS CUSTODY TO ICE.
BECAUSE WHEN WE TROUT THE ICE
SEND PEOPLE WHO MAY BE MATTER
MONO THEMSELVES. TO PRIVATE
PRISON ICE DETENTION FACILITIES
THERE OVERWHELMINGLY RUN BY
PRIVATE ENTITIES- WHERE WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE IN THREE OF
THE DETAINEES AND THOSE EYES
FACILITIES. IT IS COVERED
POSITIVE THESE ARE COVERED HOT
SPOTS BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS SHOWN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT IT IS EITHER
UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO DEAL
WITH PANDEMIC. AND THAT IS ON
WILLING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
IMMIGRANTS AND WE NEED TO STOP
TRANSFER. CUSTODY OF OUR STAY
PRISONS TO ICE DETENTION
FACILITIES AND NEEDS TO AND
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR FIRST OF
ALL LET ME ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES IN
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
STEADFAST. MOM FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE- AND CLEARLY THAT'S WHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE IN TERMS OF.
NOT ONLY APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
BUT JUST ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE FULLY AWARE. STATEMENTS ARE
FULLY AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
YOU KNOW MORE THAN FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO ON AS A RESULT OF
PLOT A VERSUS FOR TODAY OR THE
FEDERAL COURT DETERMINE THAT
CDC ARE HAS FAILED TO MEET THE
BASIC CONSTITUTIONAL. RIGHTS OF
INMATES WITH REGARD TO ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO FAST
FOR DATA TWENTY TWENTY AND
WE'RE STILL UNDER THE RESULTING
RECEIVERSHIP. BECAUSE WE REALLY
HAVEN'T STRUCTURALLY FIX THE
PROBLEM DEAR TO MANY PEOPLE
INTO CONFINED SPACE WITH TOO
FEW RESOURCES. AND THAT BRINGS
US TO THE CONVERSATION TODAY
WERE UNFORTUNATELY NONE OF US
ARE SURPRISED. THE COOL BUT
NINETEEN HAS FOUND ITS WAY DEEP
INTO OUR PRISON SYSTEM. AND IN
MY OPINION THE SITUATION
CURRENTLY OF FAN QUICKNESS
CLEARLY JUST THE CANARY IN THE
COAL MINE. WE WILL SEE IN LESS
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES HAPPEN.
PRISON AFTER PRISON AFTER
PRISON WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
THERE ARE THOUSAND CASES IT SEE
I AM IN CHINO. AND SO THIS IS
ON FORCING JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG UNLESS DRASTIC CHANGE
HAPPENS. MANY OBSERVERS HAD
NOTED SOME CONCERNING PRACTICES
IN THE SYSTEM THE CONFLICT WITH
ADVICE FROM THE WHL THE CITY.
COUNTY HEALTH DIRECTOR
STATEWIDE. THIS IS LIKE THE
TRANSFERS INITIATIVE BEEN
SHELTERING LACK OF
COMMUNICATION WITH FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES AND THE
DISCONTINUATION OF PROGRAMMING.
IN OTHER INSTANCES MAYBE GIVE
GET GUIDELINES ARE BEING
FOLLOWED AS IT'S BEEN ASSERTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND YET THE
DISEASE CONTINUES TO SPREAD.
CLEARLY SOMETHING IS AMISS. I
TOO AM EAGER TO HEAR TODAY WHAT
THE PLAN OF ACTION IS FROM THIS
POINT GOING FORWARD. AS CHAIR
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I AM KEENLY AWARE OF
THE NEEDS AND REQUESTS THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE USING THAT
LANDS IN TODAY'S HEARING I LOOK
FOR T. PARTICIPATED IN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONVENIENT IF
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S.
YES THANK YOU OF. MADAM CHAIR
AND ALSO I SHARE THE SAME DEEP
CONCERN ABOUT THE LACK OF-
OVERSIGHT THE LACK OF. CARING
AND COMPASSION THAT SEEMS TO
EXIST IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM WITH
RESPECT TO. OUR THE PRISONERS
THERE ARE WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
HEALTHCARE. AS JUST NOTED BY MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES. LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
WHETHER IT WAS WOMEN CONTINUING
TO BE STERILIZED IN PRISON.
WHETHER IT'S THE LACK OF
CONCERN FOR TRUE
REHABILITATION- OUR PRISON
SYSTEM FRANKLY I THINK HAS
FAILED US AND IN NO GREATER
RESPECT THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW WITH THIS COVERT SITUATION.
I HAVE A FEDERAL PRISON IN MY
DISTRICT THE LONG POKE FEDERAL
PENITENTIARY WHICH WAS PRIOR TO
SAN QUENTIN. OF THE PLACE WITH
THE GREATEST INCREASE AND
SURGING OF COVERT NINETEEN
CASES- THE ABOUT THE INABILITY
TO GET INFORMATION. TO BE ABLE
TO HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE OF COURSE THE
FEDERAL SO THEY REALLY DON'T
CARE MUCH ABOUT WHAT THE STATE
HAS TO SAY ABOUT ANYTHING. BUT
NONE THE LESS WE SEE THE SAME
KIND OF LACK OF REGARD- IN OUR
OWN CD SHE OUR SYSTEM WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW WE TREAT THESE
CENTERS. AND HOW WE ADDRESS THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS PROBLEM.
ARE THERE PEOPLE IN PRISON WHO
SOME MIGHT CAN TO BE. LESS THAN
THE REST OF US THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT THESE ARE PEOPLE
OVER WHOM WE ALL OF
RESPONSIBILITY THEY ARE
INCARCERATED. THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE LOST THEIR FREEDOM- AND SO
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CARE FOR THEM AS HUMAN BEINGS.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING THAT SO I
WILL BE VERY INTERESTED TO HEAR
WHAT HAPPENS TODAY AS WELL. I
AM VERY FRUSTRATED WITH OUR
FEDERAL SYSTEM. WHICH AGAIN
DOES NOT THINK THAT THEY HAVE
ANY ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
YET MANY OF THOSE GUARDS IN THE
STAFF AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE. HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
THIS CONDITION AND BROUGHT IT
BACK INTO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY-
I THINK THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE SEEING-
BUT THE- THE FACT THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A COMPLETE AND UTTER
DISREGARD OF FOR THESE. THE
INMATES AS HUMAN BEINGS AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE HAVE A
SOCIETY TO KEEP PEOPLE AT LEAST
THE VERY BASIC LEVEL OF HUMAN
DIGNITY. I HAS REALLY LED TO
THIS PROBLEM TODAY AND IT IS MY
HOPE THAT OUT OF ADVERSITY.
COMES OPPORTUNITY OR AS THEY
SAY OUT OF WOMEN SHE TRIED TO
MAKE LEMONADE THAT WE CAN
REALLY START MOVING AND
FINANCING ARE MORE CARING A
MORE CHARGED UP IN FAIRVIEW.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE AN CARP TO
THOSE WHO FOR WHATEVER DESERVE
A TO BE ISOLATED FROM THE
GENERAL POPULATION BUT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE ISOLATED FROM
HUMANITY AND THAT I THINK IS
WHAT I HOPE WE CAN ADDRESS SIR
STARTED PRESSING TODAY
DIMENSION. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON FROM THERE IN TO
MEMBERS ALSO ONE TO MAKE SOME.
COM ON. TURN TO THE IMAGES ONE
MOMENT BUT I AM INDICATING IT'S
NINE TWENTY FOUR BECAUSE- OUR
FIRST PANEL INCLUDES TO-
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHO
I UNDERSTAND HAVE A HARD STOP
AT TEN. SO SINCE I KNOW MANY OF
US WILL HAVE QUITE AN ONE MAKE
SURE THAT WE GIVE THAT PANEL
ADEQUATE TIME SO NOW I WILL
TURN TO SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOLLOWED BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
LEVINE AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. MINIATURE THANK YOU
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO OFFER MY
APPRECIATION MADAM CHAIR TO YOU
AND YOUR TEAM- FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE A PARTICIPATE TO DAY- AND
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO. CENTER SKINNER HAS BEEN
LEADING FROM THE FRONT ON THIS
ISSUE. BEFORE EIGHT HIT THE
HEADLINES SHE HAS BEEN SOUNDING
THE ALARM. FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MADAM CHAIR AND
AGAIN I TRULY APPRECIATE. BEING
HERE TODAY. I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO THIS TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SECTOR IDEAS HE'S BEEN
RESPONSIVE- TO THE NEEDS AND
WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY
OBVIOUSLY- I DON'T TAKE
LIGHTLY. AND I AM NOT ONE. TO
TYPICALLY GO AFTER STATE.
AGENCIES BUT HERE'S MY
CHALLENGE. REPRESENT THAT AREA
WHERE- TEN CLINTON IS AT. AND
I'M GONNA EASE A PHRASE THAT
CAME FROM AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST IN
MARIN COUNTY TODAY. THE
CONDITIONS IN ST CLINTON THIS
MORNING. HAVE UNSTOPPABLE
MOMENTUM. UNSTOPPABLE MOMENTUM
IF THE CURRENT CONDITIONS.
CONTINUE IN THE DAYS TO COME.
AND AGAIN I DON'T. SAID A
SLIGHTLY BUT THIS IS A FAILURE
OF LEADERSHIP. THIS CRISIS IS
COMPLETELY AVOIDABLE. THE BASIC
THE BASIC PROACTIVE ACTIONS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN INITIATED
BACK IN EARLY JUNE SIMPLY NEVER
HAPPEN TO THE LEVEL WHERE
SUCCESS COULD BE G. THE A
HUNDRED TWENTY TO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY. PRISONERS TRANSFERRED
FROM CHINO SHOULD EVER HAPPEN
IN SUCH AN OLD FACILITY WHERE
THERE WERE NO SOLID DOORS. NO
SOLID DOORS AND THEN THE VIRUS
SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE. THERE IS
NO PROACTIVE MEASURES WE ARE
LEADING BEHIND THE- THERE'S
STAFFING SHORTAGES LACK OF
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. NOT ENOUGH
SECURITY NOW AND HOSPITALS.
LACK OF COMMUNICATION WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES IN BOTH
THE COUNTY MARIN COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO. PHYSICIANS ARE NOW
SPENDING. HOURS UPON HOURS TO
FIND HOSPITAL BEDS TO TRANSFER
INMATES OUT TO. THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT CUSTODY COULD
STAFFING. AND TONIGHT WE'LL
HAVE OUR FOLLOW AT THAT MEETING
WITH WE'LL CALL IT ALL HANDS ON
DECK MEETING BETWEEN. THE
LEGISLATURE CDC ARE. SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC HEALTH MARIN
PUBLIC HEALTH ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WE NEED TO
DEVELOP A UNIFIED INCIDENT
COMMAND ON SITE BOTTOM LINE ALL
AGENCIES INVOLVED ARE HEARING
THE SAME THING ALL AT ONCE WE
NEED TO DEVELOP A STRATEGY TO
CREATE SEARCH CAPACITY FOR I
SEE YOU IN HOSPITAL BEDS IN THE
GREATER BAY AREA. AS OF TEN PM
LAST NIGHT TWENTY FOUR OUT OF
TWENTY FIVE I SEE BEDS IN MARIN
ARE FULL EIGHT ARE SAN QUENTIN
INMATES. WE NEED TO CREATE. EMS
PROTOCOLS FOR PATIENT TRANSFERS
SO THAT WE'RE NOT FLOODING ONE
AREA OF THE BAY. BUT THERE IS A
STRATEGY TO BE ABLE TO TRANSFER.
THERE IS GOING TO NEED TO BE
SOME TYPE OF ON SITE MEDICAL
FACILITY. ESTABLISHED WE NEED
TO DISCUSS WHAT THAT STRATEGIES
FOR PLANNED EARLY RELEASE IN
WHERE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL
POTENTIALLY BE QUARANTINE. AND
THERE HAS TO BE A LONG TERM
DECISION ON ADDITIONAL
TRANSFERS INTO THE FACILITY.
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE THANK
YOU FOR LOVING COMMENTS AND
TRULY. INNER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE BEFORE I
TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
I APPRECIATE YOUR CLARITY ON
THINGS THEY NEED TO DO. AND I
HAVE NO QUARREL WITH IT EXCEPT
THAT I DO NOT THINK IT WILL BE
ADEQUATE IF IT IS DONE AT SAN
QUENTIN ALONE. WE DO NOT KNOW
THE EXTENT OF THIS VIRUS NOW IN
ALL THE REST THE FACILITIES
EXCEPT WHAT IS REPORTED WE KNOW
THAT EVERYONE HAS NOT BEEN
TESTED WE KNOW THAT ALL GUARDS
OF NOT. TO STAFF I SHOULD SAY
STAFF HAVE NOT BEEN TESTED SO I
THINK THAT. WHILE YOU OF
OUTLINED A PLAN FOR ONE
FACILITY. THIS MUST BE A PLAN
FOR THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE OPENING COMMENTS OF THIS
HEARING. THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
IS I'M NOT A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. ARE AND MY NUMBER OF
THIS HOUSE THIS IS A HEARING OF
CONSEQUENCE. THAT WEIGHS
HEAVILY ON MY CONSTITUENTS TO
HEAR. THE SIRENS OF AMBULANCES.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
STEADFAST LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. CALL THE NINETEEN IS A
DANGEROUSLY POWERFUL FORCE OF
NATURE. BUT HUMAN BEHAVIOR CANCONTROL IT SPREAD.ADVOCATES
FOR CALIFORNIANS WERE
INCARCERATED RAISE THE NEED TO
PREPARE AND TO SPEND THOSE IN
CUSTODY FROM THE VIRUS EARLY
INDEPENDENT. I HEARD THEIR
CONCERNS AND DOES A GREAT
COUNTY'S PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
DR MATT WILLIS ABOUT THE
ALARMING POTENTIAL OF AN
OUTBREAK OF CODED IN OUR
PRISONS. SO I ACTED. I WROTE
LETTERS AND SPOKE WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF CDC ARE I SPOKE
TO THIS ISSUE DURING THE
ASSEMBLY'S COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE BUDGET DISCUSSION WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE. I SPOKE WITH MEMBERS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S CABINET I
SPOKE WITH THE GOVERNOR I CALL
THE PLAN CDC ARCH CREEK SITE
SPECIFIC CODE PLANS FOR EACH OF
ITS FACILITIES. I CALLED FOR
EXTRA. CHIEF BEING POSITION
MAKING AT THE AT HERE ARE AFTER
THE DISASTROUS TRANSFER IN
MEANS THE SAME QUESTION THAT
WAS NOTHING MORE THAN THE WORST
PRISON HOLTZ GREW UP IN STATE
HISTORY WE DID NOT MEET THIS
MOMENT I CALLED FOR A PLAN FOR
HOSPITALIZATION HOSPITALS WOULD
NOT BE CRIPPLED BY BOTH
COMMUNITY SPREAD AS WE ARE SEEN
IN A VALLEY AND A SURGE OF
INSPECTION AT SINCE I GOT SENT.
BACK HAS NOW CLAIMED OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED VICTIMS IN LESS
THAN A MONTH I CALLED FOR AN
INCIDENT COMMAND TO BE SET UP.
ASK PLAN WHAT WE RECEIVED WAS
UNACCEPTABLE UNMITIGATED
DISASTER DELIVERED BY A LACK OF
PLANNING AND PREPARATION. WE
CANNOT SWEEP IT UNDER THE RUG.
THERE MUST BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHATEVER SAID TODAY WILL MAKE
UP FOR LOST TIME IT WON'T EASE
THE PAIN OF YOUR SELECTED
STOCKTON PRISONERS WE CAN'T GO
BACKWARDS. WE WILL BE PRESENTED
A PLAN TODAY. NEVER HAS TOO
LITTLE TOO LATE BEEN MORE TRUE
OR CRUEL HAS BETTER LATE THAN
NEVER BEEN SO MORALLY REPUGNANT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SO A MEMBER LEVINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. THANK YOU SENATOR
A SKINNER PURE LEADERSHIP- I
APPRECIATE YOU AND EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES I AGREE
WITH. EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
SAID BY OUR COLLEAGUES AND I
JUST WANT TO I DON'T WANT TO
TOO MUCH TIMES WE CAN GET TO
THE PALACE BUT I DO WANT. TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
BE RIGHT ABOUT PUBLIC HELP US
WITH THE PASSAGE IS BEING-
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE CRISIS
AND YET THE KNOWS THAT I'VE
BEEN IN. THE CITY'S YOU. THEY
HAVE NOT GUIDED BY THE PUBLIC
OTHER LEASES INDICATE ISSUES
ARE SUCH AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PUT
TAPPED- ON THE- WAITED PROTECT
THOSE ARE WORKING THERE LET'S
THINK ABOUT WITHOUT THOSE YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER THAT WAS THE
QUESTION DOES YOUR PENDING OR
HAVING TO GO TO WORK- WHAT KIND
OF ENVIRONMENT WITH ONE SO. THE
ALL WHAT I WANT TO HEAR I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR IS YOU. KNOW WHAT.
HOW FAR AWAY ARE THEY FROM
COMBINED THEM OUT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE WHAT THEY NEED FROM US.
TO MAKE SURE THEY GET THERE I
ALSO AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
ALI. I DON'T I THINK ALL AYE
STRANGERS OR AT LEAST INFORMING
ICE. THAT'S INTERNAL CALLS THAT
HE'S A STOP IMMEDIATELY- I
THINK I'M FINALLY YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO GET RELEASES AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN RELEASE I KNOW
THAT. THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
WORK ON THAT- IN THE FIRST
ITERATION GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
BUT NOW WE NEED EXPANDED. RIGHT
HERE YEAH OR RELEASE I KNOW
THAT A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IS
BEEN USED. WE HAVE TO EXPAND
THAT AND- EVEN IF IT'S ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THEY DON'T HAVE HOUSING
USED PROJECT ROOM HERE ANY.
OTHER MECHANISM AVAILABLE THAT
WE CREATED TO THIS WILL BE
CRISIS. AND GET INDIVIDUALS OUT
OF THAT ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE
THAT IS TRULY THE BEST
SOLUTION. TO MINIMIZE THE REST
AND- SO I APPRECIATE OF THIS
HEARING OF THE CORD TO THE
POWER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA SO WE
HAVE. YES SENATOR. PARDON ME
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN DISAPPOINTED
CLARIFICATION YOU SAID THAT
THERE WAS A HARD STOP AT TEN
FOR EVERYONE ON THE PANEL OR
JUST THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS THINK MORE
TIME JUST FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BECAUSE I WAS
NOTHING FELT THAT'S WHOLLY
INADEQUATE GIVEN THE NAY THE
SEVERITY ISSUE THE NATURE OF
THE QUESTIONS WE HAD THANK YOU.
YOUR YOU'RE WELCOME INTERMENT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
I WILL INTRODUCE THE SECOND
PANEL LATER JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME THE FIRST
PANEL WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CDC ARE IT
WILL INCLUDE SECRETARY RALPH
TIAS FROM THE I'M SEAT
SECRETARY OF CDC ARE YOU WILL
HAVE CLARK KELSO WHO'S THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER AND WHO IS
ORDERED BY THE JUDGE TO.
OVERSEE THE DELIVERY OF CARE IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEMS MARCH EARLY
HAS NOW NOT AVAILABLE SO WE
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM SEASON
FINALE WHO'S THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND PROGRAMS
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SO I'M GOING TO START
WITH THE SEASON FINALE BEEN NO
SHE'S NOT AVAILABLE YET SHE IS
ENJOINED YET OKAY I KNOW SHE
HAD TO LEAVE AT TEN SO. IN
RESEARCH EIGHT ZERO BUT SIR YES
I'M SURE. MY WE WANNA ASK YOU
AND TALK TO ABOUT. A YOU TO
SAY ON BUT I MAY SWITCH TO
SEASON FINALE BEFORE WE ARE
REALLY COMPLETED. ON AND
SECRETARY TIAS BEFORE YOU START.
YOUKNOW I. THE SENATE WHEN OUT
IN SOMETIME IN MARCH AND OF
COURSE WE WERE HOME. AND WHILE
I WAS HOME I WATCHED WITH FOR
WHAT WAS OCCURRING AT RYKER'S.
ENDED A PRISON IN OHIO AND THEN
AT SOME FEDERAL FACILITIES WHEN
I SAW. COATED SPREADING LIKE
WILDFIRE AT THOSE FACILITIES
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT OUR STATE
PRISONS AND SO WE STARTED
REGULAR CALLS. AND I WROTE MY
FIRST FORMAL LETTER TO YOU AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IN APRIL.
BASICALLY ASKING FOR WHAT IS
WHAT IS DISORGANIZED TO AVOID.
WHAT HAPPENED IN OHIO IN
BREAKERS. BEYOND OUR- I JUST
FEEL LIKE IT WAS NOT TAKEN
SERIOUSLY AND THAT WHILE THE
REST OF OUR STATE WAS GETTING
CLEAR MESSAGES AND PEOPLE WERE
BEING PROTECTED THAT WAS NOT
THE CASE WITH OUR FOLKS WHO ARE
IN THE SYSTEM AND SO YOU MAY
OPEN AND ON HER MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS SECRETARY. YOU
VERY MUCH PARTICIPATING. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'M JOE I HAVE A
STATEMENT TO READ. QUE SO WHAT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY. TO TALK ABOUT THE
CALIBER DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IN THE EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE COUPLED WITH. A COVER
NINETEEN IN OUR FACILITIES WE
UNDERSTAND. AND SHARE. CONCERN
FOR THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
AND STAFF. BECOME HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THIS WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC. IN
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL INDIVIDUALS AND
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
AND WILL REMAIN A TOP PRIORITY.
JUST BEFORE THE GLOBAL
CORONAVIRUS OUR COMMUNITY CDC
ARE AND C. C. H. U. S.
RECEIVERS OFFICE. OF OUR TIRES
THE EMPLOYMENT JUST TO PROTECT
STAFF THE CARD FOR YOUR
POPULATION. AT THE END THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE CITY C. R.
AND C. C. H. YES TOOK IMMEDIATE
STEPS TO IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES
THE WHOLE SPREAD APPROPRIATE.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CDC AND CV
PH GUIDELINES. THESE EFFORTS
HAVE BEEN DONE IN COORDINATION
WITH MISTER KELSO AND RECEIVERS
OFFICE AND HIS TEAM AND BASED
ON. BUT KNOWING THAT OVER
NINETY WATER. BY SUSPENDING
RECITATION AND TOURS STATEWIDE
WHICH IS SPENDING IN PERSON
OBSERVERS AT ALL SUITABILITY
HEARINGS THAT HALTED ALL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WITHIN
THE PARAMETERS OF THE
INSTITUTIONS WE BEGAN VERY
EARLY SCREENING ALL WHO ENTERED
THE INSTITUTIONS AND EXPANDED
THE SCREEN TO INCLUDE
TEMPERATURE SCREENING ALL
INSTITUTIONS. RECORD IN THE
PREVENTION WAS A KEY WE ALSO
DELIVERED FACT SHEETS AND
POSTERS EDUCATE INMATES AND THE
POPULATION AND STAFF WINSTAR
ALWAYS TO CHOOSE THE ORDER HAND
SANITIZERS. THE INSTITUTION BY
ANY CALLS WORK AREA IN HOUSE
UNITS WE INCREASE THE FREQUENCY
OF DISINFECTING AND CLEANING
EFFORTS IN HIGH TRAFFIC AREAS
HIGH VOLUME AREAS SUCH AS DAY
ROOMS DINING HALLS SHOWERS AND
RESTROOMS. WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PRISON INDUSTRY
AUTHORITY WE BEGAN PRODUCING
CLAW YOUR MASK WOULD TO
DISTRIBUTE IT INSTITUTIONS FOR
THE USE OF STAFF AND INMATES.
ONCE MASSIVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE INSTITUTIONS THE
USE OF MASS BY INMATES AND
STAFF BECAME MANDATORY. AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE MANDATORY. A
KNOWLEDGE DURING THE IMPORTANCE
OF PHYSICAL DISTANCE INTO
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF THE
COVERNINETEEN WE ACTIVATED
GYMNASIUMS I CAN HOUSING UNITS
WITHIN INSTITUTIONS TO MOVE
THOUSANDS OF IN MY TO BOMB
ACOSTA HOUSING TO SPACES. OR OR
COULD INCREASE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING TO SIX FEET IN ALL
DIRECTIONS. AND WE ATTEMPTED TO
ACHIEVE THIS WE MODIFIED A
PROGRAM ALSO SUSPENDED INTO A
COMPANION J. S. EXPEDITED THE
RELEASE APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED ARCHERY
PERSONS IN APRIL. DO STE THE
IN. A CAR TRADE POPULATION BY
MORE THAN EIGHT THOUSAND SINCE
MID MARCH. WE INTENDED TO
FURTHER REDUCE THE POPULATION
BY IMPLEMENTING ROLLING EARLY
RELEASES STARTING THIS WEEK AND
NEXT. THIS IS A STATE WIDE
EFFORT. STAND STERN OF THE
FAMILY GLOBAL. MR WEBB'S AND
EMAIL AND THE THEM IN. AND
RIGHT OF THE NEED TO THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE CONTACT
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES. WE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH OUR PHONE
CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE FREE
PHONE CALLS EACH MONTH AND
EXPANDED PHONE ACCESS TO
CERTAIN PRIVILEGED GROUPS
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE THAT.
THANKS TO THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
WITH THE HELP OF THE STATEWIDE
TESTING TASK FORCE WE HAVE
PERFORMED MANDATE. MANDATORY
STOP TESTING AT TWELVE
INSTITUTIONS WE TESTED
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED STAFF. THERE ARE
STILL MORE TESTS PENDING WITH
THESE RESULTS IN THEIR ONGOING
EVEN AS WE SPEAK BUT AS YOU SEE
ON THE PUBLIC TRACKER THERE
HAVE BEEN EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN. ALL THE STAFF
BASIS. WE BEGIN RIGOROUS STOP
TESTING- RIGOR STEP TESTING
PLAN AT FOUR INSTITUTION THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO THE CD PHP ALL
NURSING FACILITY GUIDELINES.
THIS INCLUDES BASELINE TESTING
FOR ALL STAFF BY JUNE
THIRTIETH. IS ALREADY HAPPENED
WILL REQUIRE SERIAL TESTING ON
A WEEKLY BASIS UNTIL. THERE ARE
MULTIPLE TESTING ADVANCE WITH
NO POSSIBLE CASES. IN ADDITION
TO THE PARTNERSHIP WITH C. P.
H. AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY CDC ARE AS WELL
IS MOVING FORWARD. TO A NON
SKILLEDNURSING TESTING PLAN.
THAT PROVIDES FOR WEEKLY SERIAL
TESTING OF STAFF AT
INSTITUTIONS WHERE THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK. SO IS THE CASE A ST.
WHERE ALL OUT OF STATE WATER
SOME TO PROVIDE FOR THE
FREQUENCY OF THIS OUTBREAK IN
INSTITUTIONS AND BASS LINE AND
FUTURE SURVEILLANCE TESTING.
ALL OTHER INSTITUTIONS STARTING
TODAY. OR SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
STAFF SPREADING THROUGHOUT
EVERY CORNER CALIFORNIA IT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGE TO FIND A
VENDOR WAS SUFFICIENT CAPACITY.
BUT WE'RE MORE REPORTER
INGRESSIVE. SO WHILE WE ARE
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGIES RESPOND CODE
NINETEEN TO MINIMIZE THE SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS. THE VIRUS STILL
CONTINUES TO SPREAD IN OUR
FACILITY JUST DECIDED BY ALL
THE SPEAKERS AND YOU MADAM. WE
HAVE HAD SETBACKS SUCH AS THE
SENATE COULDN'T OPERATE BUT WE
REMAIN STEADFAST IN OUR
RESPONSIBILITY CATION TO
MEETING THE MOMENT. TO PROTECT
OUR POPULATION AND THE STAFF IN
THE COMMUNITY. DID YOU SEE OUR
CITY FURTHER ACTION OF THE TO
MITIGATE THE OPERATOR SO I
COULDN'T THESE ACTIONS APPROVED
ESTABLISHING A UNIFIED COMMAND.
AT THE PRESENT TO COORDINATE
CUTS THE MEDICAL RESPONSE. THE
TEAM IS COMPRISED OF MEDICAL
CUSTODY EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
BUDGET DISEASE EXPERTISE.
AREN'T CCH YES. THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
EMERGENCY EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE VISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH. ADDITIONALLY
THE PRESIDENT'S CURRENTLY
INSTALLING SIX TENTHS THAT WILL
USE THAT ALTERNATIVE CHAIR
STATION RECALL THE NINETEEN GET
MY PATIENTS ON GROUNDS. AD
THAT OPENS UP CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE PRESIDENT TO ALLOW
INCREASED PHYSICAL. POINTS IN
IT I. FOOD A GYMNASIUM AT THAT
INSTITUTION. I TO EXPRESS SO WE
CAN DO BETTER AND I KNOW WE
WILL DO BETTER BUT I NEED A BY
HAD. THERE ARE SIXTEEN OF OUR
INSTITUTE THAT EVERY CALM FREE
TODAY THIS RISING QUE ANSWER
COMMUNITIES WITH THE ADDITIONAL
EIGHT REPORTING ONLY SINGLE
DIGIT NUMBERS. WE HAVE THE
OUTBREAK TO SEVER OTHER
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON AT
LANCASTER. AND THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN THIS
POSITIVE PROGRESS HIGHLIGHTS
YOU SEE OUR AND THE RECEIVERS
OFFICES ISOLATION AND
QUARANTINE EFFORTS. THE MASS
TESTING IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THE FIRST COVER NINETEEN.
CASE WAS GOING. AS HELP-MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. SEE SEE ON THE
RECEIVER'S OFFICE WE ARE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO
FIGHT OVER THAT ALL
INSTITUTIONS WE ARE PART OF
THIS COMMUNITY. WE EACH STEP IN
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE OUR PLACE
TO FURTHER IN THE CALL TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ALL WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO HUESO PROVE OUR
EFFORTS IN EVERY SINGLE WAY
POSSIBLE. WHICH INCLUDES AND
PROTECTION FOR CONTINUED
PRODUCTIVE COLLABORATION WILL
EVALUATE STAKEHOLDERS. NOW I
WILL SAY I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW
ONE THING THAT I DID HERE. WAS
THE LACK OF CARE THERE'S A
THOUGHT THAT. I'M GONNA
QUESTIONS OR MYSELF DO NOT CARE
ABOUT POPULATION OR WE VIEW
THEM AS SUBHUMAN OR THEY DON'T
DESERVE THE SAME TYPES OF
CONSIDERATIONS AS ALL OF US ARE
ALL OF US YOU SEE RIGHT HERE. I
SAY THAT. INSOFAR AS THE TRUTH
WE HAVE MORE TIRELESSLY TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE INSTITUTIONS
WE HAVE DEDICATED STAFF MEMBERS
RETURNING TO WORK TO THE TUNE
RIGHT NOW THREE HUNDRED AND
STAFF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
STAFF MEMBERS HAVE RETURNED TO
WORK. TO DO THE WORK OF
ASSISTING IN MITIGATING AND
HELPING OUT IN REDUCING THE
SCOPE IT. SO THE THOUGHT THAT
WE DON'T CARE I DON'T CARE
PERSONALLY. ALL THIS FROM THE
TRUTH. WE CARE ABOUT THE
INMATES WE CARE ABOUT THE STAFF
COULD WE HAVE DONE BETTER IN
MANY INSTANCES AND I CAN ANSWER
SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS OF
COURSE WE CAN. WE'RE FOUR
MONTHS INTO A PANDEMIC FOUR
MONTHS IN A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC
THAT WE ARE WE ARE LEANING AND
LEADING INTO ANY RESOURCES ALL
SMALL THE RECEIVERS OFFICES CDC
ARE EVAN WORKING ARM IN ARM TO
TRY AND MITIGATE AT ALL
INSTITUTIONS NOT JUST. NOT
RIGHT OUTSIDE OUR- WITH THE
WITH THAT TO A MADAM SO. TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
ON TO QUESTIONS TO YOU IN HERE
FROM DOCTOR GOLLY BECAUSE I'VE
JUST LEARNED THAT HE HAS JOINED
US SO IF I COULD TURN TO DR
GOLLY WHO'S THE SECRETARY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HER HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND WHO'S BEEN
DIRECTING CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE TO THE ENDEMIC
TACTICAL. IS A NOT AVAILABLE.
SAID DR ALL YOU NEED TO ON YOU
YOURSELF IN. WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
YOU NEED TO BE ON MUTED OKAY
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR YEAH NOW
WE CAN'T YES GOING GLOBAL THANK
YOU. WOMEN THANK YOU. HAVE
MANY- I HAVE LIMITED TIME BUT I
AM. RICHARD OF HAVING A CHANCE
TO JOIN THIS HEARING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING ON WHAT I
THINK IS AN ESSENTIAL AND
IMPORTANT ISSUE ACROSS OUR
STATE- I WANT TO THANK
SECRETARY DEALS FOR ITS
PARTNERSHIP OVER THE LAST MANY
MONTHS- THEIR THAT. REALLY
BEGAN TO BACK IN MARCH AS WE
BEGAN TO SEE THE- THE RAT
WITHIN OUR PRISON SYSTEM JUST
AS WE- THROUGH- HHS ARE
COMPARTMENTS EARLY. E. PH AS
WELL AS OUR I AM SO. TO BE ABLE
TO PARTNER WITH- CDC ARE IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROTOCOLS. AND THE- PLANS
AROUND INFECTION CONTROL AND
TESTING ARE ROLLED OUT. I WANT
TO BEGIN BY- ALSO STREAM BAD
TODAY OUR FOCUS IS ON THE
ISSUES AT SAN QUENTIN MOVING
FORWARD ENSURING THAT IT AS WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SOME
SUPPORT TO SECRETARY DO ES AND
THE RECEIVER AND THEIR
RESPECTIVE TEAMS AT THE
FACILITY AND BEYOND. BAD WE
LOOK FORWARD TO INSTITUTING
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
MENTIONED BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I SECRETARY DHEAS
IN TERMS OF INFECTION CONTROL
IN TERMS OF THE INCIDENT
COMMANDER. IN TERMS OF MODELING
WHAT WE EXPECT TO SEE NOT JUST
INSANE C<c.cyan>. BUT IN OTHER CDC</c>
ARE PRISCILLA NEEDS. ENSURING
THAT. BEEN SUPPLIED AND PROCESS
SEES AN LABS ARE AVAILABLE SO
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE FURTHER
DELAYS IN TESTING THAT COULD BE
DONE ENSURING THAT ASSETS SUCH
AS STAFF HANDS FOR ON SITE ON
PROPERTY ADDITIONAL HOUSING
UNITS ARE AVAILABLE SO THAT WE
CAN DO FOR CRIME RATE AND-
THANKS. SURE THAT. THIS IS BOTH
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES AND AT THE
LARGEST JAIL SYSTEM IN THE
NATION- THIS COMES FROM A
NUMBER OF YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
RUNNING THOSE JAIL FACILITIES-
AND THEIR MAP ARE THE MEDICAL
SERVICES THERE SAID IT IN A
PANDEMIC OR IN ANY OPERATE THE
FIRST ISSUE IS TO IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO ARE SICK. THIS IS NOT.
AND AMONG THOSE WHO ARE NOT
SICK WE MUST KNOW WHO ARE
INFECTED AND WE'RE NOT THAT
EFFECTIVELY COAL OR DAM IN
DISTINCT AREAS. SERVED BY
BOOSTING STAFF AND LIMITING
MOVEMENT AND MAKE SEEN AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. BECAUSE IF WE
HAVEN'T YOU CONTROL THE ENTRY
OF THE VIRUS OR THE INFECTION
THROUGH THE FRONT DOOR THE JOB
NUMBER ONE IS TO MAKE SURE.
CONTAINMENT HAPPENS IN THE
FACILITY IN A SUCCESSFUL WAY.
ONCE YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THE
STATE AND- INFECTION CONTROL
PROCEDURES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT SAID IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MONITOR THOSE WHO ARE KNOWN TO
BE INFECTED YEAH I'M NOT
CERTAIN. AND THEN ALSO ENSURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO CAST AND-
TRACK THOSE WHO ARE NOT YET
INSPECTED TO ENSURE THAT IF
THEY DO BECOME INFECTED WE PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE SICK WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO NEED A
CUTE HIGH LEVEL CARE ARE
TRANSFERRED SAFELY AND
IMMEDIATELY TO OUTSIDE
FACILITIES TO RECEIVE THAT
LEVEL OF CARE. THINK THE PLANS
THAT ARE IN PLACE MOVING
FORWARD TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL SYSTEM THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
NOT JUST IN MARIN AND SAN
FRANCISCO BUT ALSO IN OTHER
COUNTIES ACROSS THE BAY. WHERE
HOSPITALS MAY BE ACCEPTING
PATIENTS TO WORK THROUGH THE
REGIONAL COORDINATING SYSTEM AT
OUR ANSWER SYSTEM LED BY DR
DAVE DUNCAN. HE HIMSELF HAS
HELPED MANAGE THE TRANSFER OF
PATIENTS AND IMPERIAL COUNTY TO
VARIOUS OUTLINED HOW TO COUNTY
FACILITIES THE SAME HANNAH AND
I KNOW IS PLANNED TO BE DONE
NOW IN THE SAME CUENTA QUE.
THIS REQUIRES CLOSE CONNECTION
WITH DOCTOR WILLIS AND HIS TEAM
AT THE MARIN PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND IN PARTICULAR
CLOSE WORK WITH MARIN GENERAL
HOSPITAL AND ENSURING THAT THAT
HOSPITAL HAS CAPABILITY NOT
JUST THE SERVER. THINK QUENTIN
PATIENTS BUT AS ASSEMBLY MAN
PAUL LEVINE MENTIONED ENSURING
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE CAPACITY.
FOR THE MARINE COMMUNITY AS
WELL. FURTHERMORE PART OF WHAT
THE SECRETARY MENTION. CLOSE
AND CONNECTED WORK WITH
DIRECTOR GIL DUTY ACT HELLO
YEAH THAT'S ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BRING
ADDITIONAL SPACE TO TREATMENT
CAPABILITY AND SPACE TO SAN
QUENTIN TO ENSURE THOSE WHO ARE
SHOWING FORMERLY SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OR MODERATE TO MILD
SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS. CAN BE
ADEQUATELY CARED FOR ON THE
FACILITY WITH STRONG MEDICAL
PERSONNEL DIRECTOR QUIT MEANS
AND MEDICINES IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF THEY CAN AVOID
GOING TO THE OUTSIDE
FACILITIES. THAT WERE ABLE TO
DO THAT IN A SAFE AND
MEANINGFUL WAY THAT IF CHORUS
IN SURE IS THAT THOSE WHO NEED
A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE HAVE
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO THOSE
SERVICES BOTH WITHIN THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND IN THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE. ALTHOUGH THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION THE
RULES AND LESSONS WE'VE LEARNED
FROM PRIOR OUTBREAKS IN PRISONS
IN CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS-
HOLD TRUE TODAY IN THIS SETTING
AND I JUST WANT UNDER SCHOOL OR
BEFORE I TURN IT BACK TO YOU
CHAIRWOMAN WHAT YOU SAID THIS
IS NOT JUST A SAN QUENTIN
ISSUE. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
LEARN THE LESSONS AND THIS OF
ALL BEING PANDEMIC AND ENSURE
THAT WE NOT ONLY TAKE THOSE
INTO ACCOUNT AT SAN QUENTIN BUT
ALL OF THIS ALREADY AND MY
ENTIRE AGENCY AND OUR
DEPARTMENTS CONTINUOUS READY
THE SERVER. PARTNER WITH
SECRETARY VIA AS AN OLD THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT WE PUT OUR BEST
FOOT FORWARD. FOR A VERY
VULNERABLE POPULOUS. THANK YOU
SECRETARY KELLY- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
IS SINCE HE HAS LIMITED TIME
AND MUST LEAVE AT TEN. I WOULD
LIKE TO DIRECT SOME QUESTIONS
IN BEFORE RETURNED OTHER
PANELISTS BEFORE WE DIRECTOR
QUESTIONS TO- THE REST THE
PANELISTS. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
START WITH ONE. TE DOCTOR
GOLLY IN THE NOON BRIEFINGS
WITH THE GOVERNOR YOU ENTER THE
GOVERNOR HAVE POINTED MANY
TIMES TO OCCUR. CAN YOU USE
THAT CURVE TO GO TO GUIDE THE
REST OF US IN RELATIONSHIP TO-
HOW TO FIND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WAS SUCH
CURVE ANALYSIS DONE FOR CDC OUR
FACILITIES. AND IF AND IF IT
HASN'T BEEN IF IT WASN'T IN THE
PAST ARE YOU DOING ONE NOW. IT
HAS IT HAS NOT BEEN DONE AND
IMPLORED AID- MANY OF THOSE
MODELS AND CURBS REQUIRE US TO
HAVE ACCURATE MASON ABOUT THE
LEVEL OF IN FACT TO SPREAD.
WHAT WE TALK ABOUT IS THE ARE A
FACTOR AND WE CAN CERTAINLY
CREATE THAT AND HAVE AT LEAST
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS AROUND
HOW TO CREATE THAT NOT JUST
SYSTEM WIDE BUT IT WOULD BE
NEEDED TO WORK HER ACROSS ANY
FACILITY AND WHAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE US TO DO. IS BOTH
UNDERSTAND THE LEVEL OF- SORT
OF- HOW CLOSE IN MAKES ARE TO
ONE ANOTHER OBVIOUSLY THE LEVEL
OF SO PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEN AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS
GOING. DESIGNING CURVES IT IS
JACK CREATED FOR LARGE
COMMUNITY IS WHERE THERE IS
GENERAL FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT AND
MIXING- AND TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
SOME OF THE NON PHARMACEUTICAL
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING INCLUDING BASED
COVERINGS. AND NINETY FIVES AND
OTHERP. B. AS WELL AS PHYSICAL
DISTANCING I THINK THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE TIME NOW THAT
AS A FIVE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT EFFORTS IS MAKING
SURE THAT OUR COLLABORATIVE
PLAN FOR TESTING AND SECRETARY
DHEAS I KNOW IS WORKING HARD
ALONG WITH OUR OUR TEAMS. TO
ENSURE THAT THAT TESTING IS
AVAILABLE TO STOP THE RECEIVER
TO MAKING SURE THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL INMATES WILL
BE EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION AND THAT TEST
POSITIVITY REPEAT THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO BUILD THOSE MODELS
FOR ALL OF US THANK YOU DOCTOR.
I HAVE TO SAY THOUGH I'D DO NOT
FEEL THAT TO SATISFACTORY
ANSWER IN THAT. THIS IS A-
POPULATION THAT'S IN CUSTODY
AND THE PEOPLE THAT DO WITH
THEM OR STAFF OF THE STATE SO
AND THIS IS A POPULATION THAT
WE CONTROL. THE TEMPO THE STAFF
IN IT AND THE PEOPLE IN SO. IF
YOU WERE IN THE TESTING COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE THE- IN COULD
HAVE BEEN MANDATED THE WEARING
OF MASKS COULD HAVE BEEN
MANDATED ALL OF THE THINGS THAT.
THAT ARE COUNTIES ARE TELLING
THE REST OF US THIS IS EIGHT
EIGHTY. AN ENTITY THAT IS EVEN
MORE. CONDUCIVE TO SUCH THINGS
JUST BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
THE CONTROL WE HAVE OVER THE
INDIVIDUALS- SO IT'S- I DON'T
FEEL VERY SATISFIED WITH THE
ANSWER AND I WOULD SAY THAT TO
BOTH CDC ARE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. BY STARTED
RAISING THE QUESTION OF TESTING
BACK IN EARLY APRIL AND I KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA DID NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO PASS BUT AS
WE WATCH THE OUTBREAK IN
NURSING HOMES AND WE KNEW THAT
AND WE BEGAN TO NOTICE NOT
NOTICE BUT LEARN THE- SPREAD BY
PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT
SYMPTOMATIC. THIS TESTING
REALLY REALLY WHAT'S NECESSARY
IN THIS LARGEST CONCORD
FACILITY AND APOLOGIES I SHOULD
STOP EXPRESSING FRUSTRATION AND
LET AMONG EIGHT. MEMBERS SO AT
QUICK. SENATOR MORAL SENATOR
MAY I JUST- YES I MEANT FOR ONE
BRIEF COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO SEPARATE OUT THE ANSWER
AROUND THE MODELING OKAY WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD AND
CAN BE DONE AND EVER. BILL IN
ALL OF THE AND- MEN'S I THINK I
REALLY DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE- THE PLAN AROUND
TESTING AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND TESTING OR ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE WE'VE BEEN
PARTNERING ON INSURING THAT
THOSE- THOSE TESTS YEAH DON
SCALE AND SECRETARY DE HAS
MENTIONED- A SECURE IN NUMBER
OF TASKS. THAT ENOUGH IS THERE
MORE TO DO ABSOLUTELY I AM THE
FIRST TO SAY THAT THE GLOBAL
TESTING CHALLENGE IN CALIFORNIA.
WAS ARE YOU KNOW REALLY
MULTIPLE FACTORS BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY I TAKE THEM WE TAKE
A SERIOUS RESPONSIBILITY TO
STARTING NOW WITH NOT ENOUGH
TESTING NOT JUST IN OUR
CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS OF
THOSE THAT ARE RUN BY THE STATE
BUT- WHY. AND TODAY. WE REALLY
REYES STOP START FROM JUST
DAY BACK IN APRIL TWO TODAY-
ACHIEVED OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND TESTS ON SOME DAYS.
THINGS TO ME AND THAT'S IT ALL
OF YOU IS TESTING IS. AND MANY
OF OUR FACILITIES AND ITS
RAMPING UP SO THAT SHOULD
BECOME SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS US
MORE INTELLIGENCE INTO THE
SITUATIONS IN THE FACILITIES
ALLOWS US TO PLAN BETTER THERE
IS NO DISPUTE BUT MORE COULD BE
AND SHOULD BE DONE. SO I WOULD
HESITATE TO LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
WITH THE IMPRESSION THAT I OR
ANY OF US BELIEVE THAT THE-
RESPONSE HAS BEEN SATISFACTORY
AND THAT MORE SHOULD AND CAN BE.
THANK YOU CENTER MORE BLACK
THANK THANK YOU MAY TURN THANK
YOU DOCTOR GOLLY FOR- DEALING
WITH THIS CRISIS MANAGEMENT-
SITUATION. WE'RE DEALING WITH
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY APPEAR TO
WILL- PERCEIVE AND THEY'RE
OBSERVING. THAT WERE NEGLECTING
NURSING HOMES IN PRISONS. AND
ALL THEY SEE IS BEING TOLD THE
CLOSE BEACHES AND RENTAL HAS
SAID ARE USED SO WE'RE- TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COMMUNICATE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND HOW CAN I
BEST TELL THEM HOW YOU SELECT
PRIORITIES. DOCTOR GROWING YOUR
MUTED AGAIN. WE STILL CAN'T
HEAR YOU. OKAY NOW I ARE YOU
HERE ON ME TO GO AHEAD CAN YOU
HEAR US NOW YES YES SEEMS LIKE
EACH TIME WE HAVE TO ON MUTE SO
YEAH RIGHT TO BE QUICKER DOING
THAT- I THINK IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND THE
ISSUING CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES IS- CLEARLY THE
FRONT DOOR BY IS WHERE THE
INFECTION COMES AND- AND BASED
ON THE LEVEL OF MAKE SCENE
BETWEEN STAFF AND RESIDENTS
WHETHER THOSE ARE IN MAY TO
RESIDENTS IN A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY. WE BEGIN TO SEE A
VERY RAPID SPREAD RATE SO OUR
NUMBER ONE STRATEGY IS TO
ENSURE THAT IN ANY CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITY THAT WE PREVENT
INFECTION COME COMING IN THE
FRONT DOOR I WILL SAY SENATOR
MORE LIKE THAT WE HAVE HAD A
NUMBER OF SUCCESS STORIES
WITHIN AND SOME OF THE
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES
WHERE AND WE MIGHT EVEN AT A
LARGER RATE. IN THAT SETTING
BUT HAVE BEAT THROUGH SOME VERY
FULL TRIED AND TRUE FRANKLY
INFECTION CONTROL STRATEGIES
AND ABLE TO SEPARATE STAFF.
EIGHT RESIDENTS ARE IN MAY. AND
ALLOW YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCE. IN TERMS OF
ILLNESS IN DOUBT- THE OUTBREAK
TO SETTLE DOWN AND THEN
INSTITUTE. SERIAL TESTING AND
SURVEILLANCE TESTING TO PROTECT
FURTHER OUTBREAKS WE'VE DONE
THOUGH IN A NUMBER OF
FACILITIES NOT JUST IN THE
SKILLED NURSING SETTING BUT
ASSISTED LIVING SETTING I KNOW-
SECRETARY TIAS HAS SIMILAR
STORIES SO IT CAN CERTAINLY BE
DONE AND HAS BEEN DONE I WOULD
SAY THAT PART OF WHAT WE SEE
ABSOLUTELY YEARS AS COMMUNITY
SPREADING INCREASES. SO THE
CURRENT WAVE OF INCREASED CASES
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES ARE LOW
ARE- EARLY INDICATORS OF THE
SPREAD THAT WE WILL AGAIN SEE
IN SOME OF OUR CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITY. SO WITH THIS INCREASE
AND COMMUNITY SPREAD WE HAVE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OUR OWN VIGILANCE AND SOME OF
THOSE CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES THE OTHER POINT OF
OUR IMPORTANCE IS OUR
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES
WHETHER THEIR JAILS AND PRISONS
FOR NURSING HOMES OR OTHER
SETTING. TO HAVE SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
HEALTH. THE NUMBER OF MORE IS
AND HAND UP MEDICAL WITHIN. IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHETHER AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE STATE
LEVEL IS EXTREMELY HIGH
COMPARED TO OUR- COMMUNITIES-
ARE ARE- I'M NOT. IN CONGREGATE
SETTING COMMUNITIES AND THAT
DOES. PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO
THE LEVEL OF VULNERABILITY
AROUND KOBE NINETEEN WE
CONTINUE TO REFINE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHICH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS LEND
THEMSELVES TO THE WORST
OUTCOMES THE CDC AND PRACTICED
UPDATED OVER THE WEEKEND THE
LIST OF TIERED. CONDITIONS THAT
SEEM TO HAVE THE HIGHEST RISK
OF BAD OUTCOMES WITH PREVENT
NINETEEN AND THE STATE LOOKS AT
THAT AND UPDATES OUR OWN
GUIDANCE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR GO JUST TWO QUICK
QUESTION SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY BACKGROUND MATERIALS FOR
THIS THIS HEARING- THERE ARE
TWO THINGS I'D LIKE TO. I
UNDERSTAND OR OR HAVE SOME.
DATA PROVIDED ONE IS WHAT IS
THE FLU- STATISTICS SO HOW MANY
DEATHS DO WE SEE IN PRISONS
YEAR OVER YEAR- SO DO WE HAVE
ANYTHING THAT'S ABNORMAL OR
ABOVE THAT THE TREND. AND THE
SECOND IS HOW HOW'S CALIFORNIA
IT'S PRISON SYSTEM- DOING
COMPARED TO THE OTHER FORTY
NINE STATES ARE ARE- PER CAPITA
NUMBERS SIMILAR ABOVE OR BELOW-
SO IF YOU HAVE THAT INFORMATION
NOW THAT BE GREAT BUT OTHER
OTHERWISE I'D I'D LIKE TO. SEE
A JUST THE- ELITE ANALYZE HOW
WE'RE DOING- YEAR OVER YEAR AND
STATE BY STATE THANK YOU. YEAH
WE DON'T I DON'T HAVE IT TODAY
BUT WILL WORK WITH A CD PH AS
WELL AS OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES ON
THIS PANEL TO GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION SO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WELCOME AND ARE
MORE LIKE A DOCTOR GOING FOR
YOU ARE NO LONGER. ABLE STAY
WITH US I HAVE A QUESTION. ON
THE COURTS PUT OUR PRISONS
UNDER RECEIVERSHIP WE HAVE A
RECEIVER NOW FOR THAT HEALTH.
BUT THAT RECEIVERS ALSO OVER
TIME TURNED CERTAIN FACILITIES
ABOUT HALF THE FACILITIES BACK
OVER TO SEE THE SHORE SO IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING IN THAT
PROCESS THAT HALF ABOUT HALF
THE FACILITIES ARE STILL UNDER
THE RECEIVER AND ANOTHER HALF
OR NOT. NOW THE RECEIVER WHEN
WE HEAR FROM IN MAY INDEED THE
STORE'S RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
WHOLE SYSTEM I DON'T KNOW. BUT
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE ARE A-
DEBT THIS IS OF OBVIOUSLY A
SYSTEM WIDE PROBLEM. AND THAT
IT NEEDS COMPETENT PUBLIC
HEALTH MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
WHETHER EPIDEMIOLOGISTS OR
OTHERS TO BE CALLING THE SHOTS
AS TO WHAT HAPPENS AND
DEVELOPING A PLAN SO I'D LIKE
TO KNOW FROM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
VOTE OF HER. PERSON ALL WILL BE
DOES THE- TO OVERSEE. THIS WHAT
HOW WE RESPOND TO THIS OUTBREAK
AND CONTAINING IT AND ALL TO
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF DEATHS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I'M
GOING TO LET SUSAN FINALE
ANSWER MOST OF THAT QUESTION
BUT I WILL SAY THAT SECRETARY
DHEAS MENTIONED OUR HOT
ACTIVATION OF THE INCIDENT
COMMAND TEAM WHICH WILL
INCLUDE. EXTRA CHEESE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL FOR AROUND-
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND TRACKING THE
DISEASE INFECTION CONTROL AND
THOSE SUPPORTS ARE AVAILABLE
AND- COMING TO BEAR ON THAT
TEAM. THAT INCIDENT CAME AREN'T
ONLY FOR SAN QUENTIN OR FOR THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. BASS AND
MICHELLE INCIDENT. TEAM IS
FORCING QUENTIN BUT I KNOW
SECRETARY DS'S SHARED- I'LL
PLAN ENVISIONED FOR EXTENDING
MAD AND WE ARE READY TO PARTNER
AND PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE CAN IN NEED SO THE RESPONSES
ADEQUATE I THINK WE AS A AGENCY
ARE CONTINUE TO STAND READY. TO
PROVIDE BOTH GUIDANCE AND
ASSISTANCE IN ANY WAY THAT WE
CAN- AND- IF IT REQUIRES ALSO
SELLS TO BRING ON ADDITIONAL
STAFF. WILL DO WHAT WE CAN
EXPEDIENCY AND TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND GRAVITY
OF THE SITUATION AS I'VE SAID
IN OTHER PRESS CONFERENCES AND
OTHER HEARING. THERE IS A LIVE
VIRUS THEY GO. IN ORDERS FROM
ZERO SIXTY VERY QUICKLY WE SEE
THAT BY THE TIME YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE A CHANCE TO TEST OF
EVERYONE THAT A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE INFECTED AND THAT WE
HAVE TO DO WHAT I STARTED THIS-
SORT OF MY BRIEF COMMENTS WITH
IN TERMS OF SEPARATING OUT
THOSE WHO ARE IN GOOD IN THOSE
WHO ARE NOT IN CONTINUING THE
TAP SO WE READY TO CAN YOU. SEE
FOR A SECOND D. AS AND THE
RECEIVER IN ANY WAY THAT- IT IS
NEEDED AND OF COURSE TO ADD OUR
EXPERTISE THROUGH PROVIDING
GUIDANCE AND THEN ON BLOOM WAY.
ISSUED A CHANCE TO. SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS AND IF THERE ARE
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME- I CAN
BE REACHED DIRECTLY OR- THROUGH
THROUGH STAFF AND I'D BE-
HONORED TO PROVIDE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS I CAN. DOWN THE
ROAD THNK YOU THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN GIVING
PROVIDING US THE INFORMATION
YOU HAVE AND I'M SURE WE WILL
HAVE. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS-
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO NOW MEMBERS
IS TURNED TO SEASON FINALE. AND
THEN WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
RECEIVER AND THEN WE CAN OPEN
QUESTIONS TO ALL TO. THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF- POLISHING PROGRAMS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THE RECEIVER AND ALSO THE
SECRETARY DS. SO LET'S NOW TO
ON SEASON FINALE. MORNING
BURNED BY US TO THE STATEMENT
HERE MY NAME SYSTEM LA NINE THE
CHEAP. YEAH FOR QUALITY PROGRAM.
IN THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH. AND
WAS ASKED TO GIVE A LITTLE
CONTACTS NATIONALLY THERE ARE
TWO POINT SIX MILLION CORRECT
CASES. AND TOTAL DEATHS OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE.
WE NOW IN CALIFORNIA HAVE OVER
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
CASES- WITH A NEW CASES
CLIMBING EACH DAY- AND
RESULTING IN. A TOTAL OF. IN
THE LAST TWENTY HOURS A NUMBER
THAT RELATING HE SAYS INCREASED
BY TWO POINT 9% AND DEATHS
INCREASED FIVE POINT 7% SO
CLEARLY A PROBLEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE
INCREASED- YESTERDAY BY THREE
HUNDRED CASES FOR A OTAL OF-
HOUSING HOSPITALIZATIONS OF
FIVE THOUSAND SEVENTY SEVEN
THAT'S LIKE AN INCREASE OF SIX
POINT THREE PERCENT. AT THE
BEGINNING OF FEBRUARY MOST
CASES ALCOVE IN NINETEEN WERE
IN RETURNING TRAVELERS THE
FIRST RECOGNIZED ME
TRANSMISSION WAS IDENTIFIED IN
LATE FEBRUARY. EARLY MARCH CASE
NUMBERS BEGAN TO INCREASE AND
ON MARCH FOURTH AND THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN CALIFORNIA AS THE
NUMBER OF CASES BEGAN TO
INCREASE- WE AND FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND PLAN AND THAT ON.
A STATE WIDE STAND HOME ORDER
PARKS NINETEEN. DURING THE
INITIAL PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC
TESTING WAS EXTREMELY LIMIT AT
INITIALLY TESTING WAS ONLY
AVAILABLE AT THE CDC CASTING
BECAME AVAILABLE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH LAB IN LATE. WARY AND
SUCCEED WE WAS AVAILABLE ON
COMMERCIAL LABORATORIES TESTING
PRIORITIZE. FOR ONLY 7% AND
BURDENS EXPOSED IN HIGH RISK
SETTINGS I'M PARTICULARLY HOW
ARE WORKERS. IN RESOURCES WERE
NOT ABLE BASS FIND HAS OR WILL.
ISN'T CORRECTION FACILITIES
UNTIL LATER. THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HATS WERE
CONDUCTED OVER. TWO MONTHS
LATER BROUGHT PEACE. TING IT
DROPPED. THE NOT. IN CALIFORNIA
NOW RE MOVED UP TO OF OVER FOR
ME AND IN OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
THE DAYS AND EACH DAY THE RATE
OF POSITIVE TESTS OVER LAST
DAYS AS FAR POINT 6% AND THE
POSITIVITY OVER THE SEVEN IS
POINT VERSE SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE IS CLIMB. AS TEST CAPACITY
AS OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEPLOYING
THIS TESTING TO CONTROL DISEASE
AND CONGREGATE SETTINGS HAS
INCREASED AS WELL WE CONTINUE A
LEARN ABOUT THE TRANSMISSION
THAT'S VERY INFECTIOUS VIRUS
WHICH IS HARD TO CONTAIN IN ANY
ENVIRONMENT BUT VERY
CHALLENGING AND CONGREGATE SAT
AT. I AM VERY GOAL. DOCTOR
GODLY WENT OVER OUR TO PREVENT
THE VIRUS FROM ENTERING THE
FACILITY AND TO AGGRESSIVELY
WORK TO REDUCE TRANSMISSION
WHAT A CASE OR CASES ARE
IDENTIFIED. SECTION CONTROL
MEASURES WILL NOT STOP ALL
INFECTIONS AS MANY STATE. AS
MANY STAFF AND MAYES MAY
ALREADY BE EXPOSED TO MAY
DEVELOP SYMPTOMS OVER. THE NEXT
TEN TO FOURTEEN DAYS ONCE THE
FIRST CASES ARE RECOGNIZED
RECOMMEND AYE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO TASTIC WRESTLING WILL RESULT
IN THE GROWTH OF THE NUMBER OF
CASES AS A SYMPTOMATIC CASES
WILL BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH THAT
TESTING. THE PAGE HAS BEEN
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION-
AND CCH THE ASK THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. SERVES AS A
TECHNICAL CONSULTANT TO CDC ARE
AN A RECEIVER FOR STATE PRISON
OUTBREAK'S ACROSS THE STATE.
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC WE ASSIST
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A GENERAL
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT POSTED ON THE
DVR WEBSITE PROVIDED ALL OF
GUIDANCE ON HOW GREAT GREAT
CONTROL. WE HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN NUMEROUS MEETINGS AND
PROVIDE A VERBAL AND WRITTEN
GUIDANCE ON SPECIFIC PERSON
SITUATIONS WE DO HAVE DEDICATED
STAFF ABOUT HELP WITH THIS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. GIVE AND-
AND EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE SOME
STANDARDIZED GUIDANCE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT GIVEN THE LAY
OUT OF THE PRISON THE GENERAL
ASIAN HEALTH OF THE INMATES IN
A PARTICULAR BIRDS. PRESENT THE
AVAILABILITY OF STAFF AND THE
PROVISION OF PP AND ANY
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES MAKE IT
NECESSARY TO HAVE INDIVIDUAL
PLANS. WHEN CASES IN BOYS OR
INMATES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
SEE PAGE HAS PROVIDED VERBAL
GUIDANCE ON THAT SITUATION AND
HAS BEEN TRACKING CASES OF DVR
HAS BEEN TRACKING THOSE CASES
AND- EMPLOYEES AND PROVIDING
DATA ON THEIR WEBSITE. TESTING
SURE SHORTAGES WERE PROBLEM
ACROSS THE STATE NATION EARLY
ONSET CVH WORK VERY HARD TO
DEVELOP AND THE TESTING PLAN
PROVIDING OPTIONS FOR MATCHING
AVAILABLE LABORATORY RESOURCES.
FOR BOTH SPECIMEN COLLECTION
AND CONDUCTING LABORATORY TESTS
OF THE NEEDS OF PERSONS ACROSS
THE STATE. EVEN WITH EXPANDED
TESTING FACILITY SOMETIMES
BASED LONGER OF AN IDEAL TURN
AROUND TIMES AND- ALLOWING THEM
TO BETTER MANAGE THE SITUATION.
MORE RECENTLY WE ASSIST IN
PROVIDING AN OVERALL TESTING
STRATEGY SIMILAR TO THE
STRATEGIES EMPLOYED BY SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. INCLUDING
BOTH SURVEILLANCE TESTING
PRISONS WITH NO ACT BREAKS YOU
PRIOR BASELINE TESTING- OVER.
EACH WEEK MORE AGGRESSIVE
SERIAL CAUGHT DOWN AND
FACILITIES WITHOUT BREAKS.
EXISTING I'M NOT POSITIVE BUT
SALUTE ALLOW FOR REALLY COME
HARDING I THESE A- CASES AND
ALLOWS THIS AT LEAST YOUR- THE
COORDINATES AND ALL LIMIT THE
MOVE OF STAFF AND THE- I'M IN
ADDITION WE WORKED. DEVELOP A
MORE DETAILED INFECTION CONTROL
GUIDANCE WITH VERY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS- BETTER ADAPTED
TO THE NEEDS OF EACH PRESENT.
THIS GUIDANCE PROVIDES
STRATEGIES FOR PREVENTING STAFF
FROM INTRODUCING THE VIRUS WHEN
THEN THE FACILITY AND
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO
CONTAINING THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE. THESE STRATEGIES
INCLUDE PREVENTION AND CONTROL
INTERVENTIONS INCLUDING
MONOGRAM ALL STAFF AND INMATES
FOR SIGNS OF AND SYMPTOMS
UNIVERSAL MASKING BY STAFF AND
INMATES FOR SOURCE CONTROL USE
OF RECOMMENDED PERSONAL.
REQUIREMENTS MAINTAINING UP
CRITICAL DISTANCING AND
ENVIRONMENTAL. CLEANING AND
DISINFECTION. THE HAS BEEN ON
THE GROUND WORKING WITH CDC AN
RECEIVER I'M PARTICULARLY. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. KOALA AVENAL IN
KINGS COUNTY- CALIFORNIANS
SUPERMAN AND SAN QUENTIN ON THE
CONTROL OF- COPING NINETEEN
IMPRISONS DEPENDS O MANY
STRATEGIES MINIMIZING
VISITATION AND NONESSENTIAL
MOVEMENT FROM OUTSIDE WORST
REYES AND SCREEN EMPLOYEES AND
ANYONE ENTERING THE PRESENTS
EQUESTRIAN MADE FOR FOURTEEN
DAYS AND ENSURING THAT
EMPLOYEES WORKING WITH
SEQUESTERED INMATES DO NOT WORK
WITHIN. THE OTHER PARTS OF
REPRESENT EXCLUDING ANY AND ALL
ILL EMPLOYEES PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING WEARING MASKS
BRANAGH AND PRACTICING SAFE HIM
HIDING FOR ALL STAFF AND
INMATES CANCEL CANCELING
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
LIMITING THE MOVEMENT I'M OF
EMPLOYEES BETWEEN DIFFERENT
WORK- AREAS QUARANTINE EXPOSED
INMATES FOR FOURTEEN DAYS I
SLIPPING APART AND- INMATES
TESTING AND EXCLUDING. EXPOSED
STAFF FROM WORK- CANNOT RUN
HOST OF OTHERS THAT WE'VE BEEN
LAYING OUT SINCE BEGINNING OF
THE- SOME OF THESE. ARE GIVE TO
ACCOMPLISH BY BALANCING THE
NEEDS OF OPERATING A PRISON
GIVEN STOPPING SHORT OF JUST
SPACE CONSTRAINTS. GAINES AND
OTHER OPERATIONAL NEEDS- AND AS
DOCTOR DOLLY AND OTHERS HVE
AND MENTIONED. WE ARE AND
TAKING A MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVE
STAND AND ON THAT COMING
TOGETHER FOR THE- SITUATION ST
MARTIN ST MARTIN- ESTABLISHING
THAT INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM.
TO COORDINATE PATIENT CARE AND
MOVEMENT- AS WELL AS TO MAKE
SURE ALL OF THESE INFECTION AND
PREVENTION STRATEGIES ARE IN
PLACE. WE CONTINUED TO
RECOGNIZE THIS CHALLENGE
CHALLENGE AND BOTH- AND ALL
CONGREGATE SETTINGS BUT
PRIMARILY IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND PRISONS
AND WE'RE HERE TO PARTNER AND-
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE DEDICATED
STAFF TO THIS EFFORT. AND ARE
HAPPY TO NOT ONLY PLAY THE ROLE
OF THE TECHNICAL. CANCEL BUT TO
BE PART OF THE THESE INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAMS. THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU FINALITY- I
WILL NOTE THAT THE VISITATION
STOCKED CDC ARE ENDED
VISITATION ALL FACILITIES.
BEFORE APRIL FIRST
ADDITIONALLY- AND MANY OF THE
THINGS YOU DESCRIBED WERE AT
LEAST BY THE DEPARTMENT'S OWN.
THE INDICATIONS IMPLEMENTED AND
YET MANY WERE NOT BUT- YET WE
HAVE THE SITUATION WE HAVE
TODAY O HOW THOROUGHLY THESE
WERE IMPLEMENTED BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT THE MOVEMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THEMSELVES STOP
THE TRANSFER FROM COUNTY JAILS
THE VISITATION WAS STOPPED ALL
OF THOSE THINGS WERE DONE. WAY
BUT LET'S NOW- TURNED TO CLARK
KELSO WHO IS THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER FOR. THE OUR STATE
PRISON SYSTEM CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MISTER COLE SO HE-
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS CLARK
KELSO I SERVICE THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEDICAL CARE WITHIN CDC ARE. I
WAS APPOINTED TO THIS POSITION
BY THE FEDERAL COURT IN THE
CLASS ACTION LITIGATION PALMER
SCHWARZENEGGER IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT. AND WAS CHARGED WITH
BRINGING THE LEVEL OF MEDICAL
CARE UP TO CONSTITUTIONAL
SANDERS AS RECEIVER I EXERCISE
ALL THE POWERS THAT SECRETARY
DIAZ POSSESSES BUT WITH RESPECT
ONLY TO THE DEPARTMENTS MEDICAL
CARE SYSTEM. THAT'S WHY BOTH
SECRETARY DIAZ AND I ARE HERE
TODAY. A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE AN
IMPROVING CDC ARE THE OVERALL
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. WHICH HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR CAPACITY TO
RESPOND TO THE COVERT RISKS.
AND I HAVE DELEGATED ON A BACK
TO THE STATE- MANAGERS YOU
NOTED THE MANAGEMENT OF
NINETEEN OF ITS THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS. WHICH IS A
PRESUMPTIVE INDICATOR THAT
THOSE INSTITUTIONS ARE
DELIVERING A CONSTITUTIONAL
LEVEL OF CARE. CODE OF COURSE
IS A NEW AND SYSTEM WIDE
CHALLENGE AND SO I WORKED MOST
CLOSELY WITH SECRETARY DIAZ AND
UNDERSECRETARY FOR HEALTHCARE
DIANA SO SEAN COVERT MATTERS.
FACED WITH THE CRISIS OF CODE
OUR COLLABORATION HAS NEVER
BEEN CLOSER. I'D LIKE TO GIVE
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR PLANNING AND
EFFORTS TO COMBAT COBRE
NINETEEN OVER THE LAST FOUR
MONTHS. SOME COMMENTS ON THE
CRISIS AT SAN QUENTIN AND A
BRIEF STATUS REPORT AND THEN OF
COURSE THE QUESTION. PLANNING
AS YOU. BEGAN A LATE. BOB AS
YOU KNOW CDC ARE ESSENTIALLY
OPERATES THE LARGEST CONGREGATE
LIVING FACILITIES IN THE STATE
WHICH ARE PERFECT FACILITIES
FOR THE SPREAD OF COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE. SO ON MARCH ELEVENTH A
CBC OURS PUBLIC HEALTH BRANCH
ISSUED ITS FIRST CODE GUIDANCE
TO THE INSTITUTIONS- ARE BASED
IN PART IN INCLUDING LINKS TO
GUIDANCE PUBLISHED BY THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION. AND WE BEGAN
POSTING THAT GUIDANCE ON OUR
INTRANET AGES. WE ALSO RELEASED
OUR PUBLIC FACING INTERNET
SITES THAT CONTAIN THE COBRA
TRACTOR FOR THE PRISONS. A CDC
OURS CO WOULD PREPAREDNESS BABY
IS AND HEALTH CARE AS INTERIM
GUIDANCE. OF THE INTERIM
GUIDANCE PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE IT
HAS THE BASICS TO HELP COMBAT
ON OUR- INCLUDING THE- ON TEST
I SAW. CONTACT TRACING
QUARANTINE MONITORING HOSPITAL
REFERRALS- EVERYTHING THE
DOCTOR GALLEY HAS MENTIONED.
BUT TWO DAYS LATER ON MARCH
THIRTEENTH SECRETARY IDEAS AND
I SENT OUT OUR FIRST
COMMUNICATION DAHLE CDC OUR
EMPLOYEES TO BE IN REORIENTING
EVERYONE TO THE CHALLENGES THAT
WERE CUT OFF. AND OUR FIRST
CASE OCCURRED ONLY ONE WEEK
LATER ON MARCH TWENTIETH FC I
AM THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
FOR MEN. NO DURING MARCH AND
APRIL AS YOU'VE HEARD CD'S YARD
TOOK A SERIES OF IMPORTANT
STATUS- INCLUDING ESTABLISHING
AN OVERALL COOPER NINETEEN
COORDINATOR STANDING UP THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS CENTER.
SENDING OUT GUIDANCE FOR
FACILITY ENTRANCE SCREENING FOR
ALL STAFF. IMPLEMENTING IT
IMPLEMENTING AN ACCELERATED
RELEASE PROGRAMS. IMPOSING
SEVERE RESTRICTIONS ON IN
TROUGH FACILITY MOVEMENT
SHUTTING DOWN VISITATIONS
HOLDING ALL NONESSENTIAL
TRANSFERS BETWEEN PRISONS. AND
THE CLOSING CDC ARE TO INTAKE.
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT SEE I
AM BROUGH SLOWLY DURING APRIL-
BUT CASES SPIKE ON MAY FIRST
THE JUMPING FROM NINETY ONE TO
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN. AND
THE NUMBER OF CASES CONTINUED
CLIMBING REACHING A HIGH OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
BY MAY FIFTEENTH. AS A RESULT
DURING THE FIRST THREE WEEKS OF
MAY- WE CONSIDERED WHETHER WE
COULD SAFELY MOVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF THOSE. VULNERABLE
PATIENTS THE NEGATIVES TO
ANOTHER FACILITY. WITH THE GOAL
OF SAVING LIVES. THE DECISION
INVOLVED THE BALANCING OF THE
GROWING RISKS TO THE SEA I AM
PATIENTS AGAINST THE RISKS OF
ANY LARGE SCALE TRANSFER. WE
WERE ALSO CONSIDERING IN MAY
HOW THE DEPARTMENT GOOD SLOWLY
BEGAN RE OPENING AND
REESTABLISHING SOME OF ITS
NORMAL PROCESS. AND ON MAY
TWENTY TWO A MEMORANDUM WAS
DISTRIBUTED TO THE FIELD
ANNOUNCING CDC OURS PHASED
APPROACH WHICH INCLUDED A SLOW
RE OPENING OF INTAKE. AND THE
RESUMPTION OF IN OUR
INSTITUTION WITH. ATTACHED TO
THAT MEMORANDUM WAS A COLD
SCREENING AND TESTING MATRIX
FOR PATIENT MOVEMENT. OF THE
NATION THE MATRIX PROVIDED
AMONG OTHER THINGS BUT A
TRANSFERRING PATIENT SHOULD
RECEIVE A CODE TEST BUT A
PATIENT COULD TRANSFER ONLY IF
THE TEST WAS NEGATIVE AND THE
NO INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE
TRANSFERRED TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION PRIOR TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF THEIR TEST
RESULTS. ON OR ABOUT MAY TWENTY
THIRD WE DECIDED THAT THE
EXPANDING CASES AB CIM. POSED
AN UNACCEPTABLE RISK TO THE
LAST REMAINING DORM. WHERE
HUNDREDS OF CODE HIGH RISK
PATIENTS WERE HOUSE. AND THE
DECISION WAS TAKEN TO MOVE
THOSE PATIENTS OUT OF SEE I AM.
SOMEONE MOVED TO CORCORAN AND
THE REMAINDER WERE MOVED TO SAM
QUITE. BECAUSE THE MATRIX- DID
NOT SPECIFY THAT THE REQUIRED
NEGATIVE COPE WITH TEST HAD TO
OCCUR WITHIN ONLY A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME IN RELATION TO
THE TRANSFER SUCH AS SEVEN DAYS
OR LESS. WHEN THE MOVES WERE
MADE OUT OF SEE I AM ALTHOUGH
ALL PATIENTS HAD NEGATIVE TEST
RESULT. IN MANY CASES THE TESTS
WERE TWO THREE AND IN SOME
CASES FOUR WEEKS ALL. FAR TOO
OLD TO BE A RELIABLE INDICATOR
FOR THE ABSENCE OF CO. AS IT
TURNED OUT. TO OF THE SIXTY SIX
PATIENTS MOVED TO CORCORAN
TESTED POSITIVE WHEN THEY WERE
RETESTED AT CORCORAN. S. ONE
NEGATIVE COCHRAN HAS BEEN
MANAGING THEIR OUTBREAK PRETTY
WELL SO FAR THEY HAVE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE CASES ACTIVE
THIRTY CASES HAVE ALREADY
RESOLVED AND THEY HAVE HAD
FORTY SEVEN OF THE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE CASES IN THE LAST
FOURTEEN DAYS. THEY'VE SENT OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL ONLY ONE
PATIENT. WHEN OF COURSE BEEN A
VERY DIFFERENT STORY AND DEALS
IN CRISIS. UPON RETESTING OF
SAN QUENTIN TWENTY FIVE OUT OF
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TO
TRANSFER RES TESTED POSITIVE.
AND SAN QUENTIN ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY FELL BEHIND THE BAR
STE. ON JUNE TWELVE I ASKED THE
DOCTOR RE WILLIAMS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. AND THE DOCTOR STEP
RETURNS THE FROM THE UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO CONDUCT AN IN PERSON
ASSESSMENT. THEY VISITED THE
PRISON THE NEXT DAY ON JUNE
THIRTEENTH AND REPORTED SERIOUS
RESOURCE DEFICIENCIES ON THE
PHYSICAL PLANT. IN COVERT
SUPPORT STAFFING INDIAN TEST.
THE FOLLOWING DEFICIENCIES MOST
OF WHICH WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THEIR REPORT. REALLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE RAPID SPREAD
OF CODE BUT IT STANDPOINT.
FIRST DEPRIVED YOUR CELL BLOCKS
LIKE GOOD VENTILATION AND I
HAVE A VIRUS SPREAD
CHARACTERISTICS SIMILAR TO A
DORMITORY SETTING. EVEN THOUGH
IN MAYES OUR HOUSE IN CELLS AND
ALSO. THE VIRUS SPREAD VERY
RAPIDLY IN THOSE CONDITIONS.
SECOND WE HAD TESTING TURN
AROUND TIME PROBLEMS. NO WE DID
NOT HAVE THIS PROBLEM AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS WERE WE
SUCCESSFULLY CONTAINED THE
VIRUS BUT WE HAVE THIS PROBLEM
AT SAN QUENTIN. OUR VENDOR IS
AGREED TO PUT OUR TEST AT A
HIGHER PRIORITY WITHIN THEIR
TESTING SYSTEM. AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE BIO OF IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO PERFORM SOME OF
OUR TEST. WE HAVE COMPLETED THE
FIRST ROUND OF TESTING OF ALL
PATIENTS ON SAN QUENTIN WHO
CONSENTED TO BE TEST. THIRD
MANY PATIENTS AT SAN QUENTIN
REFUSED BEING TESTED OR EVEN
BEING ASSESSED FOR SYMPTOMS.
THE FOR EXAMPLE BETWEEN TWO AND
THREE HUNDRED PATIENTS IN EAST
BLOC ARE REFUSING TEST AND
ASSESS. AND THAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE THE
OUTBREAK. YESTERDAY THE PRISON
LAW OFFICE OFFERED TO ASSIST US
IN WORKING WITH THEIR CLIENTS
ON THIS ISSUE. AN OFFER WE OF
COURSE HAVE ACCEPTED AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE FOR THEIR HELP IN THIS
REGARD. FOURTH AND FINALLY THE
PHYSICAL LAYOUT AT SAN QUENTIN
MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
THE POPULATION DURING AN
OUTBREAK. IT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT
TO SEPARATE PATIENTS
APPROPRIATELY IN THE
INSTITUTION NEEDS ADDITIONAL
BEDS SPECS. WE HAVE HOPE LAST
WEEK BUT ONE WAY OF INCREASING
THE AVAILABLE SPACE WAS TO MOVE
ONE HUNDRED INMATES FROM THE
SAN QUENTIN GYMNASIUM. TO AN
EMPTY WEARING OF HOUSING UP
NORTH KERN STATE PRISON. TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THAT
TRANSPORT. WE HAD ADOPTED A
MUCH STRICTER TRANSPORT TESTING
POLICY. SO THAT ALL ONE HUNDRED
PATIENTS HAD TO RECEIVE A
NEGATIVE COBRA TEST NO MORE
THAN FORTY EIGHT HOURS PRIOR TO
THE TRANSPORT. ON SATURDAY WE
LEARN THE TWO OF THOSE PATIENTS
HAVE RECEIVED POSITIVE TEST
RESULTS AND WE CANCEL THE
ENTIRE MOVIE. AS OF THIS
MORNING TEN POINT REPORTS SO
I'LL LET ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN ACTIVE CASES WITH EIGHT
HUNDRED AND NINE OF THOSE
OCCURRING IN THE LAST FOURTEEN
DAYS. WE HAVE HAD ONE DEATH OF
A PATIENT WHO TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVERT NINETEEN. WE HAVE
FORTY TWO HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
ARE OUT OF STANDPOINT. I
BELIEVE DURING THE WEEK OF JULY
SIX IT IS LIKELY THAT WE SHOULD
BE SEEING A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THE POSITIVE CASES AT SAN
QUENTIN PERHAPS AS MANY AS
THREE HUNDRED. MOVE FROM ACTIVE
TO RESOLVE THE STATUS SINCE WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST THAT
MANY POSITIVESWHO ARE STILL A
SYMPTOMATIC. OUR TWO BIGGEST
CONCERNS NOW ARE INSUFFICIENT
RESOURCES THAT STAND POINT TO
HANDLE THE ENORMITY OF THE
CRISIS. IN THE CAPACITY OF
LOCAL HOSPITALS TO DEAL WITH
THE FLOW OF SAN QUENTIN
PATIENTS. ADMINISTRATION IS
RESPONDING TO THE RESOURCE
PROBLEM BY DIRECTING CO HELLO
YES TO ESTABLISH UNIFIED
INSTANT COMMAND HELP MANAGE THE
OUTBREAK THAT BEGAN YESTERDAY I
BELIEVE. AND WE ARE REDIRECTING
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR FROM THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
AND REGIONAL HEALTH CARE EX
EXECUTIVE TO SUPPORT
INSTITUTIONS STAFF IN THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER. THIS WILL
HELP STABILIZE RESPONSE TO THE
OUTBREAK. THE STATE HAS ALSO
FLOWN INTENDS FOR ADDITIONALCLINIC AND HOUSING SPACE AND
CAL OVER YES WILL BE BRINGING
IN A FIELD HOSPITAL TO PROVIDE
MORE BEDS AND HOUSE. WITH
RESPECT TO LOCAL HOSPITAL
CAPACITY WE ARE INFREQUENT
ONGOING CONTACT WITH BAY AREA
HOSPITALS. IN THIS POINT WE ARE
CONFIDENT THE NECESSARY
CAPACITY EXISTS. FOR EXAMPLE
SETON MEDICAL CENTER IN DALY
CITY IS MAKING ITSELF READY TO
ACCEPT AND TO ACCEPT A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF OUR
PATIENTS. AND WE HAVE OTHER
ARRANGEMENTS IN PLACE FOR
LONGER HOSPITAL. WE DO MONITOR
THIS ON A DAILY BASIS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT HOSPITAL
UTILIZATION CAN CHANGE RAPIDLY
DURING THE PANDA. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE MARIN GENERAL
HOSPITAL SAN QUENTIN'S PRIMARY
LOCAL HOSPITAL IS NOT A CELL
HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FOR
OUR LIKELY NEEDS. AND THEY IN
THE COMMUNITY ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY EVEN IN THEIR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. TO
STABILIZE PATIENTS BEFORE
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER HOSPITALS.
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
MARIN GENERAL AND IF IT APPEARS
THE MARIN GENERAL CANNOT HANDLE
FLOW ARRANGEMENTS WILL BE MADE
TO TRANSPORT PATIENTS DIRECTLY
TO OTHER HOSPITALS. IT WAS NOT
THE OVERWHELMING MARIN
GENERAL'S RESOURCES. WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THEIR CONCERT. BUT
ME CLOSE WITH A BRIEF STATUS
REPORT SYSTEM WIDE WE HAVE
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED ACTIVE CASES.
ONLY TWO HUNDRED CASES THAT
HAVE RESOLVED AND TWENTY TWO
DEATHS. THAT GIVES US AN
OVERALL DEATH RATE OF ZERO
POINT 44% WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING
THE STATISTICAL CHALLENGES OF
DIFFERENT POPULATION SIZES AND
FOUNDERS CDC YOURS CRUDE THE
DEATH RATE OF ZERO POINT FOUR
FOUR PERCENT. IS A MAGNITUDE OF
ORDER LESS THAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GO BUT DEATH RATE
WHICH IS TWO POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. IN THE UNITED STATES
IS OVERALL COOPER DEATH RATE
WHICH IS FOUR POINT 9% BOB
DON'T PUT TOO MUCH RELIANCE ON
THAT COMPARISON UNTIL WE'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. OF THE REFORM A MORE
GRANULAR- BETTER ANALYSIS OF
THE COMPARISON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT COMPARING APPLES
TO ORANGES. WE HAVE HAD VERY
LARGE OUTBREAKS IN FOR PRISONS
SAN QUENTIN WITH- I'M ALONE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN POSITIVE
STRUCK A WALL OF WITH ONE
THOUSAND AND TWIRL POSITIVES.
AVENUE ALL NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT POSITIVES AND SEE
I AM EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX POSSIBLE. THE OUTBREAK OF
CHAKRA WALLACH AND HAVING ALL
HAVE MOSTLY ROSE ALL. SEE I AM
pRESOLVED SAN QUENTIN WERE AT
THE BEGINNING. NEXT WE
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGED A MODERATE
OUTBREAK AT- CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN WHICH HAD
AT ONE TIME ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT TOTAL CASES. BUT
WHICH NOW HAS ALL SIX. ONLY ONE
OF THOSE IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN
DAY. SEE I DO EXPERIENCE ONE
DEATH. A PRISON LANCASTER ALSO
HAD A MODERATE OUTBREAK WITH
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIVES ALL OF WHOM HAVE NOW
RESOLVED WITH ZERO CASES NO
LAST FOURTEEN DAYS. WE HAVE
ANOTHER FOR PRISONS WITH
MODERATE OUTBREAKS THAT SO FAR
APPEAR TO HAVE PEAKED WITH
AROUND TWO HUNDRED OR FEWER
TOTAL CASE. FINALLY WE HAVE
FOURTEEN INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED SMALL OUTBREAKS.
THAT HAVE NOT BLOSSOMED INTO
MODERATE OR LARGE EVENTS AND A
LEVIN FACILITIES WITH NO CODE
CASES AMONG INMATES CURRENTLY
IDENTIFIED. THESE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENTS GIVEN
COVE ITS EASE OF ENTERING AND
SPREADING AND CONGREGATE
HOUSING SET. THESE NUMBERS I
THINK DO INDICATE THAT HOPE IT
DOES NOT SPREAD YEAH THROUGHOUT
THE CDC OUR SYSTEM IN AN
UNCONTROLLED TRASH. BUT GIVEN
THE GLOBAL IS GOING TO BE WITH
US FOR QUITE SOME TIME- I SHARE
EVERYONE'S CONCERNED. ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE DONE TO DATE STILL
IS NOT ENOUGH THERE IS MORE
THAT CAN BE DONE. BECAUSE THE
VIRUS HAS PLENTY OF TIME TO
CONTINUE SPREADING THROUGHOUT
THE SYSTEM. RIGHT NOW UNTIL
THINGS TO STABILIZE FURTHER
SYSTEM WIDE SECRETARY DIAZ HAS
CLOSED AND TAKE AGAIN STOP ALL
UNNECESSARY MOVEMENT BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS. REIMPOSED A
SYSTEM WIDE MODIFIED PROGRAM.
AND ADOPTED A NEW AND
CONTINUING XCELERATED RELEASE
PROGRAM. AND I KNOW THAT HE
SHARES MY VIEW THAT WE WILL NOT
OPEN AND TAKE YOUR STARK
MOVEMENT AGAIN. UNTIL WE HAVE
ASSURED OURSELVES AND OTHERS
ARE ASSURED. IT CAN BE DONE
SAFELY. THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THE PANEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CARROLL SO MEMBERS WE'VE
NOW HEARD FROM THE- PANELISTS
FOR THE FIRST PANEL SO I WILL.
OPEN IT TO QUESTIONS I WOULD
FIRST THOUGH LIKE TO ASK AND
THIS CAN BE SECRETARY DS FOR MR
CALLACE SO. WELL THERE WAS
INDICATION THAT GUIDE YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOW A LIMITED NUMBERS I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT BY.
THE DVR'S OWN STATISTICS POSTED
ON YOUR WEBSITE THERE HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE AT TWENTY
FOUR OUT OF THE THIRTY FIVE
FACILITIES THAT'S BUYING YOUR
OWN WEBSITE. NOW I WOULD
SUSPECT THERE COULD BE FAR MORE
THAN NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND IT SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED BY ALL THE
PANELISTS THUS FAR THAT NOT
EVERY INMATE IS TESTED SO SINCE
THERE'S NOT THROW TESTING WE
CAN'T KNOW. BUT ADDITIONALLY.
THERE IS STAFF WHO HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE OUT THIRTY FOUR OUT OF
THIRTY FIVE FACILITIES THE ONLY
FACILITY WHERE STAFF IS NOT
TESTED POSITIVE IN THIS IS ON
CDC OURS WEBSITE THIS YEAR
CONSERVATION CENTER HOW FOR.
ONE COURSE RATED PERSON DID
TEST POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS SO
THAT WAS THE VIRUS. PRESIDENT
WARS. AT ALL THIRTY FIVE
FACILITIES. AND WHILE THERE MAY
NOT BE ACTIVE CASES AT ALL
FACILITIES SINCE WE ALSO DO NOT
REQUIRE THE TESTING OF THE
STAFF. AND EDITION ONLY STAFF
REPORT ON WHETHER THEY HAVE
COVE IT IS SELF REPORTED I
GUESS THE POINT OF THIS IS.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO REQUIRE
STAFF TO BE TESTED AND WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO REQUIRE STAFF TO
HAVE TO INFORM THE DEPARTMENT
WHEN THEY ARE POSITIVE AND
SIMILARLY WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE MORE THOROUGH TESTING. OF
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION IN
EITHER SECRETARY DHEAS OR MR
CALL SO YOU YOU COULD RESPOND
TO. SO CALLED ALL NOT TAKE THIS
THAT TESTING. SO AS FAR AS A
STAFF TESTING GOES. WE ARE
AGGRESSIVELY TRYING TO SEEK
GREATER CONTRACTS TO PROVIDE
GREATER TESTING AT ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS BUT AS SAID
EARLIER IN MY STATEMENT IT IS
BECOMING IT IS DIFFICULT TO.
RECEIVE AND OBTAIN CONTRACTS TO
BE ABLE TO SUFFICIENTLY TEST
ALL STAFF MEMBERS AT ALL
INSTITUTIONS. AND WITH THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT CONCERN I HAVE
LEANED INTO WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
WITH DIRECTOR WG. JUST TO SEE
IF I CAN GET RESOURCES THAN
ASSISTANCE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE HAVE- BEGAN SEEKING
TO TEST AT INSTITUTIONS- WHERE
WE HAVE OUTBREAKS. STAFF ARE
REQUIRED TO LET US KNOW IF WE
IF THEY HAVE TESTED POSITIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY THEY DO LET US
THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF THAT
STAFF POSITIVES ARE REPORTED TO
US BECAUSE THEY HAVE TESTED IN
THE COMMUNITY- AT THEIR OWN
DOCTORS. THE REPORTED BACK- SO
THAT IS IN PLACE THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT OF STUFF BUT THEY
MUST LET US KNOW THAT THEY-
ALSO. MA'AM CHAIR ON THE- SIDE
OF INMATE TEST. YEAH THE THREE
AND APRIL WE'D SIMPLY AS BOBBY
GALLEYS INDICATED WE DIDN'T
HAVE ADEQUATE. WE DIDN'T HAVE
TESTING RESOURCES TO CONDUCT
THE SORT OF TESTING THAT-
WIDESPREAD TESTING THAT WOULD
LET US DO SURVEILLANCE OF HOW
MANY INSTITUTIONS HAD CODE. NOW
WE DID FINALLY- AS TESTING
RESOURCES BECAME MORE GENERALLY
AVAILABLE IN MAY. INSTITUTE A
SURVEILLANCE TESTING PROGRAM
WHERE WE DID NOT TEST ALL
INMATES BECAUSE WE STILL DIDN'T
HAVE THAT MUCH TESTING CAPACITY
BUT WE- BASED ON SOME
STATISTICAL MODEL PREPARED BY
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OF THE
DIVISION. OF TESTED
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT
SAMPLES OF THE INMATES EL ALL
INSTITUTIONS. TO SEE IF WE
COULD IDENTIFY WHERE WE HAD OUR
GOAL WOULD PRESENT IN THE
INMATE POPULATION AND WHAT IF
WE FOUND A POSITIVE CASE THEN
WE WOULD FOCUS ATTENTION ON WE
NEED TO TEST EVERYBODY OF THAT
INSTITUTION- TODAY WE HAVE-
ESSENTIALLY TWENTY THOUSAND OR
SO BUT THIRTY THOUSAND OR SO
TESTS AVAILABLE TO US. ON THAT
WE CAN USE A WEEKLY BASIS- SO-
IT IS. IT IS CURRENTLY BEING
EXAMINED HOW WE CAN EXPAND THE
SURVEILLANCE TESTING PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE DON'T THINK GUARD
SAMPLE SIZE WAS LARGE ENOUGH.
SO THAT WE COULD CATCH UP
ENOUGH PRISONS EARLY ENOUGH TO
PREVENT A LARGER OUTBREAKS SO
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF NOW
DOING THE SAME THING- SECRETARY
DEALS IS DOING ON THE EMPLOYEE
SIDE. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
CAN WE EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
BEEN MADE TO GET TESTED. WE DO
HAVE THE CHALLENGES ARE EVEN
WITH AN EXPANSION OF THAT
PROGRAM. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF INMATES REFUSING. AND THE IF
WE START SUDDENLY SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO TEST EVERY AND MADE
EVERY SEVEN DAYS I'M QUITE
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL HAVE A
VERY LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
REFUSING TO UNDERGO TESTING AT
THAT RATE. AND THAT CERTAINLY
COMPLICATES ANY EFFORTS TO-
IDENTIFY WHERE YOU HAVE. BUT
IT'S NOT AN INSURMOUNTABLE
PROBLEM BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CONSIDER IS
YOU EVALUATE. THE RESULTS
YOU'RE GETTING FROM YOUR
TESTING PROGRAM. SENATE TURN TO
SENATOR MITCHELL NOW I HAVE
MANY MORE QUESTIONS BUT ALLOW
SENATOR MITCHELL GO AHEAD. I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT I'M AT
CHAIR ON JUST I'M GOING TO
HAVE- THREE TWO TO RECEIVER D.
AND WANT TO- EXCUSE ME TO
RECEIVE HER KELSO AND WANT TO
SECRETARY DEUS. START WITH SOME
THE CAL FELL ON. I WAS STRUCK
BY YOUR STATEMENT AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR TESTIMONY
WHEN YOU REALLY BASED ON- THE
REALLY THAT THE COURT EQUATED
YOUR POSITION ON CAR QUITE
FRANKLY WITH SECRETARY D. AS IN
TERMS OF YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
WITH REGARD TO HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN THE FIFTH IN
THE PRISONS. AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR ACCOUNT BY DATE- STARTING
MID JUNE OF. WHEN YOU INTERVENE
THAT AND TOOK ACTION WITH
REGARD TO SEND CLINTON. BUT I'M
I'M CURIOUS FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT RESPONSIBILITY
TO YOU DO YOU TAKE. WITH OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF OUTBREAK
SYSTEM WIDE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL- MY RESPONSIBILITY-
FROM THE COURT ORDER- WHEN I
SAID I HAD SECRETARY DIAZ'S
POWERS. THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE COURT ORDER SAYS SO I HAVE-
HIS OPERATIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. WITH RESPECT
TO CDC ARE AS MEDICAL CARE
SYSTEM. AND THEREFORE I SHARE
ALL OF THE SAME ACCOUNTABILITY
IS ON AS THE SECRETARY. OF THE
DEPARTMENT. SO I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED FROM DAY ONE A LONG
SECRETARY DIAZ AND ON HIS
UNDERSECRETARY FOR HEALTHCARE
PLAN OF SOCIAL. ON ALL CODE
MATTERS I AND I'M ACCOUNTABLE-
EIGHT AND- RESPONSIBLE OF BOTH
FOR THE SUCCESSES. AND FOR THE
FAILURES. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
PREFER THAT. ON SECRETARY- DE
IS. TOP ABOUT THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH REGARD TO
TESTING AND FORM ONE THREE WHAT
IS YOUR INTERNAL CAPACITY HE
TALKED ABOUT NEEDING TO FIND
THE VENDOR WHO COULD MANAGE
TESTING AND SO I'M WONDERING
WHAT IS YOUR INTERNAL CAPACITY
OF GIVING YOUR ROLE AND GIVEN
THE FACT THAT HEALTH PERSONNEL
ON. ON STILL ON LARGE PART
REPORT TO YOU WHAT'S YOUR
INTERNAL CAPACITY TO RAMP UP
TESTING. FOR PERHAPS A BOWL. ON
THOSE INCARCERATED AS WELL AS-
PERSONNEL OPERATING WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. ON THE SENATE IMAGE
MY RESPONSIBILITIES- ARE TO THE
CARE OF INMATES. THE QUESTION
OF STAFF TESTING INCLUDING THE
TESTING OF MEDICAL ON OF STAFF
AND HEALTH CARE STAFF IS REALLY
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF CDC OURS
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH OFFICE
THEIR WELLNESS OFFICE- NOW NOW
I HAVE TESTING CAPACITY THAT
BUT WE ARE USING FOR INMATES
AND- BUT I'M RELUCTANT TO
DIVERT ANY OF THAT- FOR- STAFF
TESTING FAIR AND I KNOW THAT
SECRETARY DIAZ AND HIS TEAM-
THEY ARE AND HAVE BEEN IN THE
PROCESS OF. ESTABLISHING A
CONTRACTS FOR STAFF TESTING ON
BUT I NEED TO LET SECRETARY
DIAZ I THINK TO TAKE THAT PART
OF THE QUESTION. LET LET ME
REFRAME THE BECAUSE MY RE
QUESTION IS IN IN IN WHAT I
HEARD FROM SECRETARY D. AS I
GOT THE IMPRESSION THAT HE'S
LOOKING FOR AN EXTERNAL
CONTRACTED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO TEST INMATES.
SO LESLIE FAIR ENOUGH YOU'RE
ACTUALLY RIGHT LET'S LEAVE IT
ON PERSONAL ASIDE WHAT IS YOUR
INTERNAL CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF TESTING THAT WE ALL
NOW. MANY OF US HAVE ALWAYS
BELIEVED WAS NECESSARY BUT NOW
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE ON THE
SAME PAGE IN TERMS OF
CONSISTENT REGULAR TEST IN EVEN
REPEATED TESTING OF INMATES. DO
YOU HAVE THE INTERNAL COMPACT
BODY THE PROVIDE THAT TESTING
OF INMATES WITH THE. FIVE THANK
YOU CENTER ON. CLARIFICATION ON.
WE BELIEVE THAT NOW WILL HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO THE ORDINARY
SURVEILLANCE TESTING- THERE
EVEN WITH AN EXPANDED PROGRAM
THAT WE NEED TO DO OUR OWN
NURSING STAFF. IS ABLE TO
CONDUCT THAT TYPE OF TESTING
PROGRAM. WE HAVE TO OUR TEST
KITS PROVIDED BY OUR OUTSIDE
GENERAL VENDOR WHO DOES ALL OF
OUR LABORATORY TESTING. AND WE
ARE ABLE SOUND ALL OF OUR
SAMPLES TO THEM WHEN THEY GET
THE TEST RESULTS THEY ARE
IMMEDIATELY- TRANSFERRED
ELECTRONICALLY AND- ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD SYSTEMS WILL BE
GET RESULTS BACK. I YOU HAVE
OUR- ON DURING THAT. CRITICAL
TWO TO THREE WEEKS. WHEN YOU
NEED TO SUDDENLY BE TESTING
THOUSANDS OF INMATES AT ONCE
FOR THEIR WE ARE MORE CHALLENGE
OTHER TWO THINGS THAT WE DO
FIRST- WE HAPPENED OVERALL
RESOURCES TO TESTING AND AWAY
FROM MOST GENERAL HEALTH CARE
SO GENERAL HEALTH CARE
FUNCTIONS HANDLE SUFFERED
DURING THAT PERIOD. THE OTHER
THING THAT WE'VE DONE THAT I
THINK WAS HELPFUL TO ASSUME
SOME OF THE- OUTBREAKS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE HAD
ROAD- SUPPORT. WHO COULD HELP
THEM DR- SOME OF THAT SURGE
TESTING. AND OF THAT HELP WE
STILL HAVE THE PROBLEM OF SAN
QUENTIN EVEN RIGHT NOW WHERE IN
ORDER FOR EVEN AFTER WE'VE DONE
ALL THE TESTING. IN ORDER FOR
NURSES TO ACTUALLY DO TWICE
DAILY ASSESSMENTS OF PATIENTS
WITH TESTED POSITIVE. WE DON'T
THINK WE HAVE SUFFICIENT STAFF
FOR THAT- IT JUST IT IT'S A
WORKLOAD THIS MUCH HIGHER- THEN
WE ARE STAFF FOR AND WE ARE AT
SAN QUENTIN- LOOKING AT- ON
BUMPING UP THEIR STAFF
RESOURCES BOTH BY DIVERTING
NURSES FROM OTHER INSTITUTIONS
YEAH INCREASING OUR RELIANCE
REGISTRY NURSES. BOB SO DURING
THAT SURGE PERIOD WELL WHAT WE
ARE CHALLENGED. AND IS THERE A
PLAN FOR THAT THAT WE BY THEN A
THAT YOU HAVE CHALLENGE THERE
ARE OF ON PROPOSED FLEW.
PERCENT WENT THERE IS A
PROPOSED SOLUTION TO A MEDIUM
SEND NURSES FROM OTHER IN. WITH
REGISTRY THAT'S MY A LONG TERM
SOLUTION BUT BECAUSE IF WE GET
TO MONIES PRISON SIMULTANEOUSLY
HAVING LARGE OUTBREAKS WE WON'T
BE ABLE SUPPORT. SO STAFF IS AT
THIS POINT I READ I DON'T HAVE
A SOLUTION FOR IT YET.BUT THEY
ARE AT THIS POINT EXPLORING PER
WEEK. YES SIR THE STAFF AND
WHEN WE NEED. I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AND I THINK
WE'RE SEEING THIS THE BEAR.
OTHER THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FLORA NURSES. ARE WHO ARE. IN
HELPING OUT IN PROVIDING
SERVICE. OUR I THINK THE GOV
OFFICE HELLO EARLIER A NOW
APPROACH. FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
TO DO. THEIR TIME MAKE THEM SO
OF THE- SO WILL WE'RE GOING TO
BE EXT ALL OPTIONS BECAUSE AND-
ABOUT THE GOOD CITY THE NURSES
OVER THE NEXT WELL TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS IF THAT'S HOW THIS LAUGH.
WHAT WE'RE TO NEED TO HAVE MY-
CAPACITY. THANK YOU A AND I
MISTER FULL. YOUR DEATH CLEARS.
AROUND RESPONSE I THE VERY MUCH.
BUT THE SECRETARY. YOU KNOW I
AM CHAIR OF THE JOINT LETTER BY
COMMITTEE AND- THE JAIL BE SEE
THROUGH. PROVISIONS OF- SECTION
THIRTY SIX. ON CHAPTER TWO OF
STATUTES OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE
ARE THE ENTITY THAT- APPROVES
IF YOU WILL OR CAN CURSE WITH
NON BUDGET ACTION ITEMS AS
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND SO IF YOU'LL LET
ME MADAM CHAIR JUST VERY
BRIEFLY. TO FOR THE RECORD FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE
IN ALL BIG KNOWLEDGE THE
MULTIPLE FICTION THIRTY SIX
REQUEST LETTERS WE HAVE
RECEIVED. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WITH
REGARD TO REIMBURSING COUNTIES
FOR HOUSING INMATES. DUE TO THE
TEMPORARY STOPPAGE OF PRISON
INTAKE. IN RESPONSE TO CALL OF
IT. AND WE HAVE CONCURRENT WITH
ALL OF THOSE REQUESTS THE-
FIRST LETTER CAME APRIL SECOND.
WE RESPONDED APRIL FIFTH
WEAKENED HER. ALL ALWAYS WITH
STATEMENTS OF CONCERN ABOUT THE
SEVERITY OF COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS. AND RIFF QUESTI THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED
DETAILED PLAN FOR MITIGATING
THE SPREAD OF COAL BUT NINETEEN
IN THE STATE'S CORRECTIONAL
POPULATIONS THAT REQUEST WAS
MADE APRIL FIFTH. THE NEXT
LETTER CAME FROM FINANCE MAY
EIGHTH. ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION BECAUSE
THEY WERE NOW AGAIN HALTING
INTAKE FROM COUNTIES AND AGAIN
AUGMENTATION REQUESTED TO
REIMBURSE COUNTIES NOW FOR
HOLDING IN MAKES THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN. IT'LL PROCESS AND
BROWN TO IN TAKEN CORRECTIONS
AND BECAUSE WE'RE ASKING
COUNTIES TO HOLD THEM NOW FOR
ANOTHER THIRTY DAY PERIOD. IT
WAS AN ADDITIONAL- BOND EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST. ONCE
AGAIN JAIL BC CONCURRED WITH
THE NECESSITY OF THOSE CHANGES.
ALL AGAIN NO RESPONSE IN TERMS
OF THEIR FULL PLAN. ON WYNTON
AND MAY ELEVENTH WE RESPONDED
TO THE MAY A FOR QUITE A
RECOUP- REQUEST ONCE AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT
THE GOP FEE BE PROVIDED WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES
THAT ARE BEING USED TO
ESTABLISH THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
STANDARDS THE MODELING AND THE
DATA THAT SHOWS THE CURRENT
PRISON POPULATION LEVEL AND THE
PROPER PHYSICAL DISTANCING
POPULATION LEVEL WERE BEING
DONE. BOND AGAIN WITH EVERY. WE
CONCUR AND ASK FOR DE. FOR THE
LEGISLTURE COULD BE CONFIDENT
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING. IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM JUNE
SEVENTEENTH ANOTHER SECTION
THIRTY SIX LETTER WE RECEIVED
FROM FINANCE. ASKING FOR A AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. TO WHICH WE RESPONDED
IN A RATHER LENGTHY LETTER JUNE
TWENTIETH. WHERE ONCE AGAIN WE
ASK ABOUT THE PLAN HOWEVER IN
THE STAFF BRIEFING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STAFF
WITH JAIL BE FEES STAFF
INCIDENT BUDGET STAFF ASSEMBLY
BUDGET FAIR. WE WERE TOLD IN
THE STATE BRIEFING. THAT THEY
INTENDED TO BEGIN. PROCESSING
INTAKE OF UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
INMATES PER WEEK. AGAIN THIS
LETTER FROM FINANCE FELIZ DATED
JUNE. SEVENTEEN AND THE
BRIEFING PROBABLY OCCURRED
WITHIN A DAY OR TWO. WE REPLIED
JUNE TWENTIETH OF PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MALL STERNLY FRAME THE
LETTERS I HAVE TENDED TO DEAL
BE FEATURED HERE. SO THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT IT HAS POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN PLACE THAT
PROTECT THE HEALTH THE SAFETY
OF STAFF AND INMATES. AND AT
THE DATA NEEDS TO SHOW THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ARE
WORKING. GIVEN THE PROBLEMS OF
THE DEPARTMENT IN CANADA ACTED
MANY INMATES FROM. LA COUNTY I
URGE THE DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
STRICT PROTOCOLS WITH EACH
COUNTY. TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS TRANSFERRED FROM
COUNTY JAIL FOR THE PRISONS ARE
NEGATIVE OF COAL BUT NINETEEN.
BOOK FOR THE OR TRANSFER TO A
STATE INSTITUTION. AND I IN THE
LETTER. SAYING THAT WE- REQUEST
THAT THE MINUTE. HA IN FROM AND
THE PART CAN IN. THAT ONLY IN
MAY TO HAVE TESTS NEGATIVE
AGAIN BEEN TESTED. AND TO THE
STATE INSTITUTIONS WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVED AN EMAIL JUNE TWENTY
FOUR. CONFIRMING THAT KNOLL
ADDITIONAL IN MAY FOR THE
TRANSFER SO THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
WALK THROUGH IN THE CONTEXT OF
JAIL BE SEE IN THIS ONE AREA.
OUR CONSTANT CONSISTENT EFFORTS
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATURE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR PRACTICES.
AND FOR WITH THAT. I'D LIKE IT
ON FOURTH NO ONE FROM FAR ON
PANEL BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
THE SECRETARY IN TERMS OF WHAT
LEVEL OF. CONFIDENCE WOULD HE
SUGGEST WE HAVE THE CITY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE. THE
BASED ON THEIR LACK OF RESPONSE
FOR THE LAST SINCE APRIL SECOND.
SENATE BILL FORWARD BASES THAT
THERE'S A LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE.
COMMUNICATIVE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE PLAN IS. GOING FORWARD TO
ATTEMPT TO CURB THE ON GOING
SPREAD OF COOL BUT NINETEEN.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR MITCHELL AND I WILL
SAY. IN RETURN IN REGARDS TO
COUNTY AND- AB IN STILL BELIEVE
THE CAR OF THE COUNTY IN TECH
WAS A SENSE AND KERR THE SPREAD
OF KOBE. THEN THERE'S THE- AND
TRYING TO AS A WITH A COUNTY
INTO TO IN THE SURE. RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY ALL HAVE PRESSURE. SO
THE AND CALL TO CLOSE FOR
COUNTY INTAKE ANY ONE BUT THERE
WAS A- NOT BE TO THEM WORKING
IT CONTINUE NOT TO TAKE. IT'S
FROM THE COUNTY JAIL. THE WAS A
PLAN TO TAKE ONLY TRUE INMATES
ONE HUNDRED FOR WASCO AND ONE
HUNDRED FOR NORTH KERN THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TAKING IS IF
THAT WAS. I THINK THE MAYBE IN
A WE KNOW INTENDED BRING IN
SEVEN TO OUR SISTER AND OUR SO
BECAUSE WE DO THE NUMBER OURS
OF OUR RECEPTIONS. TO TALK. AND
NOR KERN WE PRIDE TO THAT
DECISION WE HAD A FIVE CENTER.
WE HAD ONE AND SHE WE HAD ONE
AT COULDN'T WE HAD WOMEN D. V.
I. WE HAVE ONE IN DELANO. LAW
SCHOOL AND THE FEMALES WE HAVE
ONE THAT THE CAL QUESTION SO
AGAINST THE SO NARRATIVE DOWN
TO ONLY TWO OF ENTRY. NORTH
KERN. AND CLOSE THE CAP.
INTERNET AND DIRECTING MANY
PEOPLE TO THE INTERNET AND
RESOURCE EVERYTHING FROM OUR-
IN MAKO HOARDING TOWARD TESTING
THE STAFF TôI TESTING OF
MATES- TO THE CLOSURES OF
PROGRAMS. OF THE MOVEMENT
BETWEEN INSTITUTIONS. AND THE
PROGRAM STATUS OF EVERY
INSTITUTION- I BELIEVE THERE'S
BEEN AN OVER RELIANCE ON OUR
END WE DO NEED TO DEVELOP A
MORE. COMPREHENSIVE A COHESIVE.
ARGUMENT RATHER THAN REFER
EVERYONE TO THE INTERNET- AND-
I HAVE BINDER HERE WITH.
DIRECTOR TENET AND I'LL BE THE
FIRST TO ADMIT WE NEED ALL OF
THOSE PUT. ONE DOCUMENT IS OVER
REPORT. BUT AS WITH ANY REPORTS
ESPECIALLY DURING COLD BUT- IT
IS GOING TO BE A REVOLVING
REMOVING AND- BUT AS FAR AS-
THE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED BY. BY YOUR- BY
YOUR COMMITTEE CENTER I DO
APPRECIATE A CORRECTIONS IS
BETTER FOR IT. BUT I HOPE YOU
DO TOO. THE DECISION TO. NOT
TAKE JAIL. INMATES ARE ISN'T
TAKE A LOT ON OUR- THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF HUMAN. WITH OUR WITH
OUR SURE PARTNER. AT THE ERROR.
NEVER PART IN THIS WHEN THIS
THE- THERE WAS A GUIDELINE SENT
TO THE SHERIFF'S EARLY EARLY TO
MID LAST WEEK YOU'RE IN THE
CLEAR DIRECTION. ON WHAT TYPES
IT MAKES ARE TO COME TO US WHAT
IS YOUR TESTING PROTOCOLS- AND
THEY HAVE BEEN GOOD PARTNERS IN
IT AND THAT- THAT GREAT YOUR
HUSBAND WILL IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE RECEIVERS OFFICE TO
MAKE SURE THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE
IS IN AGREEMENT. THAT THE
QUESTIONS OR ASK YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE REQUIRING OF THE COUNTIES
IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR CODE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES- BUT-
EVEN WITH THAT WITH THE SPIKES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS. I SENT A LETTER TO THE
COUNTIES INFORMING THEM THAT WE
READ ACTUALLY TELLING OF WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO COSTS AND
TAKE FOR ANOTHER THIRTY DAYS.
THAT DOES ALLOW US TO. IS
NUMBER ONE- TAKE A LOOK AT THE
VACANT CAPACITIES IN OUR
RESEARCH CENTERS WHICH NOW
EXISTS BECAUSE IN RATES ARE NOT
COMING IN AT TO STRATEGIZE WITH
THE RECEIVERS OPTIONS BE
POPULATE OTHER LOCATIONS OR WE
MAY HAVE CRISIS AREAS THAT WE
CANNOT D. POPULATE OR REDUCE
THE DENSITY. INSTITUTIONS AND
MOVE INDIVIDUALS AS COHORTS
AFTER BEING TESTED IN
QUARANTINE AT THE SENDING IN
AND ON THE RECEIVING END- SO. I
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR SENATOR
ABOUT THE OVERALL PLAN THE
WHEEL FINANCE IN THE FINANCE
OWES YOU. BUT AGAIN I WILL
CHALK IT AND I WILL SAY THAT
IT'S BEEN AN OVER RELIANCE ON.
ON OUR INTERNET AND POSTING.
ALL THAT THE VARIOUS PLANS THAT
ARE SO. ON THAT WHAT'S- THE
THING RESPONSE ON AND I'LL IN
NOW ON THAT I'M CHAIRWOMAN YOU
KNOW ON THE MANY MEMBERS ARE
OFTEN CONCERNED ABOUT UNFUNDED
MANDATES ACTIONS WE TAKE IT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT HAVE FINANCIAL
IMPACT ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
LET ME COULD BE CLEAR. THAT WE
HAVE PAID WE HAVE. PAID FOR.
STOPPING THE INTAKE FROM THE
COUNTY LEVEL SO THEY HAVE
RECEIVED REIMBURSEMENT. ALL AND
WITH THE SECRETARY- I'M NOT
SURE OF THE SOURCE OF THE
MISTAKE LET ME JUST STATE THAT.
BOMB IN THE STAFF BRIEFING WITH
FINANCE. WE WERE TOLD SEVEN
HUNDRED PER WEEK. AND WHEN
STAFF RETURN THE CALL TO
CLARIFY THAT THEY DID MEAN
SEVEN HUNDRED A MONTH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REITERATED A SECOND TIME. THE
INTENT WAS TO TRANSFER ME USING
YOUR TERMINOLOGY INTAKE. WAS TO
PICK BACK UP. AT SEVEN HUNDRED
PER WEEK. SOUL IF FINANCE IN
COORDINATING WITH THE AGENCY.
PROBLEM AND SO- I APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY AND I
HOPE THAT THE THAT YOU ARE
CLEAR THAT IF YOU'RE A WOMAN
AND THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
HIGH AS DEAL BE FEE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THESE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE WE ARE
NOW AT A- POINT OF CRISIS. AND
CRISIS MANAGEMENT MUST STEP IN-
IT IS SYSTEM WHY- IT CLEARLY
WILL HAVE FINANCIAL
RAMIFICATIONS ON THE STATE AS A
WHOLE. ALL ON THE QUICKER YOU
HAVE A PLAN WHERE YOU CAN WRAP
UP WERE MISTER KELSO HAS THE
RESOURCES AND PERSONNEL HE MADE
NEEDS TO CONDUCT TESTING THE
BETTER OFF WE WILL ALL BE
INCLUDE. WHO ARE CAR SERRATED.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SECTOR DS
RESPONDING BUT LET ME JUST ADD
TO THE SENATOR MITCHELL'S. HAS
BEEN HER ROLE OF CHAIR OF L.
JAIL BC. FIVE COURSES A MEMBER
OF JAIL BC CUT TO RECEIVE EACH
OF THOSE LETTERS THAT WERE
SENT. AND I JUST WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT I
DON'T THINK WAS ANSWERED. THAT
AS FAR AS I KNOW BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED A RESPONSE
THAT NONE OF THE REQUESTS. THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL THAT THE
JAILED BC SENT. EACH TIME THE
JAIL BC AUTHORIZED THE
EXPENDITURES THAT THE REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION WERE NEVER
RESPONDED TO SO WHILE THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN THINGS ON A CDC OUR
WEBSITE. THERE WAS NEVER A
FORMAL COMMUNICATION THAT WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THE CDC OUR
WEBSITE TO ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS
THERE CERTAINLY THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME OF US WHO HAVE BEEN
MONITORING THE CDC HERE ARE
WEBSITE ALL THIS TIME. FOR
EXAMPLE I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
CITE THE DATE JUST CITED BEFORE
AROUND AND THE NUMBER THE STAFF
AT WHAT FACILITIES AND THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS ARE
FACILITIES ALL OF THAT IS RIGHT
THERE ON THE CDC OUR WEBSITE.
BUT I THINK- AND I RUBIO.
SENATOR MITCHELL'S POINTING OUT
THAT JAIL BC HAS BEEN
REQUESTING THIS INFORMATION AND
OUT THE NEXT THE FOR PLANNED
FOR MONTHS. AND WILL LEAVE IT
AT THAT. SENATOR WIENER I WANT
TO ASK ONE QUESTION BEFORE I
CALLING YOU SO APOLOGIES- MR
KELSO IN SECTOR YEARS YOU CAN
RESPOND ALSO TO MR CALL SO YOU
MENTIONED THAT. AND I A PRIEST
A SENATOR MITCHELL'S. HAVING
CLEARED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
YOUR ROLE BUT YOU MENTIONED
THAT GUIDANCE WAS GIVEN
STARTING WITH MARCH TWENTIETH
AND ON VARIOUS GUIDANCE. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHILE IT'S
NOT BEEN SAID YET BY SECRETARY
DEUS. IN THE CALLS THAT I'VE
HAD WITH THE DEPARTMENT OVER
THE LAST X. NUMBER OF MONTHS
THERE WAS A CERTAIN POINT WERE
I WAS INFORMED. THAT SYSTEM
WIDE THERE WAS THE REQUIREMENT
FOR STAFF TO WEAR MASKS. WHAT I
WANT TO KNOW IS WHETHER IN FACT
THERE WAS THAT REQUIREMENT
WHETHER THE RECEIVER WAS
INVOLVED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THAT REQUIREMENT WAS EITHER
ISSUED AN ENFORCED AND FROM CDC
ARE WAS THAT REQUIREMENT
ENFORCED. THAT ALL STAFF WEAR
MASKS. BECAUSE ANECDOTALLY WHAT
WE HEAR IS THAT STAFF. DO NOT
WEAR MASKS SOME BUT IT'S
IRREGULAR AND- SO WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. YOUR MANAGER THE-
I'LL I'LL GIVE AN ANSWER I
SUSPECT SECRETARY DEALS WANTED
AMPLIFIED- BOTH SECRETARY DIAZ
NINE HAVE. ISSUED DIRECTIVES
THAT STAFF- SHOW WEAR MASKS- WE
DON'T TWICE- I ALSO- BECAUSE WE
HEARD SIMILAR SORTS OF CONCERNS
THAT WELL WE KNOW PEOPLE
WEARING MASKS AND IS ALSO A
REQUIREMENT THAT GUY. WEAR
MASKS AND ABSORB DISTANCE I
SENT OUT FROM MY OFFICE. HE.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN DIFFERENT OF.
THE ONES THOUGHT WE MOST
CRITICAL OR REVIEW. UP WITH
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF GETTING
REPORT BACK ON HOW WELL ARE
BOLD INMATES AND STAFF DOING IN
COMPLYING WITH THOSE DIRECTIVES
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING MASKS SO
ON- AND I DID RECEIVE A REPORT.
BACK LAST WEEK. SOME HUNDRED
AND SIXTY PAGES WORTH OF DETAIL
ABOUT THE DEGREE OF COMPLIANCE-
IT IS NOT UNIFORM- IN GENERAL-
IT APPEARED THAT THERE WAS ONLY
ON ONE PRISON. WHERE THE REPORT
DESCRIBED THE PRISON AND WE'RE
ONLY GOING TO GO TO NOT TAKING.
THIS LAND OFF OVER. REPRESENT
WHAT SEE I AM. SURPRISINGLY I
DON'T SEE HOW THEY COULD NOT BE
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY GIVEN THE
EXTENT OF THE OUTBREAK THERE.
BOB FOR ALL OF THE OTHER
PRISONS THE REPORT CAME BACK
THAT IT WAS BEING TAKEN
SERIOUSLY- WE'VE HAD GREAT
COOPERATION- WITH THE INMATE
ADVISORY COUNCILS AND INMATES
IN GENERAL- THEIR OBSERVANT AND
MOST INSTITUTIONS. WE HAVE SOME
INMATES WHO ARE COMPLIANT DON'T
COMPLY WITH MUCH OF ANYTHING
BUT BY AND LARGE I THINK WE'RE
DOING. PRETTY WELL- WE
INDICATED IN OUR MOST A CERTAIN
RADIUS MINOR MOST RECENT MA'AM
ALL THAT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
INSTITUTION LEADERSHIP. TO
ENFORCE THE REQUIREMENT OF
USING. OF THE PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINE SYSTEM. SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT IT IS BY BEING
ENFORCED ON OBSERVER. A JUDGE I
GOT MY DAY IN MY- HI HE
DESERVES NOT US ALONG EARLIER
THIS WEEK- AND HIT THE REPORT I
RECEIVED BACK DRUGS FIRE WAS IT
LOOKED AT HIM LIKE PEOPLE WERE
IN GENERAL COMPLYING WITH ALL
SORT OF A- MUCH. THIRTY ALSO.
SO I GOT TO BUY WHAT OF MISTER
CASTLE SAID IT IS A REQUIREMENT
WHEN WAS THE REQUIREMENT ISSUE-
I COULD GIVE YOU THE DATES THAT
HAD OPENED AROUND LATE MARCH.
MARCH BUT THAT WE JUST SIGNED
ANOTHER MEMBER AND LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS AGO AMPLIFYING AND
REITERATING THE NEED FOR MASKS
I ALSO DID- THE REQUIREMENT
REQUIREMENTS. IT IS WE ARE THAT
STUFF MASS AND LIKE LIKE MISTER
COUNSELL SENATE UP I ALSO
WANTED TOWARD PRISONS MYSELF-
DURING THE- IT WAS LAST MONTH I
DROVE. JUST ON THE CALIFORNIA
DIDN'T BLAME MYSELF DROVE. YES
TO NUMBER ONE CHECK ON THE
STATUS OF THE INSTITUTIONS BUT
TO ALSO LOOK AT MYSELF. FOR THE
COMPLIANCE OF MASS WHERE. SEVEN
INSTITUTIONS THAT I TOUR- STAFF
WERE IN COMPLIANCE AND I KNOW
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN STAFF KNOW
THE SECRETARIES ARE STILL OF
COURSE YOU CAN BEHIND AWARENESS
I'M WELL AWARE OF THAT. BOB
THAT'S WHY. YEAH WHICH IS NOT
JUST LOOK AT WHAT WAS IN FRONT
OF ME WHAT WAS BEHIND ME AND
YARDS NEXT TO ME. THE DOCTOR IN
MAKES STAFF. AND COMPLIANCE IS
MANDATORY. WE HAVE CMMUNICATED
THIS ITH THE BARGAINING UNITS
THE BARGAINING UNITS. ARE ARE
ON BOARD OF THE BARGAINING
UNITS HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS. THEY KNOW IT IT
BENEFITS MEMBERSHIP. AND THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT IF PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINE MASSIVE TAKEN ON
WHAT WE USED TO. FAILED TO
COMPLY OR DON'T COMPLY- NOT
UNDERSTANDING. THIS REQUIREMENT
NOT ONLY BY. BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS MIGHT KEEPERS
OFFICE- BUT IT'S JST THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AT THE STATE. THANK
YOU SIR- SENATOR WIENER IN I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR QUESTION
FOR US AND I SOME QUESTIONS FOR
SECRETARY DHEAS ABOUT I'D AS I
MENTIONED IN THE BEGINNING
TRANSFER OF. PEOPLE FROM CITY
CHARTER DETENTION FACILITIES
BUT ONE QUICK QUESTION BEFORE
THAT- I'VE GOTTEN SOME
FEEDBACK. THAT THERE ARE- THE
STAFF FOR MEDICAL STAFF CONCERN
CORPS AND MAY NOT HAVE THE P.
P. THAT NEEDED CAN YOU COMMENT
ON LEVEL. I CAN GIVE YOU. I GET
AN UPDATE ON A ON A DAILY BASIS
FROM OUR LOGISTICS OFFICE IN
OUR DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS
CENTER- JAN NINETY FIVE MASS
CURRENTLY WE HAVE- ONE MILLION
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
SURGICAL MASK OVER FIVE MILLION
AND NINETY FIVE MAX TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND. OVER HALF
A MILLION DOWN. OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. SHIELDS AND
WE HAVE OVER TEN MILLION PAIRS
OF GLOVES SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF CODE RED A CDC ARE OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS CENTER
THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE WE SEE
NEARLY THIRTY POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON PP FOR
EMPLOYEES. I THINK ONE COVERED
FIRST. THAT'S MY OF THE STATE
WHERE THERE WAS STRONG TO TRY
AND FIND THAT SUPPLIER BUT
SINCE THEN WE HAVE RAMPED UP IF
THERE ARE CONCERNS AT. THANK EP
IT'S REPORTED UP THE
INSTITUTIONS THE MORE
OPERATIONS CENTER HERE AND WE
ADDRESS- I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
THERE IS A LACK BUT IF THERE IS
WE WILL BE LESS. WIENER I JUST
WANT TO SAY I HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE IS A LACK OF PP AT SAN
QUENTIN FROM STAFF IT'S IN
COURT. FOR ITS- MAY LOOK INTO
THAT TO CONFIRM BECAUSE MORE
HEARING BEST FROM FROM REAL
WORLD SOURCES. ON THE REGARDING
ICE TRANSFERS- SO- SECRETARY
DEUS EX SO I WANT TO KNOW.
SINCE THE BEGINNING YOU. HOW
MANY. IT IS OUR TRANS TO OUR TO
TEN BUT AND HAS THE DEPARTMENT
BEEN TRACKING- WHETHER THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING
TRANSFERRED TO ICE DETENTION
pFACILITIES WHERE WE KNOW THAT
CODE IS SPREADING DATA WE'VE
GOT AND IS A ONE OUT OF THREE-
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE DETENTION
FACILITIES. IS POPULAR SO.
BROWN'S ARE YOU TRYING WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO FACILITY THAT
HAVE COVERED ISSUES. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR. SO AS
FAR AS THE NUMBER I WILL HAVE
TO GET THAT TO YOU FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR I CAN
PROBABLY GET IT BY THE END OF
THE DAY. BUT I WILL SAY ONE WAS
IN THE TERM TRANSFER WE DON'T
WE THE CDC OUR- TRANSPORT ME IN
MY TO SEE TO ASK CITY. IF IT
MITCHELL SERVE THEIR TERMS AND
THEIR TERM IS UP. IT IS A
RESULT WARRANT BY I USED AS A
UP WE- PICKED UP BY I JUST LIKE.
ANY OTHER LAW AGENCIES WHO MADE
ALL THE VISUAL THE TAKEN. FOR
OUR. CUSTOMERS SOMEONE LEAVES
OUR PRISONS BACK OF UP IT'S
OVER IF PRICES. WE
TRANSPORTING- OR SOME OTHERS
USE YOUR HAS OVERSIGHT OVER THE
TRANSPORT- IT'S AUDIBLE BROWN
BUT SORT OF OUR PURVIEW OF THE
MINISTER SENTENCE IN THEIR
DOMINANCE HALT. REJECTED AND
CUSTODY WATER PICKS THEM UP. MY
AYE AYES SO I UNDER IS YOU
ABOUT THE ONE DURING THE FIFTH
TRANSPORT. BOB MY UNDERSTANDING
IS- CCAR INFORMS ICE I THINK
FIVE DAYS BEFORE RELEASE ABOUT
TELL IT SNOWS TO PICK SOMEONE
UP WHEN THEY'RE BUILT THE
RELEASE OF CITY SEE ARE FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND. THIS
INVOLVED AND- ON A CALL TO
TRANSFER HAND OFF FROM CITY
SITAR TO ICE OF PEOPLE WHO'VE
COMPLETED- THEIR CITY YARD
SENTENCE OR WHO ARE BEING
RELEASE OR PAROLED- AND CITY
ARE FACILITATE SOME BEING
PICKED UP UPON THE RELEASE AND
THEN TO TURN AYE SUSPENSION.
ALREADY THE ARE OP YOUR SENSE
COVERT BECOME A THERE ARE REAL
MAJOR ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA LET'S
SAY STARTING IN MARCH HAS CDC
ARE CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO
FACILITATE ICE PICKING UP THESE
PEOPLE ARE BEING RELEASED AND A
CITY SEE OUR- LOOK INTO.
THEY'RE BEING SERVICEABILITY
WITH A COMMON PROBLEM IS THAT
HAPPENING. SO RICOH RID- AND
CURRENT CODE IF THERE IS A
HOLDING PLACE GIVEN BY ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY WHETHER BE
ICE WHETHER BE LOS ANGELES SURE
FOR THERE TO BE A GEORGIA AND
NOT HOLD IS IN PLACE. AND
THEY'RE THERE TO PICK THEM UP
THEN WE RELEASE UNDER THEIR
CUSTODY AFTER THEY'RE OUT OF
OUR CUSTODY WE DON'T- WE'RE NOT
CHECK FOR THEY GO. OR NOT
CHECKING THE STATUS OF WOMEN
GOING TO THEY ARE NOW IN THE
CARE CUSTODY OF THE OF THE
ENTITY PICKING THEM UP. SO BY.
IT I AM I CORRECT THIS ARE DOES
NOT AN OBLIGATION. TO ALERT ICE
AND TO FACILITATE THE HAND OFF
THE EYES OF THESE THE DETAINEES
ARE YOU ARE YOU. YOU'RE NOT
OBLIGATED TO DO THAT CITIES ARE
IS CHOOSING TO DO THAT. GIVEN
WHAT WE KNOW. ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THESE PRIVATE
PRISON ICE DETENTION
FACILITIES. OVERHEAD WHY IS CC
ARE CONTINUING TO ALERT ICE THE
PEOPLE ARE BEING RELEASED- AND
TO FACILITATE. THE HAND OFF WHY
ARE YOU STILL DOING THAT AND
WILL WILL WILL YOU WILL YOU
STOP. I THINK CITY SORRY TO
STOP. DOING THAT. OKAY SO AS
WITH ALL HOLDS THERE IS CONTACT
MADE WITH THE ENTITY THE
INITIALLY PLACED A WHOLE TO
INQUIRE ARE YOU GOING TO PICK
THIS INDIVIDUAL UP OR NOT.
QUESTION WHAT AS NOT JUST WILL
ANY LAW FORCED AND TO. ARE YOU
GOING TO PAY THEM UP. BUT THEY
SAY WE'RE NOT THERE WILL HOLD
AND THEY JUST HOME. IF THEY SAY
THEY ARE LOOKING NO WHERE YOU
HAVE ALL. SO THEY CAN MAKE
THEIR RIGHT COMMUNICATION
FAMILY BUT WE NOT ICE JUST WHAT
WE WOULD ANY LONG. WHO IS
REQUESTING THAT THE GOING TO
PICK UP. WE DON'T HAVE ICE ANY
AS WE WOULD ANY OTHER LAFORTUNE.
AND IF THERE IS A HOLDING PLACE
AND- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE. BUT I GUESS. THE
QUESTION IS WHY. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TREAT THIS LIKE ANY OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. AND
FRANKLY ICE IS NOT LIKE. OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE
KNOW ALL THE PROBLEMS OF ICE.
GOING WELL BEYOND COVE IT IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY TREAT.
IMMIGRANTS IN THESE DETENTION
FACILITIES. AND THE PROBLEM.
PEOPLE DOT. ABOUT WITH THE WAVE
LGBT Q. IMMIGRANTS ARE TREATED
TREATED IN CHILDREN. AND THEN
WE HAVE COBIT WERE ONCE AGAIN
THE- DONE A TERRIBLE JOB. AND
SO FIFTY C. R. IS NOT REQUIRED.
TO CORDON QUE AND FACILITATE.
ARE YOU STICKING HIS PEOPLE UP
YOU'RE CHOOSING VOLUNTARILY TO
DO SO. AND SO MY QUESTION IS
WHY ARE YOU CHOOSING TO
VOLUNTARILY DO SO. AND WILL CDC
ARE COMMITTED TO STOP DOING
THIS THIS IS MAKING THE COVERT
SITUATION IT'S HARMING PEOPLE
WILL YOU STOP DOING. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW OUR POLICY
STATE. HOLDING PLACE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY INCLUDING
THE X. FOR A HOLDEN PLACE TO
TURN OVER TO THE CUSTOMER. OKAY
LIFE IS ONE OF INCLUDE BY
SAYING I. COULD NIGHT THE THREE
WITH CDC OURS INVOLUNTARY
POLICY. TO HAND PEOPLE OFF THE
ICE A COULD NOT DISAGREE MORE.
WE THIS IS THIS IS MAKING THE
COVERED SITUATION WORSE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN CLICK
HERE. WITH THE PASSAGE OF US
FIFTY FOUR THAT WE DO NOT WANT
TO. OFFICE TATE. THE TRUMP
DEPORTATION MACHINE- AND EVEN
THOUGH YES THE GOVERNOR DID
VETO AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WEST
HEREBY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO THE
MISTAKE AND I HOPE THAT THIS
MISTAKE OF QUICKLY RECTIFIED
AND STOP. FOR NINETY DAYS.
SENATOR MOORLACH. THANK YOU
MADAM OF SECRETARY HE IS A-
IT'S A IN ORDER TO SERVE ON THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND AT
LAST YEAR WE HAD AT LEAST A
GOOD CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF TOPICS- SORRY WE'RE JUST SO
LIMITED THAT TODAY BUT- I HAD.
THE BEGINNING AND THAT THERE
WAS A VIDEO. SHOWING INMATES
PENSION SPREAD OF IT NINETEEN
SO YOU HAVE A- CONSTITUENCY
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT-
THOSE THAT ARE IN NURSING
HOMES- WHAT THEY ARE TRYING.
THEIR BEST LLOYD- ANY A CONTACT
AND YET HERE WE HAVE. A MANY
THAT ARE ACTUALLY.
INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO GET
COPE WITH TEENS SO YOU HAVE A-
A UNIQUE CONSTITUENCY AND I'M-
I'M I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER WHAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO WHAT WAS
TO BE A- LAW BASED. WAS TO. BE
MOVED BUT COULD YOU COULD YOU
HELP ME WITH. PORT AGREED WAS
IT. WAS ACTUALLY GOING ON. I
THINK THE PART OF. I AM WAS
REFERENCING A LOS ANGELES. IT
WAS REGARD RECORD LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JAIL HOW CAN THE REPORT
WAS THAT THEY WERE INTENSELY
TRYING TO SPREAD CODE FOR OUR
FOR WHATEVER REASONS POSSIBLY
TRYING TO SEEK EARLY RELEASE.
S. COLON GO ON. I REALLY CAN'T
SPEAK FOR LA COUNTY- AS FAR AS
A PRISON SYSTEM- I HAVEN'T
RECEIVED REPORTS THAT THAT IS
THE CASE. HOWEVER NOR MIGHT
ACTIVELY ASKING STAFF TO GET
AND FIND THAT IS HAPPENING IF
THAT IS HAPPENING- I'M SURE
THAT YOU CAN MAKE. A SELF ONE
SELF REPORT THAT- BECAUSE
PRICES. IN JUST. NORM YOU TO
HELP THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE
THE- THIS MATTER. RISK PATIENTS
THAT WOULD PROBABLY INFORMS
THAT THAT IS A BUT HAVE NOT
HEARD THAT'S THE CASE BUT AGAIN
I HAVEN'T ACTIVELY PURSUED I
DON'T WANT IT TO BE CALPERS
THERE WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH POPULATIONS OKAY WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE STAFF HELP
OPEN DIALOGUE WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE STAFF. AND THIS YOUR
PRISON STAFF AND IF THAT'S
THAT'S- I HAVE NOT HEARD IT OF
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WERE BE
A- I'M I WOULD ON TRYING
IMMEDIATELY. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLEAR THAT THERE'S IT MOST
HELPFUL YOU BEEN WERE WITH
RECEIVER CAR CAL SELLING HE-
HAS BEEN WORKING IN TANDEM. I
JUST WANT TO KNOW- IS THE
RECEIVER STILL ADDING VALUE
ORDERS THE RECEIVER DOWN DIDN'T.
NO I THINK THE RECEIVERS
PARTNERSHIP WITH CDC ARE IT IS
VALUE AT OTHERS EXPERTISE THAT
DOES EXIST IN THE RECEIVER'S
OFFICE THAT. THAT SEEKS YOUR
RELIES HEAVILY ON. AND THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE RECEIVER
ESPECIALLY MISTER CALDERON
MYSELF AND STRONGER NOW THAN
EVER. OF THEIR RESOURCES
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE WITH
IN THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE
THAT'S- THAT CDC ARE LACKS. AN
AYE AYE CONSIDERING PARTNERS. I
DON'T CONSIDER. THANK YOU
SECOND. HE IS A RECEIVER KELSO
AFTER THAT GROWING REPORT I'M
JUST CURIOUS I SHOULD ASK YOU
AT LEAST ONCE A YEAR. ARE YOU
STILL UNNECESSARY- AND HOW LONG
DO YOU SEE YOUR ROLE LASTING.
WELL AS A THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION- AS YOU KNOW- MY
COURT HAS DIRECTED ME FOR ABOUT
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS NOW NOT TO
TRY TO PUT A- FIRM DATE. ON
ENDING RECEIVERSHIP WHAT I CAN
SAY IS. YOUR MAKING STEADY
PROGRESS FORWARD IN THE
DELEGATION PROCESS WHICH IS THE
PROCESS A TO END THE
RECEIVERSHIP. ESSENTIALLY WHEN
COVERT TRUCK I HAVE NOW AND NOT
BEEN ABLE TO FOCUS ON THE LAST
FOUR TO FIVE MONTHS ON WHAT ARE
THE NEXT SET OF INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE READY FOR DELEGATION
AND FOR I THINK THERE ARE. A
NUMBER THAT ARE READY FOR
DELEGATION THAT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN DELEGATED I'M HOPING OVER
THE NEXT. MOTHER TO A TO FIGURE
OUT HOW I CAN REORGANIZE MY OWN
ATTENTION SO THAT I CAN GET
BACK TO THE PROCESS NOT ONLY OF
WORKING WITH SOUND SECRETARY
DEALS ON COVERT MATTERS WHICH I
THINK OF A HIGH PRIORITY. BUT
SO THAT I CAN CONTINUE THE
PROCESS DELEGATING BACK DATE
MOVING THE CASE ALONG TOWARD
ITS CONCLUSION SO- MOB BUT WE
DON'T HOLD IN TERMS OF THAT
PROGRESS. FOR FIVE MONTHS NOW
BUT I HOPE TO GET BACK TO IT.
THANK YOU WERE KELSO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LIKE SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAD A
QUESTION FOR SECRETARY DHEAS AS
RELATES TO PERSONNEL STAFFING
IT'S BEEN BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION I PARTICIPATED IN A
CALL. A LITTLE OVER A MONTH AGO
WITH ONE OF YOUR FACILITIES
INTO WHICH BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION ALONG WITH THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY. A PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT THE SOME THE
FACILITIES ARE LACKING MEDICAL
DIRECTORS OR IF THEY DO HAPPEN
COULD DIRECTOR THERE AN ACTING
CAPACITY BEYOND THEIR SKILL
START IS THAT STILL THE- BUT
THE QUESTION IF- BETTER RECTOR.
MEANING THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OVER HEALTH CARE- THAT
IS- THAT'S MORE IN LINE OF A
QUESTION FOR MR KELSO. ACTOR AT
EACH FACILITY AT EACH
FACILITIES FACILITY HAS A CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WHO IS OVER
HEALTH CARE- THEIR EQUIVALENT
TO OUR WARDENS AT THE
INSTITUTION OKAY AS A RACE TO
HEALTH CARE MATTERS TO MISTER
KELSO THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR THE- WE DO HAVE. SOME
OF THE SMALL NUMBER OF ACTING
C. E. O.'S MOST OF OUR C. E.
O.'S. I HAVE BEEN WITH US NOW
FOR MANY YEARS FRANKLY AND THEY
ARE VERY EXPERIENCED- GROUP. OF
HEALTH CARE USUALLY HOSPITAL
FORMER HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATORS-
UNDERSTAND VERY WELL HOW TO
MANAGE A STAFF OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS- IN THE STATE WE
HAVE ACTING IS BECAUSE- PEOPLE
RETIRE THEY DECIDE THEY'RE- NOT
FROM MOM. AND WE HAVE WE ARE
CONSTANTLY IN A PROCESS OF
RECRUITING. FOR CEOS AND FOR
CHIEF MEDICAL EXECUTIVES-
BECAUSE WE HAVE VACANCIES WE
NEED TO HAVE A POOL OF PEOPLE
CHOOSE FROM. IT YOU HAVE. YOUR
INSTITUTION CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PLEASE DO FEEL FREE TO CONTACT
ME- AND I CAN RESPOND MORE
PRECISELY BUT BY AND LARGE OUR
C. E. O.'S ALL OF OUR POSITIONS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
POSITIONS ARE FILLED WITH. A
PERMANENT- EXPERIENCE
LEADERSHIP. BE BECAUSE IT AGAIN
AT. CALL THAT I RECEIVED ALONG
WITH THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT THEY HAD
PEOPLE AN ACTING CAPACITY BUT
NOT NECESSARILY IN THEIR SKILL
SET NOW THEY MIGHT HAVE BROUGHT
UNDERSTANDING BUT IT WASN'T
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATED TO
HEALTH CARE AND ADDRESSING THIS
CALL THE- ISSUE. THAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD I
WANT TO- MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
ONE O'CLOCK TODAY AND WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC ALSO. BUT BEFORE WE DO.
I WANTED TWO THINGS ONE I
APPRECIATE THE HONESTY. MISTER
COLE SO IN DESCRIBING. THE
ISSUE OF THE TRANSFER HOW YOUR
MATRIX HOW YOUR A. B. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WHAT I HEARD WAS
THAT THERE WAS THE REQUIREMENT
OF TESTING HOWEVER IN NEVER
SPECIFIED WHEN. BUT I GUESS
WHAT I WOULD HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT. IS IF THERE IS THE CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER AT EACH VISIT.
CAN ANYONE UNDERSTANDS AWAY
THIS FIRE SPREAD IN YOU KNOW
MAY IN MARCH WE DIDN'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND AND MAYBE WE DIDN'T
HAVE ADEQUATE TESTING. BUT BY
THE END OF MAY WE FULLY
UNDERSTOOD AND WE HAD ADEQUATE
TESTING SO HOW THERE COULD HAVE
BEEN THE TRANSFER. WITH PEOPLE
THAT HAD NOT BEEN TESTED FOR
TWO TO THREE WEEKS. HEY I JUST
IT'S SUPPORT AND I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT. I DON'T KNOW
REALLY IF THERE'S A COMMENT. TO
MAKE OR NOT I JUST HAVE TO MAKE
THAT STATEMENT BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE. IS IN THIS IS
TO BOTH. MISTER CALDERON
SECRETARY DS BUT PERHAPS MISTER
KELSO PRIMARILY. AS THE PERSON
WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE. VINCENT
YOUR GUIDANCE INDICATED THERE'S
THE EED FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. MENU BIG
KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT'S DIFFICULT
IN SETTING. AND WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE OVERCROWDED. DO YOU HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
RELEASES ENDERS RELEASES DO NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE BACK TO.
DO COMMUNITY SETTING THEY COULD
BE AN TO OTHER FACILITIES FOR
EXAMPLE AND I DON'T MEAN JUST
PRISON FACILITIES. BUT I MEAN
FACILITY WHERE PEOPLE COULD BE
NOT CROWDED COULDN'T COULD OF A
FALL AT A FOLLOW THE
APPROPRIATE GUIDELINES. ON DO
YOU HAVE THAT AUTHORITY AND
BEFORE YOU ANSWER I JUST WANT
TO SINCE THIS IS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR TO ANY PUBLIC THAT'S
LISTENING. THE NUMBERS THAT
HAVE FOR TO EVERY SO FAR ALL
BEEN RELEASES THAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED ON THE NATURAL. THE
NOW. THREE THOUSAND
APPROXIMATELY PEOPLE ARE
RELEASED FROM OUR PRISON
SYSTEMS EVERY MONTH. SO THAT
THE FACT THAT SINCE LATE MARCH
WE RELEASE SOME SEVEN THOUSAND
IS NOT HIGHLY UNUSUAL AT ALL.
SO I GUESS SOMEONE TO IN TERMS
OF THIS PLAN FOR HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE SPREAD WHETHER THERE
IS ANY- PLANNED FOR. RELEASES
TO ACCOMMODATE TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THE APPROPRIATE FISCAL
DISENCHANTMENT THERE. AND THE
OTHER GUIDELINES FOR EXAMPLE IF
WE HAVE PEOPLE AND DORMITORY
FACILITIES ARE WE HAVE PEOPLE
IN CELLS THAT DON'T TELL A SOUL
DOORS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THE ISSUE OF OUR
RELEASES NEW TO RELEASE IT I
HAVE BEEN BEFORE- THE COURTS IN
OF THE CASE THE COURTS BEEN
HOLDING- HEARINGS ABOUT EVERY
SEVEN DAYS FOR A WHILE AND NOW
MOST RECENTLY ABOUT EVERY TEN
DAYS AND THE QUESTION OF
RELEASES IS BEFORE THE COURT-
DO NOT BELIEVE I HAVE.
AUTHORITY MYSELF TO. ORDER A
HOUSING CHANGES OR RELEASES-
THAT WOULD PUT- PATIENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE INSTITUTION.
EXCEPT FOR- ORDERING PATIENTS
UP TO GO TO HIGHER LEVELS OF
CARE HOSPITALS SO I DON'T
BELIEVE I HAVE THE POWER. TO DO
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING. SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU IT WAS A
LISTENING TO YOUR QUESTION- I'M
I'M REMINDED OF THE NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS AND ACADEMICS WHO
ARE AT LEAST IN THE ME IN MY
OFFICE THEIR CREATIVE IDEAS CUT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ASKING IS THERE
ANY MORE I. CREATE ID BOB
PARTNER WITH. AGENCIES IN TERMS
OF TRANSFER. AND SO ON I'D LIKE
TO KNOW- IF. THE SECRETARY WITH
THE COUNCIL ARE GETTING THEM IF
THERE IS A REPOSITORY WHERE
PEOPLE CAN BE SENDING THESE
CREATIVE IDEAS TO THEM. ALL MY
APPRECIATE THEM COMING TO MY
OFFICE BECAUSE OF TODAY'S
HEARING. BUT TO GET THEM INTO
THE HANDS OF THE KILLER WHO ARE
THE DECISION MAKERS IN WHO
HAVE. ALBEIT LIMITED POWER TO
MAKE FROM LITTLE DEFICIENT HOW
WOULD THEY LIKE TO RECEIVE THAT
INPUT FROM.INFORMED PEOPLE
STAKEHOLDERS ACADEMICS AND
OTHERS WHERE SHOULD THEY SEND
THEM. SENATOR MITCHELL I'D I'D
WELCOME SOME OF THOSE- SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS OR SOME
OF THOSE IDEAS WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT VARIOUS OPTIONS- BUT
YOU KNOW WITH THE VARIOUS
OPTIONS WE ALSO NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND. WE NEED TO PUT THE MAIN
LOCATION SO WHAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO MAKE A MAKE A BAD
SITUATION WORSE SITUATION
THAT'S NUMBER WE DON'T WANT TO
BE DOING- IS OUR- I. CAN SEE.
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
REENTRY SERVICES AFTER
INCARCERATION- NEEDS TO NEEDS
TO IMPROVE. WE HAVE GOOD
PARTNERSHIPS WITH RE ENTRY RE
ENTRY SERVICES ARE COMMUNITIES.
THE EXPANSION OF THAT IS NOT
SHE- AND- BUT IN A WAY THAT IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE THE USAGE ARE
YOU COLLEGE DORMITORIES SO-
EMPTY JAILS BUT ALSO BEFORE I
WOULD DO THAT I WOULD. I WOULD
BE LOW THE EMPTY HOUSE UNITS AT
THIS WITHIN CDC ARE. AND
MAXIMIZE THOSE A TO REDUCE
DENSITY INSTITUTIONS IF I CAN
HOUSE INMATES IN EMPTY
BUILDINGS. LET'S JUST HONEST
CELL. THAT WOULD GET CITY AND I
DO HAVE INDEED. IN SYSTEM I
JUST BE BUT HOWEVER TO THE NAME
OF THE COMPANY ISSUES OF OUR
EXISTING. REALLY MINIMIZE THOSE
TRANSFERS SO- I'LL STOP THERE I
WOULD JUST SAY IT WITH THE
SECRETARY GIVEN YOUR WORKLOAD I
DON'T THINK IT'S REALISTIC TO
EXPECT THAT WE SHIPPED ALL OF
THESE. TO YOU IF YOU IN A FIVE
SOMEONE ON YOUR TEAM ARE THE-
LOVE. WHO COULD. RECEIVE BEEN
COMMUNICATION- WITH THESE
STAKEHOLDERS. AGAIN THEY- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE SEEN ON
OUR- AGAIN ALSO ON IT MAY
FOCUSED AND WOULD NOT SUGGEST
HOMELESSNESS WOULD NOT SUGGEST
INTO A SETTING THAT WOULD. UP
FOR A PER THE- SUPPORT
RESOURCES. OF YOU CAN IDENTIFY
WE CAN DIRECTED TO. BOMB I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. I
THINK THAT BE HELPFUL I THINK
NOT NOT I THINK ABOUT IT SHOULD
PROBABLY BE MY LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS CHIEF SANDY REPEAT AND
SOME LOW SEVENTIES YOU ALL SHE
CAN COLLECT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- IT IS JULYFIRST SO
THE MONEY THAT WE APPROVED IN
THE BUDGET IS AVAILABLE AND
THERE WAS A- A CARRY ON OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDIN. THAT THE
BSE SEE IS ADMINISTERING THAT
CAN SUPPORT- COMMUNITY BASED
GROUPS THAT PROVIDE. REENTRY
BEDS SO- IT I THINK THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
INCORPORATED IN WHATEVER PLANT
IS BEING BLOCKED. BY BEST CDS
YOUR AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY ALLOCATED
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN
DISTRIBUTED YET. BUT THERE MAY
BE FOR EXAMPLE. MANY MANY. RE
ENTRY ORGANISE AMITY TO MIND
THERE'S MANY MANY OTHERS THAT
DO PROVIDE REENTRY BEDS AND WHO
MAY HAVE A SPACES AND THAT
SHOULD BE THOROUGHLY. THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED OUT FOR THAT
PURPOSE. AND WITH THAT I WANT
TO TURN NOW TO THE SECOND PANEL
AND I APPRECIATE. A SECRETARY
DS YOUR- ANSWERING OUR
QUESTIONS AND ALSO MISTER KELSO
AND PREVIOUSLY ARE- DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPRESENTATIVES DOCTOR GOLLY
AND A MIS FINELLI APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN A ONE TO
MOVE ON NOW. TO THE SECOND
PANEL WHICH IT IS- FOLKS YOU
CAN TALK TO US ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF CODE NINETEEN ON THE
COMMUNITY BOTH INSIDE OUTSIDE
FACILITY. WE'RE GONNA HAVE ST
LEWIS WHO'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION FOLLOWED BY JAMES K.
WHO IS THE STAFF THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER AND THE IMPORTANCE.
MISTER LEWIS DISTRICT FORMALLY.
WE HAVE. THEY WHO IS THE PRESS
ABOUT CALIFORNIA THE SOFT
ASSOCIATION AND THE DRE C. ON
WHO IS ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT- UCSF THE NEWS PART
OF AMEND AT UCSF AND WHO IS
PART OF THE SET OF DOCTOR SAID
MR KILLS REFERRED TO AS HE
ASKED THE SET OF UCSF DOCTORS
TO GO TO SAN POINT AND INTO THE-
THAT'S- WERE JEEZ TO MY
PANELIST. IT OPENED THREE. BUT
WE ARE AND WE HAVE TO STOP AT
ONE WE KNOW THERE'S LOTS OF
PUBLIC ONE AD SO. VIEW WE WANT
YOUR INFORMATION IF YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR TIME GREATLY
APPRECIATED SO LET'S START WITH
ST LOUIS. IF YOU'RE IN NEW YORK
DONE MUSIC YES NOW OKAY YOU'RE
CORRECT WE GOT. A GOOD GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU AS SOON PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR A LOT. THERE ARE
A COUPLE OF. SEE OUR WORK THAT
I RECEIVE MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GONNA FALL
WITH ALONG WITH MUCH OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
FAMILIES AND WHAT A CAR. SO I
JUST TO GIVE YOU TO A QUICK
NUMBER DATES ON MORE THIRD. FOR
SIX APRIL SIXTEENTH IN JUNE. A.
R. C. I'M COMING LAW IMPROBABLE
WOULD YOU OTHER ADVOCATES
GROUPS BEGAN AND HAVE BEEN
SINCE. CONSISTENTLY ABBY CABLE.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY US EARLY
RELEASED EARLY POST SAID THE
GUY WE'VE BEEN SENDING. OUR
REQUEST TO DIRECTLY TO THE
GOVERNOR AND SO WE REALLY TAKEN
TIME TO BE TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND SO WE
ADVOCATED FOR THE RELEASE OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE SIXTEEN OVER
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS WE
WERE ALSO CONSISTS ADVOCATES
PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
RELEASED WITHIN THE NEXT SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS. WE PEOPLE WE
BELIEVE IT WAS THE TWENTY SIX
AND EIGHT HOW. CURRENTLY
STEALING CARS WHAT GONE ON TO
FOR PAROLE. BUT TO EXPEDITE
THOSE THOSE ARE ARE STILL
HAPPENED. THE MOST STAY INSIDE
WAKES UP ONE OF THE CLEARANCE.
WELL WE ALSO ADVOCATE UP FOR
SIMPLY OF MINE LEADER MARIA
WALDRON'S CORRECTION FACILITY
EMERGED WAS ACT TO BE CAN. AN
ALL WHEEL AT IT FROM THE START
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN COST.
AND HOW DAHLE. MIGHT WHAT AT
THE SAME TIME FOR BOTH STAFF
AND BETTER COME IN CUSTODY AS
WE HAD THESE WE THAT IF THE
GOVERNOR IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES
IN THESE THESE IDEAS SHOULD BE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED ROOM AND
TODAY UP IS STARTED. THE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL BE RELEASED
PEOPLE. OF FALL INTO A CERTAIN
THAT WITH NO BE RELEASED IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS. I ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT. HAS TRULY TROUBLED
ME AS I HEAR FROM. THE LAST TWO
DAYS. HEARTBREAKING RUSSELL FOR
ME AS PERSON CHOOSE THE JUSTICE
A LITTLE TEN YEARS AGO I WAS IN
SOLITAIRE TRAIN. PRICES RAGING
THROUGH THE CITY I DON'T
REMEMBER DOING EVERYTHING I
COULD POSSIBLY NOT TO GET IT
OUT DID NOT COME OUT MONTHS AGO
A DISTANT FOR TO DISTILL I
LITERALLY DID EVERYTHING I
COULD POSSIBLY THINK OF AND I
STILL ENDED UP CATCHING THIS
VIRUS AND IT WAS BRUTAL IT WAS
WHEN I REMEMBER IN A TOOL CLOCK
IN THE MORNING- UP. THERE ARE
RESPONDING TO JUST MISERABLE
AND BANG ON A STILL ASK ALL
COULD GIVE ME TO. ALSO SAYS
CAN'T DO ANYTHING NOW. BECAUSE
SO MANY STAFF COULD NOT DOWN BY
THE THIS THIS LITTLE BUYERS
REMEMBER LET A MONTH THANKS TO
MUST MICHAEL HERE LIKE ANIMAL.
CALL ME AND THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR LOVED ONES. IN THIS
FIRE'S BEEN DYING FROM THIS
BUYERS. WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
CHINO AND THEN WHEN I GET PHONE
CALLS AND LETTERS FROM PEOPLE
THAT ARE INSIDE WE PUSHED A LOT
OF THESE LETTERS FROM PEOPLE
INSIDE. TO THAT FEAR OF
CATCHING OUR SOMETIME THEY
DON'T WANT TO GUIDE SO I
WOULDN'T DOING WE- CAN THE
GOVERNOR HELPLESS. RIGHT IN
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE NO **** TO BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT WE'RE WE'RE NOT IN A
POSITION OF POWER BUT WE CAN'T
ADVOCATE STRONG ADVOCATE. THOSE
VOICES. THE THINGS THAT
BOTHERED ME IMMENSELY WAS.
SIXTEEN PEOPLE DIED CHAU AND IT
WAS THEIR SEEMINGLY TO ME WAS
NOT ENOUGH I DON'T RATES UP FOR.
WHAT DOES DEBTS. AND I BLAME-
BUT I'M NOT. GOING TO SEEM LIKE
IF WE HAD JUMPED ON IT THEN.
REALLY HAD. ACTUALLY BEEN MADE
IT WOULD NEVER REACH SANK WITH
GREAT I DON'T KNOW. WHAT I DO
KNOW IS THAT AND SADLY BUT I
HAVE TO SPEAK TO IS TRUE
BECAUSE BEEN ASKED OF ME BUT
MANY PEOPLE AT. WHAT IT TAKES.
AN INSTITUTIONAL LOCATED. WHERE
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF POWER
IN TWO MONTHS AND WEALTH AND
PRIVILEGE WITH THIS UPWARD
COMMON PEOPLE DIED ALREADY. AND
IT BREAKS MY HEART TO BE TO
HAVE TO TELL THEM THAT I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T HAVE THOSE ANSWERS.
ADDITION TO. ADVOCACY WORK WHEN
WE FIRST HEARD THAT THEY WERE
NOT A MATT ENOUGH MASK INSIDE
OF THE FACILITIES- OUR CAR OR
SPONSORS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WE
JUST STARTED DONATE RATS WE
DON'T WE DONATED OVER TWO
THOUSAND MASK UNTIL WE LOOK AT
YOUR I CAUGHT UP WITH ALL. THE
MASTER. I UNDERSTAND IN SO YOUR
ISSUE ONE SO. WE CAN ONE OF
THE- THINGS THAT UP HEALTH
OFFICIALS TELL YOU TO DO IS TO
CASTING YOU WASH YOUR HANDS.
YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S ALL. OVER SO
WE ISSUE WE DONATED. OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND BARS AND WE FOR ALMOST
INSTANT. HAD RICH FIRST
STARTING WHICH US I AM. THE I
AM SEE I GOT YOUR LANCASTER.
THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN IN NOW OR
OR THAT WE SAW APRIL US ONE
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE WERE RELEASE THERE WAS
NO SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY BASED
OR AS A STEEP THEIR OWN OR
JUST. PROVIDE. IT IS WORKING.
WRONG ON COMMERCIAL BUT JUST
WHAT THEY- DID IT ON THEIR OWN
ABOUT. BE HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
AND WE ABOUT TO RELEASE ANOTHER
THOUSAND FIVE PEOPLE IN THE
STORE TODAY AND THE THERE'S NO
SUPPORT PLEASE COME BASED.
WE'RE LITERALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO COVER THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION. SELECT
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE PPVS WHEN I STEP ON
INSTITUTIONS THATTHEY DON'T
HAVE THEM SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THEM AND WE'RE ABLE TO GIVE
YOUR GO TO GIVE THEM TO. THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY IS THIS.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR. SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHICS THE SIXTEEN PEOPLE
AT THE SOCIAL OF ALL. AND HEARD
IT. THE SEPARATION OF THERE
WERE TWENTY TWO PEOPLE IN DIED
IN TO CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
WERE TWENTY FOR HUMAN BEINGS TO
GUIDELINES. I DON'T
DIFFERENTIATE TO THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS OF THEIR
TO DO ITS JOB NO HUMAN BEING
MET FANS LOCALS THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN CUSTODY HAVE BROKEN LAW
AND NOT BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
TO HUMAN BEINGS THAT FAMILIES
LEVELS. WOULD DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THESE IN THIS IS THAT THAT THAT
PASSED AWAY FROM COAL. UP WITH.
WHAT THEY HAVE. PROTECTED OR
SAY IT IF THEY IF WERE OLD
OVERSEE OR UNDER GOALS ISSUE
WITHIN PROTECT AND SAY. IF WE
HAD GIVEN THEM RLEASE. IF WE
TAKE A MOMENT JUST TO LOOK AT
IF POSSIBLE MAYBE REACH OUT TO
THE MINORITY LEADER AND LOOK AT
THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACT IS NOT
JUST LOCAL PRODUCE ANYTHING
LIKE THIS WHEN I GO BACK TO WIN
WHEN NOROVIRUS RAVAGES.
CORRECTION FACILITY. IT WAS
LIKE JUST YOU JUST HAVE TO FOR
TO TAKE ITS COURSE. WRESTLER
WHERE WOULD WHAT WAS. HEARD
PEOPLE INSIDE THAT IN SOME
INSTANCES THERE'S ROBUST
CLEANING INSIDE THE FACILITIES
MULTIPLE TIMES THEIR SOLDIERS
DISTANCING ONLY ONE YOUR ONE
BUILDING CAN GO TO YOUR TIME.
THERE'S A JOINT EFFORT WITH
BOTH STAFF AND PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY HER EXACT OPPOSITE OF
SOME SORT OF THE SUIT BUT
THERE'S NO CLEANING AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE NOT. MEDICAL SO I
HAVE MIXED MIXED BATCH OF THESE
REPORTS FROM PEOPLE THAT I KNOW
AND I TRUST. THAT THEY'RE BEING
HONEST WITH. THE. I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE WILL LOOK AT THIS
LANCASTER WHICH IS ONE OF THE
FIRST INSTITUTIONS THAT OPERATE
THEY HAVE ZERO ACTIVE CASES
RIGHT NOW WE DID LANCASTER
RIGHT TO THE CITY'S EIGHT THE
STUDENT DATA SO WE HAVE TO
CASES ALL WE DID GREAT RIGHT
ORDER- MAKE SURE NO I MEAN
MAYBE A COP FORCES TO MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WATER THIS
INSIDER. WHEN LOOKING AT THOSE.
IN MAYBE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
LOS. I'M ALSO HERE TO JUST SAY
WHAT WE CAN DO ASK BELIEVE US
MOST OF MY ALL COMMUNITY OR- I
WANT TO HELP WHATEVER WE CAN TO
READ THIS PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION. FROM TO SEIZE
UPON RELEASE THIS. PEOPLE THAT
ARE ARE FREE TO WEAR MASKS WE
ARE TO BE OF SERVICE HELP THE
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY. AS WELL
AS THE STAFF AND SYSTEMS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER LEWIS. SHE THANK THE
JUSTIN TO GET LANCASTER IS VERY
VERY GOOD ONE. WHEN I. IN I
ALSO TAKE NOTICE THAT. I THINK
THERE IS A CORRECT PERCEPTION
THAT. IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A-
IT'S NOT A WRONG THING FOR
PEOPLE TO REACT TO SAN QUENTIN
AND CERTAINLY THE NUMBER OF
CASES BUT YES THE FACT WE'RE
SAN QUENTIN IS LOCATED- DOES
GIVE IT MORE ATTENTION THAN
SOME OF OUR OTHER FACILITIES
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY MANY
PEOPLE IN THE LOW TURNOUT
STARTED LEGISLATURE'S YOU
DESCRIBED WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO GET ANSWERS AND ON THIS NOW
FOR MONTHS IT WAS WE DID. FEEL
THE SAME QUENTIN'S VOICE. BUT
YEAH WE HAVE THE WHOLE CAN SAY
THE HOPE IT THEY'RE NOT NOW TO
TRY LIKELY TO GET FULLY CONTROL
OF IT LET'S TURN TO JAMES KING
FROM THE ELLA BAKER CENTER.
GOOD MORNING THANKS TO THE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS JANE CAN
BE. I WAS RELEASED FROM SAN
QUENTIN SIX MONTHS AGO AFTER
LIVING THERE FOR SIX AND A HALF
YEARS. DURING MY TIME THE
QUARANTINES WERE ROUTINE. NO
MATTER HOW OFTEN I WASH MY
HANDS WAS CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT I
TOUCH TOO I WAS PROXIMATE TO I
NEVER WENT ONE YEAR WITHOUT IN
THE COAL. BECAUSE I LIVED IN
THE BUILDING WHICH- I AM FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE BUT HOUSE NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED. WE SHARED EIGHTEEN
SHOWER HEADS AND TWELVE PAY
PHONES THE BUILDING WAS POORLY
VENTILATED WE LIVED IN CLOSE
QUARTERS THE WINDOWS ARE WELDED
SHUT THE SALES HAVE BARS
INSTEAD OF DOORS. THE SALES ARE
FOR THE WIDE AND ABOUT NINE
FEET IN LENGTH AND HAVE TWO
PEOPLE LIVING IN. AS WE SPEAK
ALL OF THE- EXPERIENCING A
SURGEON CORONAVIRUSES. AN
INSIDE SAN QUENTIN THE FASTEST
GROWING SCHOOL SEARCH HAS GROWN
TO OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED ALREADY.
I SPEAK TO MY LOVED ONES ON THE
INSIDE I HEAR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IS IMPOSSIBLE. THE
MEDICAL ALARMS ARE GOING OFF
EVERY TEN MINUTES. PEOPLE
INCLUDING HOSPITAL WORKERS WERE
CLEANING COLD INFECTED SALES
ARE BEING DENIED SHOWERS THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ISSUED HAND
SANITIZER SINCE MARCH. MEDICAL
STAFF REFUSES TO GIVE THEM ANY
UPDATES ON THE OUTBREAK. AND
THEY ARE SCARED. THEY SAY
MOVING THEM FROM ONE HIGHLY
OVERCROWDED PRISON TO ANOTHER
IS NOT THE ANSWER. THE ONLY
SAFE RESPONSIBLE SOLUTION IS
LARGE SCALE RELEASES BUT IN
SPITE OF REPORTS TO THE
CONTRARY LEASES HAVE ACTUALLY
SLOW DOWN. THE BEGINNING A
MODIFIED PROGRAM IN MARCH
EARNING TIME OFF OF PRISON
SENTENCES TO REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING HAS BEEN HALTED. IN
PREPARING THESE REMARKS I HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO STOP THINKING
ABOUT MY FRIEND FREDDIE COLE.
HE SEVENTY NINE YEARS OLD
NUMBER TIMES IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE DIDN'T THINK HE'D SURVIVE
THE YEAR BECAUSE HE HAD OPEN
HEART SURGERY AND HIS MATES
WERE ADJUSTED SEVERAL TIMES. I
pA SPOKESWOMAN THE BEGINNING OF
JUNE. THE OUTBREAK WAS BEGIN. I
HEARD CHAIR IN HIS VOICE. MY
DEAR FRIEND ERAGON SIXTY SIX
FOUND OUT EARLIER THIS YEAR TO
JUST CANCERS RETURNED AND HE
WILL I COULD NOT LIVE OUT THE
YEAR. THIS WEEK I THOUGHT HE
WAS ONE. OF THE MANY WHO TESTED
POSITIVE. THINKING OF LINE MORE
SIXTY EIGHT. A FRIEND WAS
MENTORED HUNDREDS OF OTHERS
BOTH INCARCERATED AND AFTER HIS
FORTY TWO YEARS IN PRISON. HE
CREATE ITSELF- PROGRAMMING THAT
IS PREPARED THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
FOR RELEASE. AND I'M THINKING
OF PATRICIA RIGHT A CIW SIXTY
NINE AND CHEMOTHERAPY WITH LESS
THAN SIX MONTHS TO LIVE ALSO. I
SAY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THAT
NONE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS I'M
NAMING FOR ALL SERVING
SENTENCES FOR VIOLENT FELONIES
ARE A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
TODAY. IN EACH OF THESE PEOPLE
LIKE SCORES OF OTHERS WE HEAR
FROM HAVE FAMILIES THEY CAN
RETURN TO IMMEDIATE. RESPONSE
TO THE OUTBREAK STANDPOINT HAS
MOVED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE TO THE
WHOLE OR AN OUTSIDE HOSPITAL.
IN FAMILY THIS TIME THE WICKER
DIMITRIUS MCGEE JUAN CARLOS
MASON THE DLC FUENTES AND TOO
MANY OTHERS DO NOT KNOW THEIR
STATUS FOR EXACT LOCATION.
FAMILIES TRY TO GET INFORMATION
ON THE STATUS OF THEIR LOVED
ONE STAFF IS NOT RETURNING
EMAILS ARE ANSWERING PHONE
CALLS. AND PEOPLE AYE INSIDE I
HEAR THAT PLACING THEM IN THE
HOLE FOR BEING SICK IS NOT THE
ANSWER. NEAR MOVED THEIR
PROPERTIES PLACED IN STORAGE
AND ARE GIVEN A SHEET A BLANKET
IN A BAR SO. THE SALES ARE THEY
ARE BEING PLACED IN OUR DIRTY
IN A RUSH TO PACK EVERYTHING UP
GUARDS ARE LOSING WHAT FEW
FAMILY MEMENTOS AND PERSONAL
ITEMS. INSIDER CLOUT. NOT THIS
COMMITTEES HIGHLIGHTING THE CDC
OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH
ICE. CDC ARE IS THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF NEW BOOKINGS FOR EYES
FACILITIES. ONE IN THREE PEOPLE
TESTED BY AYE AYES HAVE BEEN
FOUND POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS.
AT SAN QUENTIN ONE OF THE WORST
OUTBREAKS IS A CURRENT ON DEATH
ROW WITH FAMILY MEMBERS OF LOVE
ONE SOUNDED THE ALARM AT A
RECENT TOWN HALL. SANITATION IS
NOT BEING PROPERLY ATTENDED TO
AND STAFF ARE WORKING OVERTIME
IN THE AREA AFTER WORKING OTHER
SECTIONS OF THE PRISON. IT'S
HEARTBREAKING IN RESPONSE IS TO
SET UP SIX TENS AND CREATE A
MODEST PLAN TO RELEASE PEOPLE
NOT BASED UPON WHO WAS MOST
VULNERABLE IT'S NT BASED UPON
PRIORITIZING THE ELDERLY IT'S
NOT EVEN BASED UPON THE CDC
OURS COMPREHENSIVE RISK
ASSESSMENT WHO IS LEAST LIKELY
TO COMMIT VIOLENCE A RESERVE A-
INSTEAD. THEY HAVE A PLAN IS
BASED UPON THE CRIME A PERSON
COMMITTED EVEN IF IT WERE
TWENTY THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS
AGO. AND THE FACT THAT A PERSON
HAPPENS TO HAVE A RELEASE DATE
SOON. IT'S OBVIOUS THAT CDC ARE
DOES NOT UNDERSTAND THE REAL
THREAT HERE. I WAS EXCITED TO
CENTER TO REQUIRE IS CONVENING
AN ALL HANDS ON DECK MEETING
TONIGHT I WANT TO OFFER MYSELF
AS WELL AS OTHER ADVOCATES AS A
RESOURCE TO SHARE REENTRY
RESOURCES I WOULD LOVE TO
ATTEND TONIGHT. THANKS FOR YOUR
IDEAS HAS CREATED A NEW UNIFIED
COMMAND CENTER. AND I WOULD
REFER TO THAT TEAM THE JUNE
FIFTEEN URGENT MEMO BY BERKELEY
HEALTH OFFICIALS THEY SAID IF
THE INCARCERATION NUMBERS AT
SAN QUENTIN ARE NOT REDUCE BY
AT LEAST FIFTY PERCENT.
OUTBREAK WILL OVERWHELM THE
ENTIRE BAY AREA. THIS OUTBREAK
IS ST CLINTON. LIKE TWO ONCE A
CORPORATE C. I. WCCC ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO HUMAN ERROR. BUT
THOSE OF US WHO HAS SPENT TIME
IN SAN QUENTIN NO THE OUTBREAK
WAS INEVITABLE. BECAUSE THE CDC
OURS COVERT RESPONSE PLAN IS
INSUFFICIENT AND FUNDAMENTALLY
FLAWED. UNTIL WE COME TO TERMS
WITH THE FACT THAT LARGE SCALE
RELEASES ARE NECESSARY FOR THE
SAFETY NOT JUST OF THOSE INSIDE
BUT THE ENTIRE STATE. THIS
PROBLEM WILL NOT GO AWAY IN
BOTH INCARCERATED AND NON
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WILL DIE.
THANK YOU. MISTER KING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR A
HEARTFELT AND ACCURATE REMARKS
NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM- GLENN
STALEY WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF
OUR CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ONE
OF THE- STAFF ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING STAFF AT THE AT
OUR CDC OUR FACILITIES ACTUALLY
THE LARGEST GO AHEAD MISTER
STALEY. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. BUT
ONCE DALY CCPOA STATE PRESIDENT
I'M BLESSED REPRESENT THIRTY
THOUSAND THE HARDEST WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN IN CORRECTIONS
AND PAROLE. I LIKE TO START OFF
BY STATING HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT HEARING THIS
MORNING LIKE THE REST OF WORLD
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TIME FOR
MEMBERS. OUR EXPERIENCE. HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY CHALLENGING AS
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE EVER CHANGING.
YEAH WE'RE DOING OUR BEST TO
PROBABLY DOUBT BY MAKING SURE
MEMBERS UNNECESSARY INFORMATION
THE P. ANYTHING ELSE THEY MAY
NEED TO CONTINUE TO FILL CITY
FROM PROVIDING AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS BEEN
HELLISH EXPERIENCE FOR MEMBERS
AS IS TAKING A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
BRAVERY AND COURAGE TO DO THE
WORK WE DO EVERY DAY. AS WE
SEEM TO OVER NINETEEN TAKES ITS
COURSE OVER TIME. WE WITNESS
STRESS LEVELS ANXIETY. FEAR
INCREASED AMOUNTS ARE RAINS
THESE CONDITIONS ARE ACTUALLY
SO SHOULD WITH OUR JOB DUTIES.
BUT THE FEAR SPACE. YOUR IT
DERIVES THE WORRY OF BRING IN
THIS DISEASE HOME TO OUR
FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES AS A
RESULT THIS IS SITUATION. THE
MEASURE TO BE PROACTIVE IN KEEP
IN THE MEMBER SAVE. IN ITS
EARLY ONSET THE MEDIA GDC R. A
C. H. C. S. WAS RELEASING
INFORMATION THAT WAS NOT ALWAYS
PERFECTLY ALIGNED. IS
CONFLICTING INFORMATION LET
TERM MEMBERS TO BE I'M SURE OF
THE VITAL FACTORS SUCH AS
WEATHER IN OCTOBER NINETEEN.
WAS AN AIRBORNE OR DROP A
TRANSMISSION HOW LONG THE VIRUS
LAOS WHETHER OR NOT MASS
PROTECTION WAS NECESSARY. I
NEEDED TO BE QUARANTINE AND THE
MOST SUITABLE WEIGHT SOCIAL
DISTANCE IN A PRISON SETTING.
AS AN EXAMPLE A DISCREPANT
INFORMATION WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE
FACILITIES ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF ISSUES YET
IMPLEMENTING THE POLICY VARYING
WAYS WHICH HAS LED TO DO AS FAR
RIGHT WELL YOU'RE BASIS WE DO
TAKE THE- YEAH WE CAN CALL. DE
IN HIS MANAGEMENT JUDGE CERTAIN
POLICY ALSO LIKE TO STRESS THE
FACT THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
CONCLUSION WE WANT OUR MEMBERS
TO HAVE A SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT. THIS REQUIRES A
BETTER DECISION MAKING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THE CHECKER WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSFERS. THERE'S
BEEN MISCONCEPTION THAT WE
BELIEVE CO IN NINETEEN. IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A HOAX OR
SOME MADE UP CONSPIRACY. I WANT
TO MAKE. WRONG STATEMENT AS
SAYS THAT'S NOT THE CASE WE
HAVE SPENT OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS ON P. T. OUR MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. I ALONG
WITH MORE EXECUTIVE COUNCIL
MEMBERS BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA TO PERSONALLY
DELIVER PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IN
THREE DIFFERENT WAYS. I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THE RECEIVERSHIP
INSPECTOR DHEAS NEUROLOGISTS
THAT OUR OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
WEARING THE MASK AND TO SAY
OTHERWISE IS A MISCALCULATION.
FRANKLY INSULTING MY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AS A CRACK OFFICER
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A TIME WHERE
ON THE WHOLE OFFICER IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. SURE THE COMMON THREAD.
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
OFFICERS ARE PRIORITY. BUT WE
NEED TO ENSURE THE WELL BEING
OF EVERYONE IN THE INSTITUTION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATORS IN TO RECONCILE
THESE ISSUES AND WITH THAT I'LL
BE HAPPY TAKING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SEARS- I THINK
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE DOCTOR AND
THEN I'M SURE SOME MEMBERS WILL
HAVE QUESTIONS APPRECIATE I
MEAN MISTER STALEY SORRY-
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
TEST. BUT IF YOU GO NOW TO
DOCTOR SEARS WHO IS- AS I
MENTIONED AT UCSF DOCTOR IN
PART OF THE GROUP CALLED AMEND
AND WHO IS- ASKED BY THE
RECEIVER TO GO TO- SAN QUENTIN.
AND I BELIEVE IT WAS ON JUNE-
MID JUNE THEY RELEASED THEIR-
AIR RECOMMEND REPORT THEIR
OBSERVATIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS SO DOCTOR SEARS.
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO MAKE A STATEMENT
ON THE TRAGEDY HOLDING STATE
PERSON. I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE BUT I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE ALREADY UNDERSTANDS
NOT THAT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTROL KOBE NINETEEN IN
CALIFORNIA UNTIL WE ADDRESS
WHAT IS HAPPENING INSIDE
PRISONS AND JAILS. YOUR AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A MAN YES.
MEN'S CLOTHING CALIFORNIA
PRISONS PROGRAM COMPRISES
ACADEMICS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WITH EXPERTISE
INFECTIOUS DISEASES GERIATRICS
PUBLIC HEALTH. HEALTH SYSTEMS
AND EPIDEMIOLOGY FROM UCSF UC
BERKELEY. IS IT SAN QUENTIN ON
JUNE THIRTEENTH AT THE REQUEST
OF THE FEDERAL RECEIVER'S
OFFICE AT THE TIME THERE KNOWN
CASE COUNT WAS SIXTEEN. BASED
ON OUR VISIT AND HOW THE
OUTBREAK IS INVOLVED SINCE THEN
WE MAKE THE FOLLOWING PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR HOW TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE
TO KOBE TEEN IN PRISONS. IS
ANSWER IT TO THE GRAVE THREAT.
FIRST DEVELOP A CENTRALIZED
COVER NINETEEN OUTBREAK
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAM I WILL
SAY THAT I'M PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT THIS IS URGENTLY BEING
CREATED AND I HAVE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE TEAM
THIS TEAM SORTIE TO MAKE PUBLIC
HEALTH BASED DECISIONS IN. IT
SHOULD WORK IN THE BODY DIRT
BOND TO AN OUTBREAK PRISONS
WITHOUT BRAKES NEED A DEDICATED
EXPERIENCE ALL TIME TEAM WITH
KNOWLEDGE OF CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH AND SPECIFIC EXPERTISE.
ORDER TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC
VULNERABILITIES THAT BEEN FOUND
THIS TEAM SHOULD INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING POSITIONS NUMBER ONE.
ENVIRONMENT KERRY LEAD
OPTIMIZES VENTILATION
SANITATION AND PATIENT FLOW IN
THE PRESENT TO MITIGATE CODED
NINETEEN SPREAD THROUGH.
AGAINST INFECTION CONTROL
PRACTICES NUMBER TWO HEALTH
CARE CUSTODY COORDINATION.
ORDERS WITH CUSTODY TO ASSESS
ON A DAILY BASIS HOUSING AND
RESIDENCE FOR MEDICAL ISOLATION
AND QUARANTINE AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE MEDICAL
LEADERSHIP. VERSE THREE KOBE
TESTING LEAD TO COORDINATE
TESTING OF ALL RESIDENTS HEALTH
CARE STAFF IN CUSTODY IN WHO
INSURES RAPID TESTING TURN
AROUND TIME. NUMBER FOUR A
STAFF HEALTH CARE LIAISON LEAD
TO COHORT STAFF AND TRAIN
APPROPRIATE PP USE IN INFECTION
CONTROL MEASURES NUMBER FIVE IN
ACADEMIA ALL JUST ANALYST WHO
TRACKS IN REVIEWS LINE LISTING
OF ACTIVE AND RESOLVED CASES.
SEC RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
URGENT A KERR SERRATION TO
ADDRESS OVERCROWDING THIS IS
PARTICULARLY CRITICAL IT SEEMED
QUINN IN ANY PRISON
PREFERENTIALLY HOUSES AGING AND
MEDICALLY COMPLEX PATIENTS SUCH
TO CALIFORNIA MEDICAL COOLEY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY. WHAT RECOMMENDED THE
PRISON POPULATION POINT B.
URGENTLY REDUCE TO AT LEAST 50%
OF THE CURRENT CAPACITY.
FRANKLY IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND
HOW RESIDENTS AND STAFF CAN
SAFELY CONTINUE LIVING WORKING
IN SAN QUENTIN AT ALL. THAT
SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT MAY HAVE
UNIQUE OWN ABILITIES TO
CONVERSATION IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
CALL THE NINETEEN MEDICATION
ANY PRESENT. ALL REMAINING
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY
DEPENDENT UPON G. CAR SERRATION.
SIX REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EVERY TIME
YOU HEAR THE WORDS ACCORDING I
SAW. CORD ALL OF THAT SHOULD
LEAD TO YOU THINKING THE
QUESTION OF HOW AND HOW TO DO
THAT CONTROLS THE CAR
SITUATION. OR EIGHTEEN
ISOLATION OF PATIENTS THE TANK
NGUYEN IN ANY PRISON IS LIKE A
DELICATE CAME. CALIFORNIA
PRISONS ARE ALREADY OVER 1100%
CAPACITY EVERY SQUARE AND THAT
TRANSPORT HAS ONE OR TWO PIECES
ALREADY ON IT. THIS MAKES
DISTRICT MOVEMENT OF RESIDENTS
NEARLY AND HOW. AS A RESULT WE
MUST KEEP POPULATE ALL OF OUR
PRISONS MEDIA WE HAVE ANY HOPE
OF WINNING. WHAT IS HAPPENED
IT'S- HOW. OTHER THE FOUNDATION
OF COAL NINETEEN MITIGATION THE
CAN. DIFFICULT DISTANCING
CASTING TO ISOLATE CASES IN
QUARANTINE EXPOSED PEOPLE NONE
OF THESE ANY STANDARD PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT SPACE. AS
A RESULT RAPIDLY BECAUSE REGION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA PRISONS
ISN'T URGENT PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ARE SERRATED CORRECTIONAL STAFF.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. THIRD
RECOMMENDED IS TO IMMEDIATELY
DEVELOP PLANNED TO SUPPORT CAST
AND PROTECT DISABILITY STAFF
WERE JUST AS VULNERABLE TO
INFECTION IN WHO MAY TRANSMIT
KOBE NINETEEN. INSIDE THE
PRISON AND IN COMMUNITY THE%
CURRENT OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
CONTRACT AT SAN QUENTIN DOES
NOT ALIGN WITH THE STAFF NEEDS
TO THE CORPORATE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. CONSEQUENTLY OVER
YOUR APARTMENT PUBLIC TESTING
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH WE'VE
HEARD SOME ABOUT TODAY FOR
CONGREGATE SETTINGS DURING AN
OPERATE. CASTING ALL STAFF
EVERY WEEK. IN ADDITIONALLY
OFFICE INSTEAD MUST BE. COLD AT
WORK ONLY SPECIFIC HOUSING
UNITS OR OTHER PHYSICAL SPACES
WITH THE SAME SENSE OF
RESIDENTS TO MINIMIZE THE RISK
OF SPREADING QUICKLY NINETEEN
WITHIN THE PRISON. SO TO
SUMMARIZE WHAT CAN BE DONE NOW
AT SAN QUENTIN HANDED PRISONS
ACROSS THE STATE. NUMBER ONE
IMMEDIATELY CONVENE THIS CALL
BUT NINETEEN OUTBREAK REGENCY
RESPONSE WITH THE STAFFING THAT
I'VE DESCRIBED. TO IMMEDIATELY
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
PRISON POPULATION RUDY
PERSPIRATION. NUMBER THREE.
IMPROVE MEASURES TO CAST COHORT.
OFFICERS AND STOP. LIKE TO
CLOSE BY DESCRIBING WHAT WAS
REALLY HAUNTING EXPERIENCES WE
LESS SANGUINE AFTER. MEN WORK
WE I THINK A LOT DOORS HELP. MY
STILL FREQUENTLY HEAR THEM
SHOUTING PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE
HELP US I CAN STILL REMEMBER
THE LOOK OF SHOCK FOR BOATING
ON THE FACES OF THE OFFICERS
THAT COULD NOT KEEP IN MIND A
MATCH. I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL TOLD THE
OPRY GET SAMPLING WHAT'S TAKEN
THE CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
STAFF WORKING THERE. MOST
IMPORTANTLY ON THE RESIDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THESE DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS. FOURTEEN AMEND
FURLAN FIRMLY BELIEVES THE
PRISONS ARE A REFLECTION OF WHO
WE ARE SOCIETY. IS UPON ALL OF
US RESPOND IMMEDIATELY. PRO
ACTIVELY ADDRESS THIS TRAGEDY
TO PREVENT IT FROM UNFOLDING
AGAIN AND AGAIN AROUND THE
STATE. KING KONG WAS NOT THE
FIRST PERSON TO BE TESTED BY
KOBE NINETEEN UNFORTUNATELY
WON'T BE THE LAST. PLEASE
CONTINUE TO CALL IN OUR GROUP
THAT AND IF WE CAN BE OF
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU DOCTOR SEARS- LET ME SEE IF
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS. GO AHEAD SENATOR
MITCHELL. THE TESTIMONY WAS
QUITE COMPELLING ALONG ON
WONDER RAIN AND MAYBE IT'S
REALLY QUESTION IF YOU ARE
MADAM CHAIR OF WHAT WE CAN DO.
TO ENCOURAGE REQUIRE THE KIND
OF TASK FORCE THAT DOCTOR FEARS
DELINEATE DELINEATE DELINEATED
IN HIS LIST OF THINGS TO DO IT
WAS IT WAS NUMBER ONE SECOND OF
COURSE ADDITIONAL SO YEAH I'M
NOT PATH. WHAT WHAT CAN. BUT
AFFECT CHOICE THAT. THURMAN
CHOI IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
AND I THINK THE NUMBER OF US
WHILE WHILE OBVIOUSLY IN YOUR
LETTERS TO JPL FROM TLC. YOU
DID NOT TESTIFIED WHAT YOU
THINK SHOULD BE IN THEIR PLAN
BUT YOU HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR A
PLANNED FOR ALL THIS TIME AND
WE DIDN'T GET ONE YET NOW IN
THE LETTER SO I SENT. I DID
TALK ABOUT RELEASE BECAUSE OF
JUST THE KNOWLEDGE OF. THE THAT
WE KNOW THAT TO CONTAIN THE
DISEASE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
APPROPRIATE FISCAL DISTANCING
AND THAT WOULD THAT WAS NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE ACHIEVED
IN MANY OF OUR FACILITIES AND
WE THOSE WITH LIKES THINGS AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT THEY
HAD INITIALLY THE WORST
OUTBREAKS WERE THOSE WITH TYPE
OF. THING SO. I KNOW THAT ANY
INCIDENT WHAT WE ARE KNOW
BECAUSE DOCTOR GOLLY DESCRIBED
TO US IS GOING TO BE SET UP WE
COULD CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S OUR
COMMITTEE OR WHETHER EVEN JBL
SEE OR TO- A LETTER THAT- DEAD
SPACE. SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE THINK MIGHT BE MIGHT NEED TO
BE IN THIS PLAN AND THE
INCIDENT COMMAND SHOULD DEAL
WITH. I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
GUESS REALLY MY- AT AND I DON'T
FULLY EXPECT TO HAVE THE ANSWER
BUT I GUESS MY POINT WAS.
WRITING LETTERS HASN'T ANYWHERE
RIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT. WHICH IS
PART IN ANDREAS SEVEN WONDERING
YEAH. GOOD POINT IF IT- LET
DESPITE OUR I'M I'M YOU KNOW
THINKING OUT LOUD WHICH YOU
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T DO IN A
PUBLIC HEARING MADAM CHAIR. BUT
WE AT. THING LETTERS ARE NO
LONGER WRITER URATE AND SELL IT
AND I AGREE AND IT'S BEEN A- I
HAVE BEEN A PART OF. FACES WITH
YOU AND THE SECRETARY THE ISSUE
OF RELIEF FOR YOU HAVE
REPEATEDLY REMINDED US ALL
RELEASES ARE HAPPY THAT IT
HAPPENED. A LEASES THAT WHAT. I
PREFER EIGHT ON THE FOCUS ON
SAN QUENTIN APPROPRIATELY FELL
BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM MR
CAL SO ABOUT THE SYSTEM WIDE.
SO AT THE END. DOT PIERCING.
YOU KNOW STRIKE FOR THE LACK OF
A BETTER WORD. TO DEAL WITH THE
SYSTEM WIDE. PANDEMIC INTERNAL
PANDEMIC ALMOND SO PERHAPS YOU
LIKE IN THAT CONVERSATION
OFFLINE TALK TO LEADERSHIP TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT NEXT SELECT
THANK YOU CAN DO TOM TO COME
KATE OUR EXPECTATIONS THANK YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE NIGHT
YOU'RE POINTING OUT WANT AN
INDOOR. ONE SIX SO I DID IT THE
BEGINNING OF THE- THAT YES OR
RISER FOCUSED ON SAN QUENTIN
HOWEVER. AN END YOU KNOW WE
WERE HAPPY TO HEAR OF THE
CONTAINMENT AT LANCASTER AND
SUCH. BUT JUST THE NATURE OF
OUR FACILITIES. THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN. AND MY THIS MUST BE
DEALT WITH AS A SYSTEM WIDE IT
CANNOT BE SOLELY AND ONLY FOR
SAN QUENTIN SO I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH YOU. THE BASED IN. THE
WORK EIGHT ONCE AGAIN. OF
BECAUSE OR ARE- PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAILER BILL HE'S STILL ON THE
TWO WAS NOT PASSED BY THE
SECOND HOUSE YET. WE HAVE THE
DOZEN STATUTE RIGHT NOW MEDICAL
ELDERLY PAROLE. AND NOW WHEN IT
WAS DESIGNED IT WASN'T I DON'T
THINK WE NECESSARILY THOUGHT OF
IT IN RELATIONSHIP. TO TWO
PANDEMIC LIKE THIS I THINK THE
MIDDLE PEOPLE HAD DIFFERENT
MOTIVATIONS OBVIOUSLY BUT PART
OF THE THINKING AT THE TIME
THAT IT WAS DEVELOPED WAS THE
FACT THAT OUR PRINTING COSTS.
OUR STATE BUDGET FIRST YOUR UP
EXPONENTIALLY AND LARGELY DUE
TO THE TO THESE LARGE
HEALTHCARE COSTS OF THESE VERY
MEDICALLY FRAGILE PEOPLE IN
VERY ELDERLY PEOPLE AND JUSTICE
IN THE REST OF THE POCKET. AND
SO THERE WAS THE NET. IF WE
COULD X. COULD NOT JUST EXPAND
WE HAD NO MEDICAL AN ELDERLY
PRO UNTIL THAT STATUTE WAS
PASSED. NOW YOU KNOW I'VE NOW
ASK IT. THAT STRUCTURE BEEN
PAST THERE HAVE BEEN VERY VERY.
IT REALLY PAROLED UNDER THOSE.
AND HERE WE ARE IN THIS
PANDEMIC THAT STATUTE IS STILL
AVAILABLE TO CDC ARE IN YET
WHEN I PASSED A SECRETARY DS
ABOUT IT EXPLICITLY PROX
WILLIAM TO GO. TO ME THAT'S THE
EIGHT PEOPLE RECOMMENDED BUT
WHEN I ASKED HIM FOR THE TIME
PERIOD HE SAID IT WAS SEVENTY
EIGHT THAT WERE RECOMMENDED
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND NON
SITS. DOWN THOSE. VERY FEW WERE
ACTUALLY SUCCESSFUL ONCE BEFORE
THE PROBOARDS AND I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE MEDICAL ON
THE PEARL DOESN'T JUST LET
PEOPLE BE RELEASED THE START TO
GO FOR THE PRO ABOARD IN THE
PROBE NOT EVEN ACTING. AND
CERTAINLY GIVEN THAT WE KNOW.
THAT THE DEATH RATE IS HIGHER
FOR MEDICALLY FRAGILE AN
ELDERLY PEOPLE. THEN IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE FOR US TO USE THIS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO YOU THE
STATUTORY TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
GIVEN THEM I'M- ALSO. BEEN OUT
AND I'M SO I. THE POPE TIME
BECAUSE I TO GET TO THEM. BUT I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT YOU
KNOW IT COST US RIGHT NOW. IN
THE INCARCERATED IN TO HOW THEM
AND- IF WE WERE TO DO A DEEP
BECAUSE OF THIS PUBLIC CRISES.
PARK FOR THEM ALL WOULD BE FOR
LESS FAR LESS AND WE ALSO HEARD.
TIMES ABOUT STAFFING SHORTAGES
WHICH SURPRISE ME BECAUSE WE
HAVE A VERY NUMBER OF STAFF IN
OUR. A PRISON SYSTEM IN A CD
SURE SO BUT IF IN FACT THERE
ARE STARTING SHORTAGES. IN WHAT
BETTER TO YOU. THESE TOOLS WE
HAVE. DEEP ACOSTA THE HEALTH OF
EVERYONE. AND FIGURE OUT
HOUSING A DIFFERENT SETTING SO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS I THINK ARE
SENT BUT BY TOTALLY TO SAN
MITCHELL LETTERS ALONE NOW
ENOUGH HOPEFULLY AND I DON'T
HOPEFULLY I I'M BROKEN HER
ABOUT ALL OF IT. AND I. FOR THE
IS ICE IN MY STE. THAT STATE.
THEY MUST BE. IN PLEASE BEING
CURSED IN INDIVIDUALS IN THE
CARS IN THE ALL OF US FOR SOME
SIDE ABOUT THE PANDA. ARRAY
LIMITATIONS ON ALL OF US IN A
MAY THOSE TYPES SETTINGS AND
THE ONLY OTHER I GUESS ALL ASK
THE QUESTION INSTEAD OF JUST IT.
BUT IF THREE. IF EITHER IF ANY
OF THE PAIN. ONE TWO. WANT TO
BE TESTED SO WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW IS IF YOU ARE TESTED SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN QUENTIN THEN
YOU ARE POSITIVE THEN WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN A I'VE HEARD SOME.
ARTS OF WHAT WHAT CIRCUMSTANCE
YOU'RE PUT IN THE NET THAT MAY
BE CONTRIBUTING TO PEOPLE
CHOOSING NOT TO BE TESTED BUT I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF THERE WAS
ANY OF THE PEOPLE. IN THE LAST
PANEL WHO COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR. SO THERE COULD BE
EITHER MISTER LEWIS MISTER
KING. FOR MISTER STALEY. OR
DOCTOR SEARS. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR SO I KNOW AND REALLY
INSTITUTIONS TESTED POSITIVE
WHAT HI I RECEIVED PHONE CALLS
WITH THAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS
IF YOU TESTED POSITIVE BE
QUARANTINED IN YOUR SO. IF YOU
ARE THEY WOULD PUT ON HAPPEN AT
SOME STRESS. AND THEN YOU'D BE
QUARANTINE JUNIOR YOURSELF
KESSLER WE WANT TO YOUR SALE
AND THEN WHEN THE RESULTS CAME.
IF THEY REMAIN POTS YOU WERE
FORM TEAM FORTY DAYS IF YOU IF
YOU DID NOT JUST DâN POINTING
SO I WILL TAKING I ALSO WANTED
TO SHOW. SOMETHING ELSE WITH
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE THERE ARE.
THINGS WE'VE GOT TO GOVERNOR
HOW ABOUT THE POWER OF
COMPUTATION THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN GIVEN- LIKE HIGH STANDARDS
FROM THE WHARTON EVERYBODY DOWN
AT THE SYSTEMS WHICH IS S. MOST
A LARGE NUMBER. FIFTY THE
INSTITUTIONS THESE PEOPLE ARE
GOOD TO GO THERE NOT PUBLIC
SAFETY ONLY THING A SUPPLEMENT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS IN THESE
DIFFERENT COMPANIES THAT WON'T
PUT UP A FIGHT ONE PERSON
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE IN PRISON ONE.
OKAY I'M- EIGHT. I DO
UNDERSTAND FROM FAMILIES
SERVING CORSET INDIVIDUALS THAT
MANY. OF THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- HAVE SEEN THAT
THOSE PEOPLE SOME PEOPLE BEING
TESTED POSITIVE FOR PUTTING
POLITICS AND SUCH AND HAVE A
LOT OF FEAR ABOUT THAT SO IT
COULD ALL THE THINGS YOU
DESCRIBED A MATCH MORE COULD BE
CONTRIBUTING TO PAY. FOLKS TO
BE TESTED I'VE FOR. MR SO ARE
NERVE CC WAY I'M YOU DESCRIBE
HAVING TO BUY. THE QUICKNESS
BUT BASS. DOES THE DOES FUEL
THAT THE STAFF BE GIVEN PROP.
CHECK PP PROPER QUIT PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. THANK YOU WELL
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION IN THE
BEGINNING I WAS COATED WE HAD.
GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT THE PP YOU
GET PASSED ON TO THEIR
MEMBERSHIP AND- WE IMMEDIATELY
TAKE THIS SO WE NEED TO PROTECT
AND DEFEND OUR FAMILIES SO AT
THAT TIME WE PURCHASED THE- IN
NINETY FIVE MASS THEN WE WENT
OUT. AND PURCHASED- THE- CALLED
MASS FOR MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEN WE BOB THE-
NEIL TRAIN IN OUR FIVE RE
USABLE- OUTSIDE OUT WE JUST
FELT AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT AS
A FAMILY- OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ESERVER EVERYTHING AND-
WE FELT LIKE WE- GET IT OUT
QUICK. PAYING ATTENTION. TO
LOWER EVERY DAY CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'M I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
WILL APPRECIATE KNOWING IF AT
ANY POINT THERE IS THE SENSE
THAT THERE'S NOT BEING ADEQUATE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. REPEATED
BECAUSE CLEARLY CHECK THE
REQUIREMENT IS NOT ONLY
ESSENTIAL FOR THE STAFF BUT
ESSENTIAL FOR THE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS- SO THAT EVERYONE
IS SO WE CAN AGAIN CONTAIN THIS
DISK SO APPRECIATE IF YOU'RE
FILL US IN. I HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR SEARS AND
THEN I WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE
PUBLIC. DOT HE HAD A MENSCH TO
US RIGHT NOW IN THIS HEARING
THE SPECIFICS THAT YOU FEEL
SHOULD BE FOLLOWED I KNOW YOU
ALSO OUTLINED THEM IN THE
LETTER THAT YOU GAVE TO MR CALL
SOMEONE TO. DEPART YOU BET HAVE
YOU OR ANYONE ELSE FROM AMEND
BEEN INVITED TO BE PART OF THIS
INCIDENT COMMAND. OR IN ANY WAY
IT FIVE THREE TWO- IT IT'S NOT
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AT A AT LEAST
A POINT. MADAM CHAIR. OF WE
HAVE WE HAVE NOT BEEN
SPECIFICALLY INVITED TO THE
INCIDENT COMMAND A CENTER BUT
YOU HAVE BEEN IN FREQUENT
CONTACT WITH THE RECEIVERS
OFFICE ABOUT. THANKS FOR C. C.
H. YEAH THE HEALTHCARE SO CDC
ARE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO PER THAT
SUPPORT AND HAPPY TO PLAY ANY
ROLE NOW TO HELP WITH THE
CENTRALIZED LEADERSHIP RESPONSE.
SO IT'S QUITE NICE WALKING.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THAT
INFORMATION- WILL TRY TO- WITH
NO THAT THAT- THAT WHAT EVER
PLAN HAS GOT TO BE DIRECT LED
BY. COMPETENT MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SO THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING. TO AS I.
GET DEVELOPED NOW I'D LIKE TO
MOVE TO- PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL JUST WITH. SET UP CERTAIN.
AND WE KNEW WE AT THIS HARD TO
STOP SO WE DIDN'T WE WEREN'T
NECESSARILY ABLE TO INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE REPS FROM ALL THIS.
ORGANISED SINCE OUR CDC ARE OR
SOME OTHER CORPS I KEY FOLKS SO
WHAT I'VE DONE IS ALLOWED A FEW
PEOPLE INCLUDING. FRANKLIN FROM
SEIU DOCTOR NERVE THREE MAN WHO
IS- WITH ASKED ME LOCAL TWO OH
SIX THE STATIONS THAT OF A PER.
CARE AT THREE SIX YARD A COUPLE
OF OTHERS TO SPEAK FOR NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES EACH ON THE
LINE AND WE WILL MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC LINE. SO LET'S START
WITH. IN A DO YOU. MODERATOR.
THREE YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
BROWN'S. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT MY NAME IS KAREN WHEN
AND I WORK AT SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO MAKE. THE CARE. WELL PROP
LOCAL ONE DOLLAR I WOULD LIKE
TO BRIEFLY COMMENT ON WHAT DID
YOU LIKE WORKING AT BANK ONE
DURING THE COMBAT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND OTHER STATE
PRESIDENT AND I HAVE BEEN IN
CONSTANT COMMUNITY. WHAT YOU'RE
CROP HEY. THANK AS WELL AS
OTHER PERSON- HAS BEEN WIDELY
VERY GIVES LAW YEAH. THIS
CRISIS OUR REQUEST PP EACH
MANAGEMENT HAVE ONLINE YEARS
WE'VE BEEN FORCED TO RE USE
GALLONS BALLOT ALTHOUGH IN OVER
INTO THEY HAVE BECOME COUNTERED
UNABLE TO FIND A NEW ONE IN
THEIR INSTITUTIONS. THE
DEVASTATING AS WE ARE FRONTLINE
CAMP ON WHAT ARE CALLED THE
PLEDGE PATIENTS. I CAN SAY THAT
WITHIN THE PAST WEEK ACCESS TO
PROPER PPL THINK WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH. I'M VERY MUCH DUE
TO A COLLABORATION OF MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN WHICH WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR. OUR
STAFF ARE BEING PUT INTO A
SERIOUSLY DANGEROUS PRACTICE AT
BEING MANDATED DROPPED IT TO
WORK A OF SHIPS. AFTER DANGER
WE ARE PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY EXHAUSTED WE SLEEP
IN OUR CARS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE NOT IN THE
CONDITION TO SAFELY DRIVE CALL.
WE ARE OF OUR DOT. ON TO SPEAK
WITH WORKING OTHERS WE ARE
TRACKING AT THE ACTION. WE NEED
HELP NOW PLEASE. EVERY DAY I'D
BE MORE MORE OF OURS CAN'T BE
POSSIBLE BECAUSE NINETY EVEN
THOUGH WE- TRY OUR DOUBTS TOO
OUR- THE BILL NOT DELAY THE DIP
HAS DONE WHAT IS NEEDED TO FOR.
US. YEAH CAN. TO MOVE IN LATE
AROUND THAT'S RECENTLY AS- TO
SPEAKER FROM BANQUET. EXPOSING
OUT. AND OTHER IN MAY PATIENTS
ON THAT JEREMY THIS NEEDS TO
STOP IT SHOULD BE SHE- AND- IN
WE CAN. THE OUTBREAK. OBSOLETE
STOP POSTING ALL AND THAT THE.
BETTER I CAN ALL YOUR
DEDICATION BUT THE INDUCTION OF
SUPPORT IN THE FORM OF OUTSIDE
RESOURCES IT'S CRAZY. NEEDED
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISS FRANKLIN NOW DOT
MAN. I'M BEING TOLD THAT A
DOCTOR BUT SHE IS- SPEAKING IN
PLACE OF DOCTOR. A LINE IS ON
MUTED OKAY GO AHEAD OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
SKINNER DR- NATURAL FOR- AND
THE REST OF THE TOWN FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK UP DOCTOR
STUART BUT- THE FAMILY DITION
IN A THREE. HUNDRED OWNER OF
THE YEAR AMERICA POSITION TO
DENNIS WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN- DOCTORS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS. HUNDRED
DENNIS. OF COURSE POINT IN THE
TRAGIC HAPPEN THERE. IS REALLY
AS THE PANEL AT. REALLY A
QUESTION OF FAILURE TO
COMMUNICATE AS THEY SAID. AND
ALSO- MINIMIZING THE MEDICAL
VOICE WHICH- DOCTOR SEARS
ALLUDED TO A FEW MINUTES AGO.
THIS IS A PANDEMIC AND WE'VE
SEEN IN THE REST OF THIS
COUNTRY. WHEN THE NURSING HOMES
A SPREAD OUT THAT IT WASN'T-
THE BILL TO THE POLITICAL
MINDED APPEAR CRADDICK MINDSETS
EXIT. IT WAS A MEDICAL- JUST
MAKING THE EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
SEPARATED PEOPLE AND HAD LESS
CONTACT SOCIAL DISTANCING NOT
MORE. SO I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
UP WITH DR SEARS AND THEIR PATH.
BEING AN INTEGRAL. OF FIXING
PROBLEM FARM OUR MEMBERS ARE ON
THE GROUND. LIKE THE SEA HE PRO
CCPOA IN THE NC ARE YOU MA'AM.
AND WE ALL NEED PRECIPITATE. WE
ALL NEED. DARK HERE AND BE
LISTEN TO ACTIVELY. NOT WELL
WRITTEN UP AS MEMBERS IN MARCH
WERE FOR- COMPLAINING ABOUT PP
OR IN CHINO CA I AM. WHEN WE
NOTICED THERE WERE TOO MANY
AROUND THING ON. BUT ALSO TO
MAKE COMMENTS ON THE ENTIRE-
PANORAMA OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE. IT HAS COME TO MY
ATTENTION THAT THE FIVE. IN
TRANSFERRED ORIGINALLY IN MAY.
THE REASON THIS WAS WAS TO-
IMPROVE THE ACCESS FOR THE MATH
PROGRAM THE I. S. U. G. KEEP
PROGRAM. WHICH WAS A UP FULLER
PREVENTIVE PROGRAMS- THE COST
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO THE TAX HERE. AND IS AN
UNPROVEN. IS ROLLED OUT THE USE
OF SUBOXONE. NO WE- WE KNOW
THAT THE REASON FOR THE
TRANSFER WAS WAS. IN A WILL
PART DUE TO THE RECEPTION SAID
TAKE CARE THESE. TAKE HERE. A
FOR YOUR- TO THE MAIN LINE SO I
CAN QUITE. BIT CARSON
UNEXPECTED PROBLEM. WHEN THE
TRIP AND OCCURRED WHICH PEOPLE
WHO WEREN'T TESTED RIGHT
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE THE TRANSFER
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT. SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE. WAITED
TO CDC OURS RUN- WE WANT
MEDICAL INPUT- WE WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO HAVE HAD THE DECISION-
WHAT THE ISSUE IS IN A MAD
PROGRAM THE ADDICTION PROGRAM
WHY WHY THE TRANSFER START IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND ALEX ALEX
WHAT'S BUT MY MESSAGE HERE BUT
WE NEED INPUT NOT ONLY ON WHEN
THE EMERGENCIES IN THE WILD
FIRES OCCUR. BUT WHAT CARD THE
WILD FIRES. AND WE DON'T HAVE
BEEN PUT ON TO AN UNPROVEN
PROGRAM LIKE THE M. EIGHTY
PROGRAM. THE UNEXPECTED
CONSEQUENCES BAKER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU DOCTOR
RUSSELL THANK YOU. NOW WE MOVE
ON TO- STEVE FAMA FROM THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE. STEVE FARMER
FROM THE PRISON LAW OFFICE
CORRECT. NO CREDIT FOR
NUTRITIONAL JUSTICE. BUSINESS
THE SAME MONTH YES. THIS GUY
HERE IF YOU LIKE ME TO SPEAK A
LAWYER TO DO SO YES I WOULD.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON IN THE PRISON
LAW OFFICE IS A PRIVATE NOT FOR
PROFIT GROUP OF ATTORNEYS AND
OTHERS TO TRY TO HELP PEOPLE
INSIDE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM WELL INSIDE. I'VE BEEN
THERE ALMOST THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
IN LATE MARCH WHEN THERE WAS
LITERALLY LESS THAN OR ONLY TWO
OR THREE CASES. THIS STATE
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR WILL
PRESENTED A SWORN DECLARATION
FROM. NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
PRISON PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
SAID THAT A MEDIA POPULATION
REDUCTION WAS NECESSARY TO SAVE
LIVES GIVEN THE CODE BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE STATE
INCLUDING THE OWNER SAID NO.
AND IN PART THEY SAID IT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE PLANNING TO DO
EARLY RELEASES OURSELVES BUT
BUILT EARLY RELEASES. EVERY TO
ONLY A HUNDRED PEOPLE PER
PRISON. IN INSTITUTIONS THAT
AVERAGE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE EACH IN OTHER
WORDS IT WAS ALMOST NOT
NOTICEABLE AND THEN THOSE
RELEASES STOCK. THANKS ASHLEY
THOUSANDS OF BEEN INFECTED
SCORES HOSPITALIZED MANY OF
WHOM BY THE WAY EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE LISTED IS RECOVERED.
ARTIST ONE AND MOST TRAGICALLY
OF ALL TWENTY TWO. PEOPLE ARE
NOW DEAD. ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO
THE EXPERTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO
SAID THAT SAME QUESTION NEEDED
TO IMMEDIATELY HAVE IT'S
POPULATIONS REDUCE. THAT AGAIN
DID NOT HAPPEN AND WE SEE NOW
WHAT IS. THAT PERSON WITH MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND TRACK DIDN'T
AS I CHECKED THIS MORNING MORE
THAN THIRTY HOSPITAL ARTS.
BLOOM PRAY AND HOPE WE'LL ALL
RECOVER. WE HAVE AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BY- TESTIMONY EARLIER
OTHER PRISONS WHERE THERE ARE
GREAT NUMBERS OF PEOPLE. WHO
ARE IN DANGER OF COKE AT
NINETEEN. STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL FACILITY IN
BACK OF BILL THAT THE- MEGA
MEDICAL FACILITY IN STOCK THEN
AND THERE ARE OTHER PRISONS
LIKE SAND CLINTON WITH THE OLD
STYLE FIVE HERE CELL BLOCKS.
SUCH IS FULL SOME WITH SOLID
DOOR WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE VULNERABLE. THERE IS STILL
TIME IN THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE
ACTION. TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION PARTICULARLY THE
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE. I WOULD
LIKE TO END WITH WHAT I ADMIT
IS A RHETORICAL QUESTION. OUR
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS
BEEN. UP FOR SCHOOL LEADERS IN
THE STATE DURING THE PANDEMIC
WITH THE DAILY BRIEFING. AND
THE BOLD ACTION TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN GENERAL. WHERE HAS
THE GOVERNOR BEEN FOR THE
PEOPLE IN PRISON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER PALMER WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO BRANDON WOODS NEXT TO
THEM STEVEN MUNK CULT AND AFTER
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE IN THIS
ROOM. SO A PLEASE THE REMAINING
FOLKS SAID IN- THOSE YOU IN THE
ROOM WE'RE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT AIMED AT. I'LL PAY
FOR. PEOPLE LEFT TO SPEAK IN
THE PHONE PLEASE BUT IT'S SO WE
CAN PROVIDE OKAY. RENDON WORDS.
RENDON WHAT DOES NOT CURRENTLY
ON THE AUDIO BUT STEVEN AMONG
CALL TODAY OKAY NO WE'LL GO TO
STERN MUNCUL. ADAM CHAIR- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK TO YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ON WHAT IS REALLY A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH FOR SO
MANY IN OUR STATE. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIPH.
ISSUE JAY AND CCJ HAS PREPARED
A LIST OF REQUESTED ACTIONS A
PROPOSAL WHICH HAS BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE STRONG COMMENTS. THE
APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS RAISED BY
THE COMMITTEE TODAY TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PANELS AND KNOW
THAT IT REFLECTS A DEEP SEATED
COMMITMENT TO TAKE STRONG AND
IMMEDIATE ACTION NOT JUST TO
SAN QUENTIN BUT AT ALL STATE
FACILITIES. OUR CLIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE EXPRESSED
SIGNIFICANT AND JUSTIFIABLE
CONCERN THAT IN ADDITION STEPS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO PREVENT
SPREAD. COVERT CAR BUT HE'S
CALIFORNIA. DESPITE REPEATED
CALLS TO ACTION SOME OF THOSE
REFERENCE IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. EIGHT AND- SLIGHTLY-
ALTERED FORMER SLIGHTLY REDUCED
FORM I'M GOING TO TRY TO
EMPHASIZE THE POINTS- THE
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE MADE IN
THAT DOCUMENT TO COMPLETE MY-
ORAL COMMENTS TODAY. THE
NUMERICAL ORDER OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE OR SUGGESTIONS
DOES NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE RELATIVE IMPORTANCE.
NUMBER ONE ESTABLISH NEW AND
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT OF CDC
OUR FACILITIES AND LOCAL JAILS
WHERE WE ALL HAVE. CULTURAL
POPULATIONS AT RISK IN THIS
DISEASE TO ENSURE PROMPT
COMPLIANCE WITH ANY. AFTER
COMPLAINTS ABOUT PRISON IN JAIL
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONDITIONS
AND TO TAKE ALL NECESSARY STEPS
TO PREVENT FURTHER SPREAD. THIS
WILL HELP IDENTIFY. IDENTIFY
HAVE REPORTED NUMBERS ARE
ACCURATE AND ESTABLISH
IMMEDIATE AND NECESSARY- STEPS
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THOSE STILL OPEN
THOSE FACILITIES NUMBER TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN TESTING TO
ANYONE REALLY. CITY SURFACED.
FOR THE DURATION OF THE
EMERGENCY. NUMBER THREE. THE
POPULATION ACTUALLY ACTUAL
RATED TO. THIS CAN BE DONE BY
ESTABLISHING PROTOCOLS FOR
THOSE WITH LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS LEFT TO SERVE. AND
EXPLORING TRANSITIONAL
ALTERNATIVES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
AND- NOT SERVING A SENTENCE FOR
A VIOLENT OFFENSE IF YOU COULD
REPORT. OKAY HOW OLD DIFFER IN
THAT CASE TO THE- WRITTEN
PROPOSAL SO WE'VE MADE- THANKS
FOR COMMITTEE FOR IT'S
IMPORTANT ATTENTION AND IN OVER
STATE IN THIS AREA. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO- PURSUE-
PROPOSALS TO. REDUCE THE
CULTURAL POPULATIONS AS THE
FIRST STEP TO SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
WELCOME. COMMITTEE IS IN RIGHT
BECAUSE OF COURSE THAT HELPS US
TO DO APPROPRIATE FOLLOW UP
SINCE WE A THERE ARE SOME OF US
ARE TAKING NOTES OBVIOUSLY BUT-
MEMORY. OPEN IS- A SAID WE
WELCOME. WE WELCOME SUGGESTIONS
AND WRITING. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE FOLKS WHO ARE HERE IN
THIS ROOM AND THEN WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO BE ALTERNATE ROUTE AND
THEN FOLLOWING THAT WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO MODERATOR
YOU COULD YOU UP THOSE IN THE
LINES. YEAH TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
WE HAVE A HEART STOP AT ONE
O'CLOCK. EVERYONE TO GO ONE OR
LESS SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
XIN IN WAITING AND GO AHEAD WE
CAN START WITH OUR FIRST PERSON
IS HERE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME'S BUT
NORMALS. AND I'M WITH THE GROUP
TRAINING INSTITUTE- FORM AND
CAR SERRATED. AND I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR A SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION THAT'S OFTEN. WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT RELEASING SAY
PEOPLE BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
THE LIFERS IN PRISON HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. MY PROGRAM IS OVER
THE AGE LAST EIGHT YEARS
GRADUATED EIGHT HUNDRED I MEAN
NINE HUNDRED THIRTEEN. HUMAN
BEINGS FROM OUR PROGRAM. THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE GONE BEFORE
THE BORDER PRISON HEARINGS IN
EIGHT YEARS ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAS RETURNED BACK
TO PRISON. FULL AND VIOLENT
OFFENSE. OKAY DOES LESS THAN A
THREE PERCENT RISK RECIDIVISM
RATE. WE FEEL THAT WE STOOD AT.
WHAT OUR EXPERIENCE AND OUR
WISDOM BE PART OF CDC OUR
STRATEGY NOT ONLY NOW BUT IN
THE FUTURE. WHEN IT COMES TO
RELEASING SAY PEOPLE SO. WE'RE
ASKING THAT SHOULD LOOK AT
LIFERS WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN PROGRAMMING. THEY ARE SAFE.
AND THEY NEED TO COME HOME AND
HOLDING THEM IN PRISON. WITH
THIS VIRUS GOING ALL IT'S JUST
AN DANGER IN THEIR LIVES I HAVE
A BROTHER THIS INCARCERATED I
HAVE FRIENDS FAMILY LEVEL AND
THAT ALL INCARCERATED AND IT'S
TIME FOR THESE PEOPLE TO COME
HOME THEY SERVE THEIR TIME
THEY'RE GOING TO WORK TO HOME.
AND WE DON'T COME BACK TO PRE
HAVE SERVED MY LAST FOURTEEN
YEARS AT SAN QUENTIN SO THIS
ISSUE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ANYONE DIE FROM THIS COVERT
NINETEEN VIRUS THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR STAYING
BEING WITH THIS. BANK YOU FOR
MORE PUBLIC. HELLO AND THANK
YOU. THIS IS AN UNPARALLELED
CRISIS IMMEDIATE DRASTIC ACTION
MUST BE TAKEN. THIS IS NOT A
TIME FOR ITIGATION. COVERT
NINETEEN IS EXPLOITING OUR
WEAKNESSES AS A SOCIETY OUR
SYSTEM OF INCARCERATION HAS A
HISTORY DRENCHED IN I'M JUST
POLICY AND INHUMANE STANDARDS.
THE PLAN CREATED TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OF THE NINETEEN BUT ALSO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE. HOW THE
GOVERNMENT REHABILITATES PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED.
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OVER THE WITHOUT
DISMANTLING THE PRISON SYSTEM
AS IT IS NOW WOULD BE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE. IN NINETEEN WILL BE
A DEADLY THREAT UNTIL WE HAVE A
VACCINE WHICH IS A YEAR OR MORE
AWAY FROM BEING WIDELY
AVAILABLE. YOU NEED TO
IMMEDIATELY AT LEAST AT LEAST
75% OF THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. ON JUNE FIFTEENTH
CHASE AN INMATE IN CALIFORNIA
WROTE THE FOLLOWING. WITH THREE
MONTHS TO GO ON MY SENTENCE THE
CORONA VIRUS HAS MADE IT IN
WITH FIFTEEN CONFIRMED CASES
AND MORE. WE ARE JUST SITTING
DUCKS IN HERE NOW. IN MEET MASS
RELEASE IS THE CAPITAL.
ANYTHING LESS AMOUNTS TO
AMERICA EXECUTION BY BIOLOGICAL
WEAPONS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TO PUBLIC SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ANYTHING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIGUEL GARCIA I'M A POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WE PROVIDE
A SERVICE INS INSIDE THE
INSTITUTION- I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND START OFF WITH- FIVE FROM
ALLEN WROTE A LITTLE SUNSET
FROM LANCASTER STATE PRISON. A
LAUNDRY. AND HE WANTED TO
RECOGNITION AND TAKE I OF THE
WORK OF HELPING OUT THE VETERAN
HOSPITAL OF THE DECONTAMINATING
SOME OF THE- BLANKETS AND OTHER
ON SHEETS THAT ARE POSSIBLY
CONTAMINATED WITH KOBE
NINETEEN. ALSO WOULD LIKE TO.
ECHO THE CONCERNS THAT MANY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE WITH
CORRECTION OFFICERS THIRTEEN
THEIR THEIR ROOMS AND NOT SURE
WHAT POLITICS MAY HAVE BEEN
STAGE DOOR. WHO WHO ARE BUT- IS
GOING TO LAW I'M GONNA BE GONE
IN PASSED TO THE. THE PHASES OF
BEFORE. CORRECTION ENTER THE
FACILITY. IT'S VERY SCARY FOR
THEM ONE INDIVIDUAL SAID THAT
HE HAD SYMPTOMS INCLUDING
COUGHING CHILLS FEVER AND
BREATHING PROBLEMS REPORTED ON
TO WORKING WITH THE FROM WITHIN
THE FIRST TEN MINUTES IS
BILLION WITH SO WHERE- WITH
FLAT K<c.cyan> NEVER BEEN SICK IN</c>
HIS WHOLE LIFE HE WAS
QUARANTINING GIVEN SOMETHING
LIKE TYLENOL A DAY OR SO AFTER
I WAS GIVEN HE WAS GIVEN. THE
OFTEN GOING TO DIE AGAIN I'VE
ON THE COMMITTEE AND THIS TING
GUESS FOR PROVIDING SERVICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
SPEAKER. HELLO I AM HERE AS A
FAMILY MEMBER DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY MASS INCARCERATION AND
EXTREME SENTENCING. THE LAST
TIME I HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT MY
FAMILY MEMBER INSIDE WAS ABOUT
A WEEK AGO I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE SAFE. IF THEY ARE WELL.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO LIVE. PRIOR
TO THAT I HAD HEARD ABOUT. ALL
OF THE INSUFFICIENT WAYS THAT
THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN DEALING
WITH THIS PANDEMIC. LACK OF
MASS FOR THE PRISONERS AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS NOT
WEARING THEM. LACK OF HAND
SANITIZER ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS
LIKE SO AND SHOWER. ANDERSON
HAVE A THEIR APPROACH TO WHAT
IS GOING TO BE AN EXTREME HUMAN
RIGHTS HEALTH CRISIS IF NOT
ACTED UPON NOW. I DEMAND WE
DEMAND. THE TRANSFER STOP EARLY
RELEASES ARE GRANTED. INMATES
HAVE BASIC ACCESS TO NEEDS AND
CARE AND OUTSIDE MEDICAL
ORGANIZATION EXPERTS ARE TAPPED
TO COME IN AND EIGHT WITH THE
OVERFLOW THAT IS EXISTING THIS
IS THAT- IMPACTING THE SYSTEM
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AND
MORE. THIS IS BETTER. THAN
POLITICS THIS IS REAL LIFE.
REAL FAMILIES AND I WANT TO
KNOW BUT EVERYTHING IS BEING
DONE I DO NOT GET A CALL THAT
MY FAMILY MEMBER HAS DIED.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
SIERRA AND I THINK YOU- FOR
GIVING ME THE TIME TO- SPEAK
TODAY AND ALSO FOCUSING ON THE
MUCH NEEDED ACTION THAT DOES
NEED TO BE TAKEN. ON THIS ISSUE.
THEY'VE TAKE IT ACTION ON
ASTRONOMICAL SPREAD OF COOL THE
NINETEEN WITHIN CDC ARE
SPECIFICALLY SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON. I ASKED ACTION IS
TAKING. TAKEN DOING DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND TO BE CLEAR
TAKING ACTION ON THE BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS OF THESE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND LIVING
CONDITIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IS QUITE CHAMBER. THE
EXPERTS OF PROFESSIONAL.
TELLING US THAT THE TO D. CARS
THREE. 52% MINIMUM TO STOP THIS
SYSTEM WIDE ISSUE WHY ARE WE
NOT MASS RELEASING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. OKAY SO
WE GO TO THE OTHER ROOM. SO FOR
EXHILARATING ROOM I THINK
THERE'S SIX OR SEVEN PEOPLE
THERE. CAN WE START NOW WITH
THE SPEAKERS IN THAT ROOM. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES WE CAN WE
CAN SENIOR YOU. MORNING THIS IS
BRENDAN WOULD VOTE FOR THE
ALBANY COUNTY I DROVE UP
INSTEAD OF BEING ON THE PHONE.
JUNE THIRD I SENT A LETTER TO
GOVERNOR SOME INSECT IDEAS
WHICH ONE A NICE THING TO THE
PEOPLE BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE
INCLUDING. I'M ONE OF THE
PERSON. AND SEND ONE. ON JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH THAT'S ANOTHER
FOCUSED ON RELEASES. GIVEN
THREE SOMEONE SUGGEST INSTABLE
ONE IMMEDIATELY RELEASED PEOPLE
ONE YEAR LEFT TO START. WE KNOW
THAT COULD BE. UP TO ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE TO BE
RELEASED NUMBER TO BELIEVE THE
ELDERLY AND THE BOTTLE
POPULATION. WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE OVER A DISTRICT FIVE IN
OUR PRISON CALIFORNIA. THREE
EARLY THESE WERE PEOPLE WOULD
DO WE IS LEFT TO SIR. WE KNOW
IN OUR PRISONS THAT OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT CONSIDER
TO BE LOW RISK LOW RISK THEY'RE
READY TO RETURN BACK TO SOCIETY
WE CANNOT PUT MY LITTLE. PONY
BUT DOES WORK TO RETURN. AND WE
SAY RELEASE WOULD BE RELEASED
NOT INTO ICE CUSTODY. NOT INTO
ANOTHER PLACE WHERE PEOPLE WE
HELD AN UNSAFE AND MARK. IS IT
A MINIMUM IS THE FLOOR BASIC
REQUEST THEY WERE ASKING FOR.
ELLA BAKER CENTER RESTORED. ON
LAW HAVE A FULL SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS CITIES ARE
SHOULD BE ADOPTING NOW. BUT
AFTERNOON ONCE WE SAW THE
SITUATION THANK WHAT WAS
GETTING OUT OF CONTROL SORT OF
PETITIONS. ON FRIDAY AFTERNOON
PUT YESTERDAY EVENING. WE WERE
ABLE TO SIGN UP OVER TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE DEMANDING
GOVERNOR INSPECTOR TAKE ACTION
NOW. AND WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION.
I HAVE SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
PRISON. I'VE BEEN SAN QUITE
EARLY I KNOW IT IS MEANT THERE
MY FRIENDS THEY'RE MENTORS.
TYING THEIR COMPASSION DENTAL
TO HUMAN BEINGS. AND SO WE ARE
HERE TODAY. ASKING YOU TO SEE
THEM. SEE THEM NOT JUST THE
INMATES WERE PRISONERS BUT SEE
THOSE PEOPLE. AND TREAT THEM
THE SAME WAY YOU WANT TO BE
TREATED I WANT TO BE TREATED.
WE SPENT SO MUCH TIME. AND
MONEY AND FOCUS ON PEOPLE. OUT
OF CUSTODY PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY I'M BEGGING YOU BACK
IN THE GOVERNOR BIGGEST THIRD
TO NOW. PICK THAT ENERGY TIME
AND FOCUS IT'S LONG PAST DUE
BUT THE FOCUS ON THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN CUSTODY. PLEASE TAKE
ACTION NOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER WOULD THEN I GAVE HIM
TWO MINUTES AS HE WAS SUPPOSED
BE A LAW. SO I DIDN'T. THINK
THAT WE ARE BEING. UNFAIR TO OF
THOSE OF YOU'VE BEEN WAITING I
JUST WANTED TO- POINT OUT THAT
I WAS GOING TO MENTION EARLIER
BUT THE LA- ARE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS A REPORT
AND THEY THEMSELVES HAVE GIVEN-
STATED THAT THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL TO HAVE LESS THAN
ONE YEAR LEFT TO SIR. NOW CAN
WE HAVE OUR NEXT SPEAKER AND
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO HOLD TWO
MINUTE TIME LIMIT. HI THERE.
ADRIN I'M HERE FATHER AND IN
HIS. THERE'S NO THAT THE RECENT
TRANSFER WAS A MISERABLE
FAILURE AND IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
CDC ARE HAS NOT BEEN DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
REJECT THESE PEOPLE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
TRYING BUT IF THEY CANNOT
SUCCEED THAN THEY MIGHT RELEASE
THEIR PRISONERS MY DAD IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT PERSON. IN MY
LIFE. SIXTY THREE YEARS OLD. IN
REMISSION ANSWER. OTHER
UNDERLYING HEALTH ISSUES AND
HE'S A VERY HIGH RISK FOR
GETTING SICK. IN DEVELOPING
LIFE THREATENING SYMPTOMS.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE
OF IN NINETEEN IS A DEATH
SENTENCE FOR PEOPLE LIKE MY DAD
AND OTHER AT RISK IN MEANS. NO
ONE WILL RESPOND TO MY CALLS OR
EMAILS REGARDING ITS WELL BEING
RIGHT NOW NOT. ON MULTIPLE
TIMES BY THE WARDEN'S OFFICE
ASSISTANT HE SIMPLY HAS NO
INFORMATION TO GIVE TO ME IT'S
TERRIBLE AT JUSTIN. WHEN
GOVERNOR NEWS ON YOU POWER AND
ORDER MASTER SINCE IMMEDIATELY
AND GUARANTEES CONDITIONS FROM
INMATES ACROSS EIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO A
WITNESS YEAH. OKAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FORGET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. MY NAME'S
LAYS THERE RODRIGUEZ AND I'M A
CONCERNED PRESIDENT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE.
FAMILY IN THE CDC. AS WELL AS I
CURRENTLY HAVE A- EMILY
RELATIVE IN SAN WEDNESDAY PRISM.
I BELIEVE THAT. KEEPING ELDERLY
INMATES INSIDE THE PRISONS AT
THE TIME OF THIS PANDEMIC IS A
DEATH SENTENCE AND I BELIEVE
THEY NEED TO BE RELEASED
IMMEDIATELY FOR THEIR SAFETY
AND FOR OUR CONSCIENCE. I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE- OPERATIONS OF
THE PRISONS NEED TO BE
DRASTICALLY REDUCED REALLY
ALONG WITH THE REQUESTED
MULTIPLE SPEAKERS TODAY. AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY MORE
TIME TO TAKE ON THESE ISSUES I
THINK THE EVERY SINGLE DAY WE
TAKE FROM THE FORWARD. FOUR
HOURS TO LOG. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT THE WITNESS. THE FIRST
RATHER PUBLIC HI I'M READING A
PREPARED STATEMENT BY WILLIAMS
MY NAME IS LARRY WILLIAMS MY IN
MADE NUMBER IS THE SIX ONE TWO
ZERO FIVE. SO SAN QUENTINSTATE
PRISON. I TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COPD ON JUNE ELEVEN I WAS
PLACED IN ISOLATION ONLY FOUR
DAYS LATER ON JUNE FIFTEENTH
WHEN I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED ON JUNE SEVENTH
WHEN I TESTED POSITIVE. I
BELIEVE IT WILL BE BECAUSE I IN
WORKOUTS ALSO IN THE ALPINE
RESTRICTION YOU NEVER WORKING
AS A PORTER IN THE PRISON ON
JUNE ME FIVE MINUTES WERE%
INSTRUCTED BY FOR. GUARD
OFFICER TWO HUNDRED BOXES. HERE
OUTSIDE OF THE WING AND THE
WHOLE OF SOUTH BLOCK WE REALIZE
THAT WE WERE THE OF PRISONERS
WHO WERE TRAPPED FROM CHINO WE
ASKED ABOUT IT OFFICER HALEY'S
I'M NOT TOUCHING MOVING THAT
PROPER IF YOU DON'T MOVE IT.
PROPERTY FOR FREE JOBS THAT
NINE I STARTED GETTING SLOTS
AND I LOST MY THEY CALL ME
TESTS NEXT MORE AND I TO. IN
HIS STATEMENT SECRETARY. HE WAS
BEING DONE ON ALL INCLUDING
TEMP TEST LARRY TOLD US THEY
DON'T GIVE US ADEQUATE SUPPLIES
AND MATERIALS THEY DON'T EVEN
TAKE BLOOD PRESSURE ANYMORE.
PAN DOWN. OPENING THE DOOR THEY
MAKE US PUT OUR FACE TO THE
TRAY SLOT WHERE THE FOOD COMES
THROUGH YOU CAN READ THE
TEMPERATURE CHECK THEY DON'T
EVEN WHAT ARE SYMPTOMS ARE
DON'T HAVE CLEAN A SHOWER US
EVERY. THE PHONE A LOT. THEY'RE
MORE MAD THEY LOST STUFF THE
NAY THAT THEY'VE IN FACT ALL OF
US AGAIN MY NAME IS LARRY
WILLIAMS I'M OUT OF SAN QUENTIN
I AM NOT I LIVE. THE THEY
SHOULD START RELEASING PEOPLE
LIKE THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
I'LL BE READING A STATEMENT
FROM A PRISONER AT SAN QUENTIN
HELLO MY NAME IS DEJA ENJOY THE
CDC ARE REFERS TO ME AS A AND
ONE ZERO ONE ONE. LEE I'M AT
SAN QUENTIN PRISON IN THE GYM
AREA. I COMMITTED ARMS AND WAS
SENTENCED TO EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
EIGHT MONTHS I'VE BEEN IN THE
GYM SINCE APRIL FIFTEENTH. ONE
ONE HUNDRED AND IGHT OF US
HAVE BEEN CAPTIVE IN THE GYM WE
WERE FORCED INTO EIGHT PODS.
CDC ARE SAYS THAT BEING THREE
FEET APART IS OKAY BECAUSE THE
DISTANCE IS SIX FEET APART
DIAGONALLY IF WE SLEEP HEAD TO
TOE TO MATCH THAT. THAT LOGIC
DID NOT WORK. ON JUNE TWENTY
NINTH TWO INDIVIDUALS IN THE
GYM TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVE
IT. AND THREE INDIVIDUALS WERE
REMOVED FOR EXPERIENCING
SYMPTOMS. I TRY MY BEST TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE BUT IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE IN THE PRISON
SETTING THERE ARE ONLY FOUR
TOILETS FOR ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN INDIVIDUALS ONE URINAL
FOR ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS TWO SINKS FOR ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN INDIVIDUALS. I
SEE A LOT IN A SURROUNDED BY
PEOPLE TRYING TO USE THE
RESTROOM WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
USE PARTITION TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS BUT THEY'VE
NOT BEEN PROVIDED. ALL IS NOT
ON TO TRANSFER TO NORTH.
SATURDAY TWENTY SEVEN I WATCHED
THE ASSOCIATE WARDEN TRY TO
SEND INFECTED INDIVIDUALS TO
NORTH KOREAN PRISON TELLING
EVERYONE WHO IS BEING
TRANSFERRED HAS TESTED NEGATIVE
WHICH WASN'T TRUE THANK YOU.
APOLOGIES WE DO HAVE A LOT TO
PEOPLE ON THE PONE LINE SO IF
YOU COULD STICK TO ONE MINUTE
THANK YOU GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS RICHARD PAN AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION THAT ORGANIZED TO
PREVIOUS. CALL CARAVAN
DEMONSTRATIONS TWO YEARS TIME
CONTENT. MISTER KING DON'T TO
SEE IS AND SOME OF THE
PRISONERS WHO ARE SPOKEN BEFORE
ME HAVE EXPLAINED THE MASS
RELEASES ARE THE ONLY REAL
SOLUTION TO THIS CRISIS. TO
SALUTE THE SPEAKERS ON THE
FIRST PANEL INCLUDING SECRETARY%
GEASS. I'M WILLING OR ABLE TO
CONSIDER. HOWEVER GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAS THE POWER TO
RESOLVE THIS CRISIS
IMMEDIATELY. UNDER HIS
EMERGENCY POWERS DURING THE
CORONAVIRUS STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT HAS THE POWER TO REWRITE CDC
OF REGULATIONS AS WELL AS
COMMON DEAR PRIVATE PROPERTY
INCLUDING HOTELS A MEDICAL
FACILITY. TO BE HOUSE PRISONERS
THE EXPLOSIVE VOTE THESE POWERS
BACK IN MARCH BUT IN THREE
MONTHS HE HAS FAILED TO INVOKE
THEM ON BEHALF OF PRISONERS IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. WE DID
MANAGE THE GOVERNOR KNEW SOME
ORDER MASS RELEASES NOW AND
THAT THIS COMMITTEE TAKE A
PUBLIC STANCE CALLING ON THE
GOT TO DO. BUT THERE IS. OKAY I
SEE AN- GO AHEAD. YEAH YES MY
NAME IS A CITY WHERE AND THE-
HISTORY IMPORTED CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE DEBATE CHAIR. AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN SAID IF THE
NEED FOR PRISON REFORM HAS BEEN
KNOWN FOR YEARS AS FAST CENTER
AND FORTUNATE TOOK A- BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO EXPOSE
THESE PROBLEMS. PRISONS ARE
OVERCROWDED. SOCIAL DISTANCING
IS IMPOSSIBLE PLEASE RELATED TO
REDUCE THE PRISON POPULATION
OVER A LEVIN HUNDRED CASES ARE
IN STAND ALONE CAPTION OF ALL
PRISONERS AND STAFF. SHOULD BE
REQUIRED ADDITIONAL EARLY
REDUCES THOSE OVER SIXTY FIVE
RELEASES WELL RISK RELEASES
GOVERNOR HAS THE EMERGENCY
POWERS TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION ARE RELEASING
SELECTED POPULATIONS. AND THEN
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD FOLLOW
UP VERSUS FEDERAL PRISON REFORM
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANOTHER PERSON IN THE ROOM.
ALRIGHT THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND- IT'S TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT I WILL I WILL STILL
LEAVE ONE MINUTE BUT FOR THOSE
OF YOU ON THE PHONE IF YOU DO
LESS TIME THAN MORE PEOPLE THE
PHONE SPEAK GO AHEAD. LATER THE
PHONE LINES WE HAVE HERE. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES WHICH CHAPTER
COMMENTER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO A FEW
THAT HAVE ALREADY CUED UP.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER.
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE TWO
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO MY. PROCEED
WE CAN HEAR YOU. SEN NOW WE
CAN'T. ZERO KNOWLEDGE ITEM
EXPERIENCING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND HAVE ONE OF MY
PEERS TAKE OVER ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MY APOLOGIES TO THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN WAITING
AND ARE ON THE PHONE RIGHT. GO
AHEAD THANK YOU THIS IS A THIS
IS TOM I'LL TAKE OVER FROM
HERE- WE WILL GO TO ONE ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME. AT FIFTY THREE CONTACT
CARD CONTINUE TO EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS I AM LISTED AS THE
NEXT OF KIN BUT THEY WILL ONLY
CONTACT ME IF HE DIED. LATER ON
THE NIGHT. SENATOR SKINNER. HE
NO ONE PERSON WORKERS ARE
WORKING JUST A LOT LOCKDOWN THE
GUARD OR RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL
THE CLEANING COOKING THE CARD
FOR ALL ONLY WEARING MASKS WHEN
HIGHER RATING OFFICIALS WERE
PRESIDENT THEY WERE NOT READING
THE UNIT OR SHOWERS AFTER USED
AN OLD GOOD WITH THE FLOOR MY
HUSBAND AFTER HE WAS ALMOST
PAPER AND HAD NO SO AND WHAT
SHOULD HE DO. THE CARD AND TOLD
HIM TO USE IT HE HE WILL BE
RETIRING AGAINST BY THE GUARDS
YOU CAN BE GOING. PUBLIC WITH
THIS INFORMATION. FROM THE
KITCHEN TO THE HOUSING UNIT.
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FROM AROUND THE
STATE SPENDING IS PROGRAMMING
CREDIT THAT I HOPE TO RECEIVE
DURING THE TIME HE SPENT ALL
THIS TIME PRODUCTIVELY GETTING.
IT BUT DO YOU. DURING THE
CRISIS HE NOT TO RIDE WITHOUT
BREAK THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PHONE LINE. WE WILL GO AWAY TO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TWO SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
FAILURE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND ARE STILL RESPOND
NINETEEN DESPITE BURN ALARM
BELLS BEING FOUNDED BY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND THEIR
LOVED ONES BY PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT BY LETTING THEM HIT BY
THE BY OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND ON THE STATE THE
COUNTRY CALLING INCREASED. THE
RELEASE OF THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
SAVE LIVES AND AVOID THE FACTOR.
UPON WE'RE PRETTY ALARM BY THE
IN WHICH STATE. RE AN EXACT THE
SHAME INDUSTRY OF THIS THAT
NEXT. AND OF BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE FOR BOTH
DISPROPORTIONATELY VULNERABLE
TO COATED NINETEEN AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN SECRET AND- WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT DESPITE. IN
PANDEMIC NOW REACHING AN
IMMIGRANT CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
CDC ARE CONTINUES TO
VOLUNTARILY PIPELINE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS INTO DETENTION RATHER
THAN RETURNING THEM TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES TO
SAFELY SHELTER IN PLACE. CDC
ARE IDENTIFIED IN VERBAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
XCELERATED RELEASE THIS SPRING
SEVENTY EIGHT OF THOSE
COMMUNITY WERE TRANSFERRED THE
TENSION STREET FROM ONE COVERT
NINETEEN NOT THAT TO ANOTHER.
REPORT THAT NEARLY. A IN YOUR-
THE SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK.
NEXT LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE YOU
ARE NOW ALL BUT- ANNIKA RIGHT
ARM ALLOCATE POLICY DIRECTOR
AND SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND A PERSON
WITH A LOVE GOING CAR THREE GET
INSIDE CAN CLINTON- LAST YEAR
IS THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAD BEEN A LOT OF IMPORTANT
WORK ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. HOWEVER SO FAR THE
RESPONSE OF THE VIRUS IN THE
PRISON POPULATION HAS EXPOSED
MANY IN THE- LOOK. THIS REFORM
CORPORATION TO ACCORDING TO OLD
GUARD POLITICS INSTEAD OF THE
MOST AND HUMANE PUBLIC POLICY
WITH MORE THAN 50% OF PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMPANY BEING THE LOW RATE
OF RECIDIVISM BY THE OUR OWN
MEASURE IT'S CLEAR WE CAN
SAFELY AND DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
THE PRISON POPULATION. REALLY
THE PROFESSIONS TO THAT THE
MARGIN STATE AND RELEASE SHOULD
INCLUDE BYFORD AND NOT BE MADE
WITH CATEGORICAL EXCEPTION. I
THANK BRENT REAL ABOUT THIS
CRISIS IN THE CLEAR SOLUTION
AND- NOT BEING AFRAID OF THE
POLITICS OF THE PAST AND TO
ENSURE THAT OUR ACTIONS MATCH
OUR WORK. YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE TO
THIRTY SIX POINT TWO THIRTY SIX
YOU ARE NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
MAY. I RESPECTFULLY COMMENT
THAT'S A SANGUINE CO WORKER AND
I AM A CERTIFIED CORRECTIONAL
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL. I HAD
BEEN A VERY VOCAL ADVOCATE
THROUGH THE KOBE CRISIS THIS
ADVOCACY COMES FROM MY PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE INCLUDING MANY
FRIGHTENED MIDNIGHT CALLS TO MY
COWORKERS. AND MY INTERACTIONS
WITH ALL OF THE SAN QUENTIN
EXECUTIVES. I COME WITH A PRIOR
MILITARY BACKGROUND INCLUDING
DESPITE DISASTER RESPONSE. THE
ADDRESSING BIO OUTBREAK SIMILAR
TO CODE. NEGATIVE HAVE BEEN
NOTED I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
GOOD IF NOT FOR THE LEADERSHIP
ACTING WARDEN RON BROOMFIELD
ARE SAYING CLINTON WILD FIRE
WOULD BE AN ASH PILE WE ARE
LUCKY TO HAVE IT AND BY THE WAY
IS NOT MY CHAIN OF COMMAND. I
DIESEL WITH AUSTIN MINISTRY
THERE'S AN OUTSIDE HEALTHCARE
MIGHT LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY
RESPECTFULLY CONTRACTS FOR
TESTING IS NOT THE ISSUE THE
FIFTEEN MINUTE RESULTS LESSON
THE FDA APPROVED IS AVAILABLE
NOW USED ELSEWHERE BUT IT IS
ABOUT THE SAME IT IS EQUALLY
ACCURATE. WE COULD GET THE REAL
ISSUE OR POPULATION AND BETTER
COMPETE. WHY CAN'T PROVIDE
PRODUCT INTERPRETATION BE LONG.
I WANT THE- WHAT I'M GOING
COLLEAGUES NURSES CORRECT
OFFICER AND DOCTOR TO BE READ.
THIS WAS A FAILURE BUT OR ARE
CREATION WE HADN'T IT WAS ABOUT
THE SAME QUINN LEVEL ONLY
THROUGH MY CO WORKERS THE
LEADER WAS IN. THANK YOU AND
PLEASE SUBMIT THING YOU'D LIKE
IN WRITING IT DOES HELP US.
NEXT OF. PUBLIC SPEAKER. WELL
NOW THAT A LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO TO SIX TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. GREAT THANK
YOU MY NAME MUCH OF IT THOUGH
AND I LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY I
JUST WANT TO SAY- YEAH YOU'RE
PRETTY TRASHY FOR- RELYING ON
YOUR POLICY TO NOT TRY TO
CONTINUE TRANSFERRING AYE
DADDY. HI WERE ADAMANTLY AGAIN
THIS INFO IN CALIFORNIA SO YOU
NEED TO LIKE CHANGE OUR POLICY
ABOUT LIKE YOU TO TRY AND
COVERAGE. AND YOU NEED TO BRING
EVERYONE I NEED YOU TO CALL ON
GOVERNOR CLOSED DOWN IMMIGRANT
CREATING AN OUR STATE BECAUSE
OF IT PROPERLY BEING IN THOSE
AREAS SO YEAH YOU'RE. JUST
PRETTY TRASHY THANK YOU. THE OF.
BAKER THREE OKAY FROM ONE OF
TWO AND NINETY TWO NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHEN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRYING TO BE
CALIFORNIA KIND ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK ALI CAN ON BLACK
COMMUNITIES HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BEING IMPACTED BY THIS PANDEMIC
IN PRISON AND I CONVENTION
CENTERS PRECAUTIONS NECESSARY
TO CALL OVERALL PICK THAT I'LL
COME UP AND ADDING TO. HAVE
BEEN THROWN OUT YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY HOW PRISON BY DESIGN KEEP
PEOPLE IN CLOSE QUARTERS AND
EXPOSURE DIDN'T THINK POSSIBLE.
I DON'T HAVE. I CALLED THE
NINETY. THERE HAVE BEEN HELD TO
HIDE THE PROBLEM. OBJECTIVE AS
THAT THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
PUBLIC CHANGES COULD BE FIT
BEHIND THAN THE FIGURES IN WHAT
IF I. A THE BIG NAY. HE MIGHT
PICK AX BECAUSE OF PRO ACT
STEPS IN A PROTECT SECOND WE OF
KOBE THANK YOU BUILDING WE ARE.
OUR UP FOR. AND LIKE THE BANK
BE PEOPLE CAN BE. AND GREEN
ISSUE HELLO. ANY CURRENTLY THE
GOVERNOR TO ADOPT. ALLY WITH
THE LATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT. ON THE OTHER
LINE THREE HUNDRED THREE ZEROS
YOUR LONG IS OPEN. THREE THREE
ZERO ZERO DO YOU HAVE YOUR LINE
ON MUTE. THE MODERATOR PERHAPS
WE CAN GO BACK TO THAT PERSON
YOU CAN GO TO SOMEONE ELSE. ALL
RIGHT LITTLE LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THREE ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS EDGAR RAMIREZ WITH
LTT. AND CHRIS SHINN AND
IMIGRATION TO CAITLYN AS A
PUBLIC HEALTHCRISIS AND THE
PANDEMIC HAD MADE THAT MORE
URGENTLY AND A CUTE AND I TO
LEAD TO. THE NEVER HE'S
INSTITUTION SYSTEMATICALLY
DEPRIVED IMMIGRANT. ACTIVE
INDIVIDUALS OF LIBERTY AND HAVE
A LONG RECORD OF MEDICAL YOU
COLLECT WE CAN FOR THE F. JUST
THE NINETY REGION HEALTH
RESPONSE TEAM. MENTIONED
PROVIDE RAPID CHECKING.
IMMEDIATE MATH REALLY THE
PEOPLE IN PRISON AND MEDICAL IN
NINETEEN INCREASE ACCESS AND
ADEQUATE PP FOR OFFICE AND
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS AND STAFF.
DR CANCERS OF PEOPLE BEING
RELEASED FROM STATE PRISON TO
AYE AND THE IMMEDIATE RELEASE
ON THE FIELD AND I THINK
COUNTRY ON EARTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. WELL
GOING TO NUMBER. ONE AND
SEVENTY THREE ONE SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS GUARDIAN ON A LIVE IN
OAKLAND I DEMAND THE CDC ARE
GOING. TO GRANT NATURALLY
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON POPULATION OF
PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. A COMBINATION
SPREAD TO OTHER CRITICISM
THOUSAND POTENTIAL LONG TERM
COMPLICATIONS OR DEATH. IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO ENSURE SAFETY AND
MAINTAIN. THING OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED IN THEIR
OVERCROWDING CALIFORNIA I'M.
NINETY THE- JEFF IS THE IS
PARTIALLY IN BEEN COMMUNITY THE
COMPANY TO HARMED INCLUDING
WORKING BACKGROUND BE LIKE
DISABILITY DOCKING PEOPLE THAN
ON HOW WE HAVE AN ETHICAL TO
AFTER SAID THE LIVE LAW I'M
PEOPLE SPEND A THE VIRUS PRETTY
YOU TO THE OKAY. AMASSING AND
CURRENT TO CURE THE BIG HUMAN
DIGNITY FOR ALL OF YOUR CONTENT
GRANTHAM ALSO LEASES IT REDUCE
THE AND YOU WON'T BE OF OUR
GREAT ENSURES THE ARE LOOKING
GET ACTIONS SUPPORT BY PUBLIC
EXPERT WITH MANY ABILITY SISTER
BETTER BE SO PEARL. WE NEED THE
OUR POLICY. I WELL I KNOW MY
TIE THANK YOU. NEXT A LINE
THIRTY I THREE FIVE YEAR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH HI THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
COMMENT AND THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER TO PUTTING THIS I'M
COMMITTEE TOGETHER- I'VE I'VE
HEARD PEOPLE MENTION GOVERNOR
NEW FROM- REACHED GOVERNOR.
PHIL BUT I. HAD MY COULD BE HE
HAD LATE HIS. UNFORTUNATELY AND
MY NAME. AND IN OUR-
INCARCERATED POPULAR. SO I'M IN
THAT SHOULD BE A PRIOR TO THE
BILL BETTER HERE. AND I HOPE
THAT YOU GUYS TRYING THAT YOU
GUYS HEAR EVERYTHING THAT IS
BEING SHARED A PERCENTAGE STATE
I HEAR A LOT OF TALK. AND I
LIVE. AND NUMBER. PLANNED THE
GRUMPY. BUT THE PROTOCOL IF WE
HAVE NOT BEEN FOLLOWED
ACCORDINGLY AND THE FATHER WHO
HAD MAY HAVE LED. TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. I LOVE. MAY THANK
YOU HOWEVER IT NEVER IS THAT IT
HAS NOT ENOUGH SO I AGREE THAT
YEAR AGO TOWARD TWO MOMENT BEEN
THANK YOU THE PUBLIC WE ARE
GOING TO OR LAST TWO TO. PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SINCE WE'VE READ
GUARD LIMIT CAN HAVE TWO MORE
THEN WE MIGHT STAND. GO AHEAD
MODERATOR GIVE US OUR LAST.
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE NINE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR CAT
SIR AND I AM PHD PREPARED
JESTER NURSE UP ALSO. BECAUSE
MY LOVED ONE IS CURRENTLY OUT.
SO IF YOU EAT THREE. REALLY
SAYS IT THE TOP PRIORITY
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO NOW. CDC
ARE ALREADY. WE ARE IN NEED
HUNDRED. LAPTOP EVER OUT OF
CURRENT POPULATION OF ROUGHLY
FIVE HUNDRED AND AT SAN QUENTIN
FORTY IN MADE FACT TO BE LEAST.
ONLY DID YOU THE EARLY RELEASE
AT LEAST HUNDRED AND FIVE DAYS
ACCORDING TO THE MARSHALL THE
FEDERAL PRISONS SYSTEM IS
ALREADY RELEASING PRISONERS WHO
HAD EIGHTEEN MONTHS LEFT SO WHY
CAN'T YOU SEE OUR EXPAND EARLY
RELEASES TO A TWELVE. IN OTHER.
ESTABLISHED EARLY RELEASE FOR.
THE ACT WE HAVE THE ALTERNATIVE
CUT TO THE PROGRAM WHICH
TYPICALLY TAKES FOUR TO SIX
MONTHS TO PROCESS THAT COULD BE
BUT IT ANOTHER DAY THANK YOU
SEVEN NON VIOLENT ROLE THAT
TAKES SIX MONTHS. THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER WERE LAST IN PUBLIC.
WELL NOW THERE NUMBER HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO TWO SEVEN TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO I
WOULD LIKE. FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TRY TO SPEAK- THIRD. CENTERED
SKINNER FOR. PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND NOT ONLY FOR
DRAFTING THEN ALSO TO. ALLEN
DAILY TO- SECRETARY TIAS.
DOCTOR TELL. YOU HARD I AM I
ADVOCATING BOTH AT THE FOR THE-
AND IT. IS THE PEOPLE ARE IN
COURT FOR NOT THE PEOPLE I
WOULD ECHO WHAT IT WHAT DAY
THAT THE NEW TO BE A LOT OF
RELEASE BUT WE ARE REALLY NEED
TO INCLUDE THEN WE TO LOOK. WHO
ARE. BUT WHAT THE MAN YUP. IN
THERE SOME OTHER WAY TO SUPPORT
FOR PEOPLE THE TO OUR
INCARCERATED RIGHT NOW MANY
ALSO ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AS
SOMEONE WHO HAD WHEN I HERE BY
MAKE MANY KIND IT IT IT IS
DETRIMENTAL HELLO AND WE ARE
THINK OF WHEN THAT THE MARKET
WHAT WE CAN'T. WE NEED TO STOP.
I WOULD THINK YOU MIGHT EVER
REALLY MAIL THE CHANGES I'VE-
THANK YOU. I KNOW THAT THE WERE
MANY MANY MORE PEOPLE WHO
WANTED TO SPEAK AND I AM DEEPLY
SORRY THAT WE HAVE THIS HARD
STOP. I'M ALL OF MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WANTED TO HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE KNOW THAT YOU REPRESENT-
US UP TO ONCE IN FAMILY MEMBERS
IN- TIGHTER FACILITIES YOU
STAFF YOUR ELVES OR READ
STAFFER YOU JUST MAY BE CERTAIN
TO CALIFORNIA IS. HE SAID. WE
WILL. OR LETTER WE HAVE
RECEIVED MANY MY OFFICE ALONE
WHEN HAS A I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT BUT WE'VE RECEIVED MANY
MANY MANY EMAILS AND LETTERS.
WELCOME AND IF YOU HAVE CIVIC
WRECK. WE WELCOME THOSE. THIS
WAS OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT
HERE I SHARE WITH SENATE
MITCHELL THE- NOT SURE ABOUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT. WHAT
WAS DISCUSSED TODAY ACTUALLY
GETS PURSUED IN WILL HAVE TO
THINK MORE ABOUT THAT BUT I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CCR HAS HEARD I
WOULDN'T. THE CONCERN BY THE
MET. PROFESSIONALS BY THE LOW.
BY THE COMMUNITY AND SO MANY
OTHERS SO I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
HUNG IN THERE AND ALL THE ALL
THAT DISSIPATED AND THE STAFF
US THIS HEARING ALL. ALL THIS
THE STAFF. YES I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND I DO
NOT WANT THIS TO BE JUST TALK I
WANT TO SEE ACTION AS A RESULT
THE ENTIRE STATE DESERVES THAT
ISN'T ALL TO THAT. AND WE WILL
BE WE WILL FEEL THE APPROPRIATE
RESPECT ONCE WE SEE THE ACTION.
THAT I WILL CONCLUDE THIS
HEARING.